REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE ON TO COME
TO ORDER GOOD MORNING EVERY
SPONSOR THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IF
YOU'RE TO SOCIAL. DISTANCING A
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE BILLS
ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING HER
HEARING TO TAKE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WHY SOME MEMBERS ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
THREE MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. WE HEAR THEM HERE
WHERE ONE CENTER WILL
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. I JUST.
STERN COULD BE BUT MINUTES SO.
WE'LL MY DINNER HIMSELF AT THAT
TIME. THIS PROVIDED MONEY THE
COMMITTEE AND I. ARE ALSO
PURCHASED REMOTELY ARBOR
PURCHASE. PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONE OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED EVERY
TIME YOU. YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU REYES. USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM EVERYTHING. EACH
TIME YOU'LL BE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU TO. YOU YOU
WOULD LIKE TO NEW PLEASE SELECT
A NEW. YOU BEGIN TO SPEAK R. I.
T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK
ON MUTE. WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED AS HE SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE. YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW PUBLIC
ACCESS WE- HAVE MADE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO HEARING ROOM-CIVIC CENTER SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND- WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY FOR ALL MEMBERS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
PLEASE FOR THE PARTICIPATION
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN. AND I WILL MASSIVE
OUT TO THESE PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONCE AGAIN FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN SIX OF NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HEALTH
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR- COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
CUSICK FEEDBACK. YOU TOO BYE
SUBMIT YOUR DEVICE WHEN. YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING I'M PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR. YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WILL TO.
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING WHICH WHICH IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE ROOM. REMOTE
THAT. A SERVICE OR HAVE THE
CONNECTION PUBLIC COMMENT WILL
BE HEARD AFTER ALL DISCUSSION
ITEMS HAVE BEEN PRESENTED. WILL
ONLY EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT THEIR
HEARINGS. IN THIS CLOSE TO THE
SAME. MANNER AS DISCUSSED IN
MANY MANY. MAYBE SOME LACKED
SIMPLY. WERE JUST INTO THE NEW
YEAR OF. TOOLS FOR TECHNOLOGY
PLEASE BE RESPECT PATIENT. FULL
INTERESTED PARTY CAN BE HER
LAST. AFTER BELIEF. PRESENT
HERE. PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASK ON
COVERING YOU NOSE AND MOUTH ALL
TIMES- WE WILL ESTABLISH A CORE.
WHEN THAT IS DONE WE HAVE
THIRTY TWO MONTHS. ITEMS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FIVE. WHICH IS A- I AM TWENTY
FIVE PROP SIXTY EIGHT PROP
SIXTY EIGHT THIS IS THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY I BELIEVE WE
HAVE- ASSISTANT SECRETARY BRIAN
CASH GOOD MORNING SIR US
SECRETARY CASH YOU MAY BEGIN.
WARNING THIS IS BRING CASH I AM
THE ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND FINANCE WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE JENNIFER NORRIS-
DR JENNIFER NORRIS IT WILL BE
TESTIFYING AND ON THIS ITEM
AND- NANCY VOGEL WHO ALSO BE
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
JENNIFER. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER NORRIS DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THAT TO
RESOURCES AGENCIES REQUEST FOR
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT FUNDS FOR OUR
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S RIVERS
AND STREAMS AND WATERSHEDS
PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM FUNDS
MULTI BENEFIT WATER QUALITY
WATERSHED PROTECTION AND
RESTORATION PROJECTS TO IMPROVE
ENVIRONMENTAL CONDITIONS AND
HABITATS FOR CENTRAL VALLEY
SALMON STEELHEAD AND OTHER
SPECIES. MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATIVE FISH SPECIES ARE HIGHLY
THREATENED DUE TO HABITAT LOSS
AND DEGRADATION. I'M A CHANGES
EXACERBATING THESE THREATS WITH
LONGER AND MORE FREQUENT
DROUGHTS REDUCED SPRING FLOWS
AND HIGHER SUMMER TEMPERATURES.
THE REQUESTED FUNDS WILL HELP
US ADVANCE THE URGENT WORK OF
RESTORING THE CENTRAL VALLEY'S
RIVER SYSTEMS TO HELP RECOVER
THESE IMPERILED SPECIES. WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ALLOCATING THESE
FUNDS THROUGH A RIGOROUS AND
TRANSPARENT PUBLIC SOLICITATION
PROCESS PROJECT WILL BE
SCREENED FOR THEIR ABILITY TO.
QUICKLY DELIVER DURABLE
BENEFITS TO TARGET SPECIES AND
FOR SUPPORT BY A WIDE VARIETY
OF STAKEHOLDERS AND PARTNERS.
WE HAVE A BACKLOG OF MANY
WORTHY PROJECTS READY TO BE
FUNDED RIGHT AWAY AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS REQUEST AND ARE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE. OF THE PREPARED DEPUTY
NORRIS AND- PEACH THIRTY OF OUR
STAFF REPORT WE TALK ABOUT THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET YOU DID GET. WE DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF VOLUNTEER.
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS WE DID GET
SEVENTY MILLION OR FIFTY
MILLION OUT THE DOOR TWENTY
MILLION REMAINS. WHAT'S THE
PLAN ON THAT TWENTY MILLION IT
HASN'T BEEN ALLOCATED YET
BEFORE WE GIVE YOU. A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION MORE. IS
THAT. I'M SURE VALLEY I WAS
GONNA ASK THE SAME QUESTION BUT
I'LL ASK YOU. SURE WE'VE HELD
THAT BACK TO SUPPORT THE
KLAMATH DAM REMOVAL PROJECT WE
ACTUALLY DON'T EXPECT TO NEED
IT BUT WE'RE HOLDING IT FOR
THAT PROCESS. THANKS FOR THE
CLARIFICATION- BELIAU. LET'S
SEE. MISS OUR IS GOOD GOOD
MORNING NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN
AT EIGHT AM YES GOOD MORNING
MISTER THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN
SENATORS NICE TO SEE YOU AS
WELL- RETAILERS FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE SO
THE ISSUE HERE IS REALLY HOW
MUCH DISCRETION YOU WANT TO
GIVE TO THE ADMINISTRATION OVER
THESE FUNDS- THAT THE BOND
ALLOWS SEVERAL DIFFERENT USES
AND THEIR ADMINISTRATION ISN'T
PROPOSING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
KINDOF TO LIMIT THOSE USES SO-
WE WILL SUGGEST YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CONSIDER ADDING SOME
ADDITIONAL BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
THIS IS QUITE A LOT OF MONEY
AND NOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT REFLECTS THE
LEGISLATURE'S PRIORITIES OF. AS
WELL SO ADD THAT LANGUAGE COULD
INCLUDE REQUIRING A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS IT COULD INCLUDE
SOME OF THEIR PRIORITIES AROUND
WHICH THAT GRANT PROCESS SHOULD
BE STRUCTURED- AND HOW THE
FUNDS SHOULD BE USED AND THE
BOND ALSO ALLOWS THESE FUNDS TO
BE USED FOR FIVE SEPARATE STATE
WIDE COMMITMENTS THOSE ARE THE
SOLVENCY- THE KLAMATH
HYDROELECTRIC SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT AS AS A DOCTOR NORRIS
MENTIONED THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT IMPROVEMENT ACT THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER RESTORATION AND
SETTLEMENT ACT AND THE TAHOE
REGIONAL PLANNING COMPACT SO
SHOULD ANY OF THOSE FIVE BE
PRIORITIES FOR YOU AS WELL YOU
COULD DIRECT SOME OF THE FUNDS
TO BE USED- FOR THOSE SO GIVEN
GIVEN A LARGE AMOUNT OF MONEY.
WE THINK YOU MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER AND MAKING SURE THAT
YOUR PRIORITIES ARE MET AND
THERE ARE A HUNDRED TWENTY
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE ONE
COULD IMAGINE TIME COMING UP
WITH THAT A SIX PRIORITY THAT
WE HAVE SENATOR DOLLY YOU HAVE
A QUESTION I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I CONCUR WITH THOSE
STATEMENTS AND I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE. US MORE OVERSIGHT
IN THE LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS US
TO HAVE A LITTLE MORE
DISCRETION AND NOT JUST GIVE
ALL THE. THE AUTHORITY TO THE
AGENCY. ALL NOT SAYING CENTER.
ARE A HAND WE'RE GOING TO THIS
MATTER TO KEEP OPEN OBVIOUSLY
WE WENT TO HAVE ROBERT DISCUSS
WITH ADVENT ON IT AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR EVERYBODY'S
TESTIMONY- BEFORE MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY- SIX LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MISS ROY
WILL YOU PLEASE CALL THE- MY
CASKEY HERE I KASKY HERE DOLLY.
DOLLY HERE MCGUIRE YOUR WITH MY
HANDS. OKAY IT'S A QUORUM
ASSIST IS VERY. WHAT MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWO SIX THE POP
INVOICE LICENSE FUND AND
HEALTH- WE MAY SPEND THE MONEY.
I BELIEVE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE HAVE BRIAN
CASH AGAIN GOOD MORNING
ASSISTANT LEARNING SECTOR
SECRETARY. A DEMONSTRATION
PROPOSES THE ITEMS THAT ARE
LISTED IN THE AGENDA USING
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE
FUND- DURING THE BUDGET
DEVELOPMENT- WE HAD LEGAL
COUNSEL REVIEW THESE USES A
FIREMAN A LICENSE PLATE FUND
AND THEY FELT THAT THEY WERE
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THAT THEY
SUPPORT IDENTIFIABLE PROJECTS
PROGRAMS. AND ASSOCIATED COSTS
THAT MEET THE PURPOSES LISTED
IN THE YELP STATUTE IN ADDITION
THESE PROPOSALS ARE CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
FUNDED IN THE PAST INCLUDING
THE BOLSA CHICA RESTORATION
PROJECTS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET ACT. AND FUNDING FOR
THE SAN DIEGO CONSERVANCY'S
MAIN OPERATING COSTS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. AND WE'RE HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THAT'S FUNNY WE HAD LEGAL
COUNSEL WEIGH IN ON THIS ONE
ALSO LET'S GO TO THE ALLEY- WE
CONTINUE RIGHT ALONG WE HAVE-
TO. RETAILERS YES I- SO TO COME
FOR YOU ABOUT THIS ITEM THE
FIRST RICK THE FOR BACK. AND
UNDER MINISTRY PROPOSAL THERE
IS A RESERVE BUT IT'S REALLY
SMALL TWO POINT ONE MILLION.
ESTIMATED WHICH IS ONLY 3% OF
REVENUE SO THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE
IN THIS ECONOMY THERE THERE'S
QUITE A BIT OF UNCERTAINTY
AROUND EVERYTHING BUT ALSO
AROUND HOW MANY PEOPLE WALK TO
HAVE PRSONALIZED OR LEGACY
LICENSE PLATE SO THERE COULD BE
SOME REVENUE UNCERTAINTY. SO
JUST SOMETHING TO KEEP AN EYE
ON AND MAKE SURE YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT SMALL OF
A RESERVE AND PROJECTED. AND
THEN THE SECOND LARGER ISSUE IT
IS THE ONE THAT'S HIGHLIGHTED
EXTENSIVELY IN YOUR AGENDA
WHICH IS JUST THAT FOR SOME OF
THAT PROPOSED USES- THERE IS
SOME QUESTION OVER THE-
APPROPRIATENESS OF THE USE OF
THE FUND FOR THESE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THE
LARGEST ONE BEING THE MOVE OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES BUILDING.
BUT THEN ALSO SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
SAN DIEGO CONSERVANCY AS WELL
AS THE DELTA PROTECTION
COMMISSION. SO WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF WAYS YOU
COULD RESPOND TO ADDRESS THIS
THE FIRST AND PROBABLY MOST
STRAIGHT FORWARD WOULD BE TO
JUST SWAP THIS EMPF FUNDING FOR
GENERAL FUND ELSEWHERE IN THE
BUDGET FOR WHAT ARE SOME
CLEARLY ALLOWABLE USES- FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S TWENTY MILLION
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET FOR-
PARKS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WHICH A YEAR LATER IN YOUR
AGENDA. SO YOU COULD EASILY
JUST TAKE THIS FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION TOTAL FOR THESE THREE-
ITEMS THAT THAT'S CLEARLY- ANY
UP YEP ALLOWABLE USED PARKS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. SWAB THAT
AND THEN USE THAT GENERAL FUND
FOR THESE COSTS SO THAT WOULD
ALLOW YOU TO FIND ALL THESE
ACTIVITIES IF YOU WANTED TO NOT
SPEND ANYMORE FROM EITHER
SOURCE BUT HAVE SOME CLEARLY
ALLOWABLE- ALIGNMENT. ANOTHER
OPTION YOU COULD PURSUE WOULD
BE FOR THE NATURAL RESOURCES
MOVING BILL THAT THAT BUILDING
MADE AT LEAST. TO TRY AND
SPREAD THE COSTS ACROSS ALL OF
THE FUNDS SOURCES THAT SUPPORT
THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEPARTMENT SO GENERAL FUND YEP
YEP AND ALL THE SPECIAL FUNDS.
AND THAT THAT SEEMS. LIKE A
MORE DEFENSIBLE USE SO FIVE
FUNDS TO SUPPORT OF THE ACT. IT
WOULD BE MORE. COMPLEX AND
COULD RESULT IN IT JUST COST
FOR ALL THOSE DIFFERENT. FUNDS
ALTHOUGH USE LESS YEP YEAH IF
YOU'RE CAN. ABOUT THE FUN BACK
SO YOU HAVE SOME OPTIONS HERE
TO ADDRESS- SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED.
WHEN I WAS READING THE STAFF
REPORT IT BROUGHT ME BACK TO
LAW SCHOOL ONE WE WOULD THINK
SOMEBODY WOULD MAKE THIS
MINORITY ARGUMENT TO SAY WELL
IT COULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THESE. SERVICES THERE SO
THEREFORE THAT'S THE LINK AND-
YOU LOOK AROUND YOU THINK YOU
TAKE A BIG DEEP BREATH- THANK
YOU FOR THAT INPUT. HELPS
CLARIFY. THE ISSUE BEFORE THE-
SUBCOMMITTEE CENTER DOLLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I.
FIRST OFF LIKE THIS COMMENDED
THE ITEMS IDENTIFIED ARE
CLEARLY FOR THE ENVIRONMENT I
HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH- BUT THE
ONES THAT ARE MOVING FOLKS FROM
ONE BUILDING TO ANOTHER IF YOU
TOLD THAT TO THE PEOPLE WHO BUY
THESE LICENSE PLATES THAT THEY
WERE. FUNDING MOVEMENT OF STAFF
FROM ONE BUILDING TO ANOTHER I
THINK YOU WOULD FIND THAT THEY
WOULD PROBABLY NON RENEW.
BECAUSE I THINK THEY REALLY
WANT THE- MONEY TO GO TO THE
ENVIRONMENT AND SELL FOR THOSE
REASONS. I CAN KERR WE SHOULD
TAKE IT ON THE GENERAL FUND.
AND ALLOW THE LICENSE PLATE
FUND GO TO WHERE IT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO GO THANK
YOU. NOW STAFF RECOMMENDATION
ON THIS ISSUE. MEMBERS IS THIS
SERVICE. SPLIT THIS IN HALF
HOLD MEMBERS- ARE HORRIBLE
ITEMS AS N. WHICH FOR- THE IS-
THE MOVE FOR THAT- NATURAL
RESOURCES WITH IS A LIE SURE
THE LITTLE THAT'S A- BILL. THE
DELTA PROTECT A PROTECTION I
COMMISSION WHICH IS- AND IN THE
SAN DIEGO RIVER CONSERVANCY THE
HISSES SMALL MOUTH I GET THAT
RIGHT ACMD CORRECT IT AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS VICE CHAIRED
DAHLIAS AND NUMBER EIGHT EIGHT
THE ACTUAL. SO THE SAFE BET FOR
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES
WHICH SHOULD BE THE BOLSA CHICA
LOW LAND RESTORATION PROJECT
THE SAN DIEGO- CONSERVANCY ONE
TIME- APPROPRIATION SAID TO YOU.
GRAPH ON WATER QUALITY AND IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN BASIN WATERSHED
SO- WE'RE GOING TO PARTIALLY
HOLD THIS MATTER AND PARTIALLY
APPROVE IT AND WILL DO A
SEPARATE VOTE A SEPARATE
DISCUSSION IF THAT'S ALRIGHT
WITH EVERYBODY. OKAY VERY GOOD
THANK YOU- DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION P. ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SEVEN FORMALLY KNOWN AS
DOCTOR CAL JIM OVERSIGHT. LAST
YEAR THERE WAS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY EIGHT POSITIONS OVER A
THREE YEAR PERIOD WE LANDED ON
TWENTY FIVE AND NOW WE'RE BACK
FOR A TWENTY SIX IS SET FORTH
IN THE STAFF REPORT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE A DIRECTOR. SHOULD
BOSNIA. GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
pI'M I'M DAVID SHOULD BE EASY
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION AND
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THIS
MORNING TO PRESENT OUR BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL- THIS IS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA GEOLOGIC ENERGY
MANAGEMENT DIVISION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
FORMALLY KNOWN AS DOCTOR- WE
ARE REQUESTING TWENTY SIX
POSITIONS AND A BASS LINE
INCREASE OF JUST OVER FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE OIL GAS AND GEOTHERMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FINE. AND HAVE
THIS PHASED IN OVER THREE YEARS
FUNDING THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
HELP CAL JIM CONTINUE
TRANSFORMING ITS MISSION TO
FOCUS ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY. OVER THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS CAL JAM IS MADE GREAT
STRIDES IN THIS TRANSFORMATION
HOWEVER THERE'S MUCH MORE WORK
TO BE DONE. AND THIS PROPOSAL
CREATES MORE CAPACITY FOR CAL
JIM TO CONTINUE ON THIS PATH.
SPECIFICALLY THE PROPOSAL WILL
INCREASE STAFF PRESENCE ON THE
FIELD TO PERFORM INSPECTIONS
AND CONTINUE THE QUEST TO
WITNESS ALL OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS. ESPECIALLY THOSE
TAKING PLACE AT CRITICAL WELL
SITES NEAR SENSITIVE RECEPTORS.
THIS INCLUDES ALSO COLLECTING
INFORMATION AND J. S. STAND UP
FOR RELATED FACILITIES AND
PIPELINES. THE PROPOSAL WOULD
ALLOW CALCIUM TO CONTINUE
ENHANCING IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
FIVE FIFTY ONE AND AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN TO ENSURE SUFFICIENT
BONDING IS IN PLACE OF THE
STATE DOES NOT HAVE TO ASSUME
LIABILITY. FOR ORPHANED OR
ABANDONED WELLS AND RELATED
FACILITIES. IT WILL ALSO HELP
ENSURE IDYLLWILD MANAGEMENT
PLANS AND FEES ARE SUBMITTED IN
A TIMELY AND ACCURATE MANNER.
IT WILL STRENGTHEN CAL GEMS
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM INCLUDING
ISSUANCE OF ENFORCEMENT ORDERS
FROM THE SUPERVISOR. STAFF
CAPACITY CREATED BY THIS
PROPOSAL WILL ALSO HELP CAL JIM
FURTHER DEVELOP PRIORITIES TO
PLUG AND ABANDON WELL SCIENCE
AND ATTENDED FACILITIES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE NEAR SENSITIVE
RECEPTORS. THERE ARE ALSO BE
CAPACITY TO IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY THROUGH INCREASED
DATA INTEGRITYAND SUPPORT OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH RULE MAKING
CURRENT CURRENTLY UNDERWAY AS
WELL AS FUTURE RULE RULE MAKING.
FINALLY THE PROPOSAL HELPS CAL
JAM IMPLEMENT COMPONENTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
DECARBONIZE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR. THIS IS A THREE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION THAT CONSISTS OF
TWELVE NEW POSITIONS IN YEAR
ONE TEN POSITIONS IN YEAR TWO
AND FOUR POSITIONS IN THE FINAL
YEAR HERE THREE. WE DECIDED TO
TAKE A MORE MEASURED APPROACH
WITH THIS PROPOSAL DUE TO THE
CONTINUING ECONOMIC STRUGGLES
RESULTING FROM THE KOVIN
PANDEMIC. NONETHELESS THESE ARE
CRITICAL POSITIONS FOR THE
EVOLUTION F CAL JAM AND ITS
ABILITY TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE
STRONGEST REGULATIONS ON OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION ENACTED
NATIONALLY. I'M GLAD TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU
BEFORE WE GET TO THE L. A. L.
STAFF REPORT HIGHLIGHTS THAT
WE'VE GOT THE SHELL WELLS IN
THE MAY WELLS. SHELL CHAU YEAH
WHICH SHALL WITH. ARE MAY WITH.
A CAN YOU. GIVE US SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THAT IT'S A
JENNIFER THERE'S- CERTAIN
PROCEDURES THAT USE YOU.
WITNESS AND BE THERE IN MAKE IT
POPULAR CENTER K. A WELL OR
STUFF LIKE THAT THE LIKE FIFTY
THREE WELL THAT YOU MAY WITNESS
HOW DO WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
STEP. HOW IS THAT GOING TO.
HARM OF BE. WORKED UP A I
ASSUME THAT THE- LIKES THAT K.
JIM SO THERE WATCHING MY
HAPPENING TO EVERY COOPER.
RIGHT I MEAN THEY DON'T WANNA
PAY FOR IT BUT WOULD LIKE HAVE
SOMEBODY THERE- TELL ME DID
THIS THIS WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU
CAN DO FROM A WORK. OUR LAYOUT
BUT PERSPECTIVE. SO IT DOES
INCREASE OUR OUR FIELD
PRESENCE- AND YOU KNOW IT MADE
IT LEAN- THE WITNESS SCENE- WE
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO DO ALL
WITNESSING ALL THE TIME-
UNFORTUNATELY AND SO IN THOSE
CASES- IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
WITNESS- IT THEN IT'S
BASICALLY- THEY ARE THE WITNESS
SCENE IS WAIVED OR- THAT THE
PROPOSAL- THAT THE STEP IN THE
PROCESS THAT THEN THE-
OPERATORS UNDER IS MOVED ON- IN
SO THIS GIVES US THE CAPACITY
TO DO- MUCH MORE WITNESSING
THEN THEN WE'RE ABLE TO DO
TODAY. AND PRESUMABLY THE
INDUSTRY WOULD LIKE TO WHEN
THEY'RE READY TO GO IN THERE AT
THIS PLACE WHERE THEY NEED TO
HAVE IT WITNESSED AND- OBSERVE
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
STAFF HERE SO THAT THAT COULD
BE APPROVED AND THEN THEY CAN
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT A NEXT
BUSINESS. BECAUSE IF THE IF YOU
CAN'T GET. BECAUSE OF OUR
STAFFING PER STAGE HAVE TO WAIT
IF IT'S A SHELL WITNESS THEY
JUST HAVE TO WAIT RIGHT CAN YOU
CAN WAIVE THAT WITNESS- I WILL
ASK- MY- ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY
CLAYTON HASS TO CLARIFY THAT I-
I WHAT I WANT I WANT TO SAY
THAT IT'S THERE'S A PERIOD OF
TIME WHERE. WE CAN- WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO WITNESS AND IF WE
MOVE BEYOND THAT PERIOD OF
TIME- WHERE WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
HAVE FIELD PRESENCE AND THEN
THE- THE WITNESSING REQUIREMENT
IS WAIVED. S. DEPUTY ARE
INSURED THIS IS CLAYTON AWESOME
ACTING CHIEF DEPUTY- YEAH IT
WHAT DIRECTOR SHOULD MAYES
INSTEAD IS CORRECT. WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GO OUT AND WITNESSES
SHALL WITNESSES BUT WE CAN ALSO
WAIVE THE SHOT WITNESSES. AND A
LOT OF THOSE CHOICES ARE
DISCRETIONARY IF IT'S AN
OPERATOR THAT DOESN'T HAVE A
LOT OF COMPLIANCE ISSUES. AND
WE HAVE A MORE CRITICAL WELL
THAT IS A MAY WITH MAY WITNESS
TEST- WE HAVE TO MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION ON WHAT WELL IS
MORE CRITICAL TO ACTUALLY
WITNESS. SO IF WE DO WAIVE A
TEST WE MAKE THAT DISCRETIONARY
DECISION ON WE FEEL THAT IT'S
BETTER TO WAVE. A SHALL THAN A
MATE IN SOME CASES WE TRIED TO
GET OUT TO ALL OF THEM WE JUST
DO NOT HAVE THE STAFFING
AVAILABLE TO GET TO EVERY
SINGLE. SHALL WITNESS TESTS AND
IN SOME CASES THE MAY WITNESSES
ARE MORE CRITICAL IN OUR
OPINION TO GO OUT AND WITNESS
THEN THE SHELVES BECAUSE IT
DID. ASSEMBLY THEN THE TOTALITY
OF THE IMPACT IT WOULD HAVE ON
THE COMMUNITY AND WHAT AND WHAT
IS ACTUALLY BEING. BEING DONE.
INTERESTING BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE. THERE'S A LOT OF-
PEOPLE THAT HAVE- OPINIONS
ABOUT CALCIUM FEATHER AND
WHETHER THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING
IT IS INTERESTING THAT BY
SPENDING MORE MONEY. YOU GET TO
DO THE WORK THAT THAT. PEOPLE
EXPECT TO BE DONE BUT NOT
HAVING IT THAT DISCRETIONARY.
PROVISION ALLOWS THAT NOBODY'S
WATCHING THIS. THE C. MEMBERS.
AS HE SAID STERN- CENTER DOLLAR.
THE QUESTION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SO OFF I NEED TO JUST-
YOU KNOW WE HAVE AYE IS T.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY TO- ISSUE
TWENTY. SO OFF WE KNOW LAST
YEAR WE GAVE YOU- THAT THE TO
HIRE I BELIEVE WAS TO SEVEN
POSITION CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT
HAS HAPPENED IN THE CURRENT-
ALLOCATION FROM LAST YEAR. IT
WHICH WAS UNDER ISSUE TEN AND
HOW MANY FOLKS YOU GOT HIRED UP
AND COMING ON THE JOB. SO TODAY
WE'VE HIRED THREE AND WE HAVE-
ANNOUNCED AND THEN CLOSED ALL
THE POSITIONS- FROM LAST YEAR'S
B. C. P. AND WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS OF. REVIEWING THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND STARTING THE
INTERVIEW PROCESS FOR THE
REMAINING POSITIONS. SO OUT OF
TWENTY FIVE POSITION YOU HAVE
THREE FILLED. AT THREE TODAY
YES AND YOU'RE ASKING FOR
ANOTHER FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN. FOR AN
ADDITIONAL. TWENTY FIVE I
BELIEVE IT IS. SO WHY IS YOUR
RESEARCH ISN'T HOW WHAT THE
PROBLEM HOW CAN YOU GET THESE
FOLKS HIGHER I MEAN WE'RE CAN
TO MY IT'S IN MY IT'S A- YOU
KNOW IT'S A FEEL GOOD OF. THAT
WERE KEEPING OUR- RESOURCES BUT
WE DON'T HAVE THE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND. WELL LAST YEAR- WEEK WE
GET RIGHT INTO THE HEAD WINDS
OF PROGRAMS AND I'M HAVING TO
WORK FROM HOME AND- IN THAT
REMOTE ENVIRONMENT- WEEK WE GET
BECAUSE- WITH WITH THE FACT
THAT. WE WERE ABLE TO GO BACK
INTO THE OFFICE- THAT WE WOULD
START THE PROCESS AND- WHEN WE
WHEN WE REALIZED IN THE SUMMER
THAT- GOING BACK TO THE OFFICE
WASN'T GOING TO BE A REALITY
ANYTIME SOON WE GET STARTED
PROCESS. ONE OF THE CONCERNS WE
HAD IS THAT MANY OF THESE
POSITIONS REQUIRE TRAINING AND
SO. ON THE REST OF THE BRAINY-
VIRTUALLY BECOMES- A LOT MORE
DIFFICULT NONETHELESS WE KNEW
WE HAD TO GET THE PROCESS
STARTED SO WE GET START. I'M
WRITING THOSE POSITIONS AND
POSTING THEM TOWARD THE END OF
THE YEAR. SO- YOU WERE SO TO
REAP. BACK AND- OF YOUR PER-
WE'RE THAT REPORT OUT. IT'S
STILL PENDING. SO IS IT SAFE TO
SAY THEN THAT. WE ONLY REALLY
HAVE THREE PEOPLE THERE AND I
UNDERSTAND CO BUT I KNOW THAT
TO I DO A LITTLE HOMEWORK TO
THIRTEEN OF THE FULL TIME STAFF
ARE CURRENTLY DIVERTED DOING
COVERT CONTRACT TRACING. AND
THEN THERE'S 80% OF YOUR OF
YOUR FULL STAFF WHICH IS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED VACANCY SO THERE
SEEMS TO BE. SOME ISSUE HERE.
AND- YOU KNOW GETTING THE FOLKS
TO DO GETTING THE FOR THE
EMPLOYEES OUT THERE TO DO THE
WORK THAT WE'VE- THAT THE BOOK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS YOU
KNOW BUT- FUNDED. BY ORDERED
ACTUALLY THE OIL PRODUCERS ARE
FUNDED SO. I FIND IT QUITE
INTERESTING THAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR MORE RESOURCES WE HAVE AN
EVEN. NUMBER ONE GOT THE REPORT
BACK NUMBER TWO WE HAVEN'T HAD
THE VACANCIES FROM LAST YEAR
SO- IS IT MAKES SENSE TO ME WHY
WE WOULD CONTINUE TO JUST POUR
MONEY INTO A PROGRAM THAT WE
DON'T HAVE. THE FOLKS UP AND
RUNNING ON THE ON THE LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I THINK IT'S JUST NOT
PRUDENT WE SHOULD WAIT. AND GET
THE POSITIONS THAT WE- THAT WE
BONDED LAST YEAR BILL BEFORE WE
GO ADDING. MORE BURDEN. UPON
THE- THE PRODUCERS TO YOU KNOW
PAY FOR THESE. ADDITIONAL STAFF
THAT AREN'T EVEN THERE. I'M WE
HAVE THE L. A. L. ROW MAYBE YOU
COULD RIM OVER I KNOW THAT-
SENATOR JACK'S HAS A
REQUIREMENT ON OF PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING WELLS WITH MISS
LIMóN WHO'S NOW IN THE SENATE
CENTER STERN HAS A CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS AND OPERATION OF-
A NATURAL GAS STORAGE THERE'S A
THERE'S BEEN A FLURRY OF
LEGISLATION TO REQUIRE MORE
OVERSIGHT REGULATIONS TOP
PLEASE PROCEED. FREE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- YES UNITS ROW
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. AND WE FIND THAT THE
RESOURCES REQUESTED AN
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS ARE
REASONABLE BASED ON THE
EXISTING BACKLOG OF FIELD
INSPECTIONS GAP BETWEEN
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IN CAPACITY.
AS WELL AS THE VOLUME OF
INFORMATION AND DATA REQUESTS
FROM THE PUBLIC. AND IN
ADDITION ASKED THE CHAIR
MENTIONED READ RECENT
REGISTRATION HAS INCREASED A
LOT OF OVERSIGHT IS
REQUIREMENTS. WHICH HAS
INCREASED THE DIVISION'S
WORKLOADS. HOWEVER CALLAGY I
AND YOU FEEL AND OVERSIGHT
WORKLOAD IS SOMEWHAT UNCERTAIN
AND CAN CHANGE OVER TIME FOR A
MULTIPLE NUMBER OF REASONS AND-
FACTORS THAT CAN AFFECT THE
DIVISION'S WORKLOADS COULD
INCLUDE- MARKET CHANGES TO
GEOGRAFIA PRODUCTION AND
COMPLEXITY OF. REVIEWS AND ALSO
JUST THE UNCERTAINTY RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTING AND YOU PROGRAMS
RELATED TO THE RECENT
LEGISLATION. THAT WE RECOMMEND-
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED A
BUDGET REQUEST TO MEET
INCREASED WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED-
WITH THESE CHANGES- HOWEVER WE
FIND AND WE FIND THAT THE
RESURCES ARE JUSTIFIED ON THE
WORKLOAD BASIS AND ARE
CONSISTENT WITH RECENT
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS- HAVE
RESIDENTS THAT AMOUNT IN THE
FIELD AND OVERSIGHT WORKLOAD
COULD VERY DEPENDING ON SEVERAL
FACTORS- AND- AT. AS UP AS-
SENATE ALI MENTIONED YOU KNOW
AND- THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
AND YOU POSITION- AND THAT THAT
DIVISION HAS RECEIVED IN
RECENT. YEARS WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPTS SOME
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
THAT REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
DIVISION'S PERFORMANCE IN
SEVERAL AREAS OF OPERATIONS. BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE AFTER AT FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE. SOME MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY ON- HOW. THE
DIVISION IS PERFORMING AND-
YEAH. ALL EGGNOG CENTER STERN
IS WITH US MORNING SAID STERN
CENTER TO FACT YOU SO YOU JUST
PROVED TO OF THE PROBLEM WE DID
REQUIRE THEM TO REPORT BACK AND
YOU'RE SAYING WE SHOULD ADD
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE TO REPORT
BACK AGAIN. THAT'S WHAT'S WRONG
WITH GOVERNMENT IS THAT IF IT
DOESN'T WORK WE JUST KEEP
ADDING MORE MONEY TO IT EVEN
THOUGH WE DON'T. GET THE
PERFORMANCE. AT THE END OF THE
DAY THE LEGISLATURE. HAS FUNDED
HAS FORCED THE FUNDING ON THIS
PROGRAM AND IT'S NOT GIVING US
THE RESULT WE'RE ASKING FOR.
DON'T WE GONNA DO. WE'RE GONNA.
ADD ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS TO THE TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS WE PUT UP LAST YEAR
WE ONLY HAVE THREE POSITIONS
FILLED. NOBODY WOULD LAST AND
PRIVATE BUSINESS DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THE- THE
PUBLIC DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
JUST BECAUSE WE HAD MONEY TO IT
DOESN'T MEAN THE PROBLEMS
GETTING THAT THE REQUIREMENTS
THAT WE'RE ASKING FOR GETTING
FULFILL. SO I THINK WE NEED A
TOTAL OVERHAUL OF THIS PROGRAM
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET THE
PHYSICIANS FILLED. THAT WE
ALREADY ALLOCATED THE FUNDS
FOR. BEFORE WE GO ALLOCATING
MORE FUNDS FOR MILLION DOLLARS
BY THE WAY. AND ANOTHER TWENTY
FIVE POSITIONS IT'S INSANE.
MAKES NO SENSE. WELL THAT WAS
OUR LEGISLATIVE VALLI'S LET'S
GO TO FINANCE MISS MCGUIRE
YOU'RE ON THE LINE YOU HAVE
YOUR HAND UP- YES. IT LIKE.
MORNING LEVINE AGUIAR-CURRY
BERMAN I FINANCE- JUST. VACANCY
IS- AS AS SURE SHE BE USING IT
CORRECT IT AFFECTS- APARTMENTS
ARE A LITTLE HIGHER AND BOARD
THOSE. BUT I WOULD ALSO ADD
THAT- YOU KNOW THAT FIVE
POSITION GRANT LAST YEAR SIX
WERE. FOR ALLEGE MANDATE- THE
ARE VERY YOU KNOW THE SKILLS IN
THOSE ARE ON OR CATCH. THEY
REQUIRE A STAFF OF THE. WELL
THIS IS A NEW KIND OF SKILL
SET- AND SO IT'S TAKING A
LITTLE BIT LONGER THAN USUAL I
AM TIRED OF THOSE DECISIONS.
THE DECISION TO CLOSE THEIR-
THEY ARE ACTIVELY INTERVIEWING-
APPLICANTS THEY HAD A AN
INCREDIBLY- WIDE RANGE OF
INTERESTS- FOR THESE POSITIONS.
SO I WOULD JUST KIND OF YOU
KNOW THAT AS YOU AS YOU
CONSIDER AT ALL. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR- THAT IN THAT SIXTEEN
POSITIONS THAT YOU'VE
ARTICULATED THIRD NECESSARY
SOME OF THEM ARE REQUIRED UNDER
SB FOUR SIX THREE BY SENATOR
STERN CENTER STERN. YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- YEAH I HAD MY QUESTIONS
ARE REALLY JUST ABOUT THE
STATUS OF THE VARIOUS REPORTS
HE REQUIRED HIS BUILDING ON.
CENTER DOLLARS LINE OF
QUESTIONING THERE BUT-
SPECIFICALLY- YEAH YOU
MENTIONED THIS BEFORE SIXTY
THREE REPORT BUT I'M ALSO I
WANTED LIKE TO KNOW THE STATUS
OF THE REPORT ON THE ISLAND
ABANDONED WELL STUDY REQUIRED
BY HOLDING LEGISLATION- THE
WELL STIMULATION STUDY REQUIRED
INTEREST BEFORE. WHICH BY THE
WAY AS BEFORE IS THAT FRACKING
BILL WE PASSED. NOT LAST YEAR
OR THE YEAR BEFORE THAT BUT
ACTUALLY WHEN I WAS STILL STAFF
IN THIS BUILDING- OVER FIVE
YEARS AGO- SO. WAITING ON SOME
WELL STEM REPORTING AND THEN
LASTLY THE STATUS OF THE U. ICY
REPORT THE UNDERGROUND
INJECTION CONTROL PROGRAM.
WHICH WE'VE BEEN AUDITED ON
FOUND IN NON COMPLIANCE SEVEN
STILL HAVE YET TO IDENTIFY-
FULLY ALL OF ARE EXEMPTED
AQUIFER'S SO- IT'S ABOUT STAT
ON THOSE. THREE CORE REPORTS
CHARACTER SHOULD PLEASE ANYONE
TAKE A CRACK ON THE REPORT CARD.
YOUR YEAH THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND YES WE- WE HAVE
THOSE REPORTS IN PROCESS- AND
WE HOPE TO HAVE THEM TO YOU
VERY SHORTLY- WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT WERE BEHIND SCHEDULE BUT-
THEY ARE THEY ARE VERY CLOSE TO
THE FINISH LINE IN AND WILL BE
IN YOUR HANDS AND. OKAY SO-
I'LL TAKE THAT SOON- I GUESS
MEETING BEFORE THIS BUDGET
CONVERSATION IS UP I MEAN I'M-
IT IS THIS IS THIS ADDITIONAL
STAFFING SHOULD I JUST WANT YOU
ALL TO MANAGE OUR EXPECTATIONS
YOU'RE LIKE IS THIS ADDITIONAL
STAFFING ACTUALLY GONNA HELP.
SURVIVE SOME OF THE RECTIFY
SOME OF THE- GAPS IN BOTH
REPORTING THE LEGISLATURE AND
PUBLIC REPORTING- I THINK OF
THE- YOU KNOW THE STATUS OF THE
WELL FINDER- RIGHT NOW IN SOME
OF THE- HITCHES IN GETTING.
ACCURATE INFORMATION EVEN ON
LOCATION OF SOME OF THE SITES
OUT TO THE PUBLIC BUT THANK YOU
CAN YOU SET OUR EXPECTATIONS
FOR WHAT YOU EXPECT TO GET OUT
OF THIS NEW TRUNCHEONS. OF
FINDING IS THIS REALLY ABOUT
BUYING TIME SHE CAN KEE
RECRUITING- I DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
I HEARD THE OSA THIS IS A NEW
LINE OF WORK SO IT TAKES MORE
PATIENCE PLUGGING AND
ABANDONING WELLS IS NOT A NEW
LINE OF WORK TO MY
UNDERSTANDING THERE'S BEEN.
THOUSANDS IF NOT MILLIONS OF
WELLS PLUGGED AND ABANDONED
OVER THE YEARS SO I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S- WHAT'S SO
NEW HERE AND IT JUST. YEAH WHAT
WHAT TO EXPECT THAT IS THE
MONEY- INDEED IT'LL GIVE US YOU
KNOW NEW CAPACITY THAT WE DON'T
HAVE TODAY AND THE- AND THE
ABILITY TO YOU KNOW WORK
FASTER- BECAUSE WE'RE ABLE TO
SPREAD THAT WORKLOAD OVER MORE
PEOPLE- SO OUR ANTICIPATION IS
THAT IN FACT WE WILL BE.
GETTING YOU KNOW WORKED ON. IN
A IN A FASTER. MANNER IT'S HARD
TO KNOW- YOU KNOW PROSPECTIVELY
YOU KNOW HOW THIS IS ALL GOING
TO MANIFEST BUT THAT'S THAT'S
THE EXPECTATION AND
ANTICIPATION. OKAY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE A
YES HI MISTER WIRE YOUR
RECOGNIZE. LET'S NOT. LET GO
YES NO IT SAYS I THINK YOU HAVE
ANOTHER DEVICE THAT SAUNDERS
SAID AND SOMEBODY ON THE PANEL
HAVE A SECOND DEVICE ON BECAUSE
IT'S YOUR GARBLED MIS MCGUIRE.
OKAY SO I DIDN'T GET THAT PHONE
ON KILL THE PHONE. NO. M. IT'S-
CONNECTION SO. I. T. SERVICES
YOUR CONNECTION. I GUESS WHAT
WHILE WE'RE WAITING TO RESOLVE
THAT SO YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
GOING YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE MORE
THROUGHPUT HOW QUICKLY DO YOU
EXPECT TO FILL ALL THE
OUTSTANDING POSITIONS THAT ARE
OPEN AS WELL AS THE NEW
POSITIONS ANTICIPATED WHAT IT
WHAT'S YOUR WHAT'S YOUR
INTERNAL TIME FRAME FOR THAT MR
SPAS IN. SO THAT TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS FROM LAST YEAR- THEY
HAVE ALL CLOSED AND WE ARE
REVIEWING APPLICATIONS AND
GETTING READY FOR THE
INTERVIEW- PHASE- FILLING THOSE
POSITIONS- SO. I WOULD EXPECT
THAT TO HAPPEN IN THE NEXT-
THREE MONTHS OR SO- TO GET A
MALL TO GET HIM FILLED- AND
THEN IF FOR SOME REASON YOU
KNOW WE DON'T FIND- YOU KNOW
FOR ANY OF THE POSITIONS- YOU
KNOW SOMEONE QUALITY ARE TRULY
QUALIFIED TO FILL THE POSITION
IF WE WILL HAVE TO REPOST THAT
BUT RIGHT NOW OUR TO. OUR
EXPECTATION IS TO IS TO MOVE
ALONG IN THE PROCESS AND BE
DONE IN. ABOUT ROUGHLY THE NEXT
I WOULD SAY THREE MONTHS OR SO.
OKAY THREE MONTHS OR SO. MISTER
GORE YOU BECKER. IS MISS ONE
FROM A FINANCE. THIS REGARDLESS
TRIED AGAIN. NO NOW I DON'T
KNOW I CAN'T TELL. IT'S NOT
MUCH BETTER. LET'S SEE TO SEE
IF YOU CAN PUNCH THROUGH TALK
FOR A BIT AND IF I STOP YEAH
STOP YEAH. IT'S EASY. TO JUST
JUST. IT WAS IS NOT START
MOVING TOWARD THAT'S NOT GONNA
WORK- WE'RE GONNA DO WE CAN
CORRESPOND WE CAN DO A FOLLOW
UP HERE- AND DIGGING A LITTLE
DEEPER ON THIS FRONT I JUST I
KNOW IT'S IS A HUGE ISSUE- NOT
JUST IN MY BACKYARD IN LOS
ANGELES WITH ALL THE URBAN OIL
SITES BUT- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- AND- THE TRUST HAS BEEN
BROKEN OVER THE YEARS AND WE'VE
REALLY TRIED TO REFORM CAL JAM
THERE. TURN IT BACK INTO
SOMETHING THAT HAS THAT KIND OF
SHINE TO IT- AND I KNOW WE
BROUGHT YOU IN MR SHOULD
BOSNIAN TO BE OVER A REFORMER
IN TO PUSH THROUGH AND THERE'S
A LOT OF CULTURE AND MISSION
OVER ALL THIS ARE YOU ACURRENT
AND THAT'S NOT EASY WORK
NECESSARILY BUT- WHAT WE HAVE
TO BE DEMANDING OF YOU AND YOU
KNOW THE GAS RIGHT NOW OR ARE
SENDING US ALL BACK AND FRANKLY
MAKING IT LOOK MORE. LIKE THE
OLD DOG THE DOG OR A BOLD SO
I'M JUST I WOULD ADD YOU KNOW
I'M I'M I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
PUMPING THE BRAKES TO GET ON
FUNDING AND I'M FRANKLY
FRUSTRATED THAT WE'RE HERE
TODAY TALKING NOW ABOUT AN
AUGMENTATION WHEN LAST YEAR WE
ABANDON THAT AUGMENTATION WE
COULD HAVE BEEN DOING THAT. ON
THE FRONT END AND THE FACT IT
INDUSTRY ALSO OPPOSE THAT
AUGMENTATION BUT NOW IS
PROBABLY WISHING THEY HAD IT SO
THAT PERMITS COULD BE PROCESS
THAT THINGS COULD BE
INVESTIGATED BECAUSE IT ALL
SLOWS DOWN SO I THINK IT'S IN
EVERYBODY'S INTEREST NOT JUST
THE FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES TO
GET A FUNCTIONAL CAL GEM I DO
SEE WORKING HERE BUT I GOTTA
JUST SAY IT'S- IT FEELS LIKE.
THERE'S A DISCONNECT WITH WHAT
THE PUBLIC WANTS TO SEE AND
WHEN WE LOOK AT YOU KNOW GAPS
ON WELL MAPS AND YOU START TO
GET SUSPICIOUS BECAUSE LIKE YOU
KNOW SOMETHING'S GOING ON DOWN
THE STREET AND YOU DON'T KNOW
QUITE WHAT IT IS AN ABANDONED
WELL THAT JUST HASN'T MADE THE
CUT LIKE HOW DOES THE ZONING
ADMINISTRATOR IN A CITY OR A
COUNTY DEAL WITH. THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION A LOT OF IS STILL
ON PAPER AND IT'S NOT EVEN
DIGITIZE THIS POINT IT'S A
HEADACHE ON ADA COMPLIANCE.
EVEN FOR PUBLISHING SOME OF THE
STUFF ON THE INTERNET WE KNOW-
THEY HAD A BUT I JUST I WANT TO
SEE THAT MAY. ENERGY FOCUS EXIT-
THE PUBLIC'S GONNA DEMAND
YOURSELF THANKS FOR LETTING ME
GIVE ME A MINUTE ON THE SOAP
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD THIS WE KNOW THAT THE KOBE
LAST. MAY OR JUNE WE'RE MAKING
THESE DECISIONS ON WHAT TO FUND
WHAT THE NOT FOUND THERE WAS A
LOT OF THE THANKS ABOUT. THE
ECONOMY CRASHING AND NOT HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY WAS THERE BUT
MISSED I'M NOT GOING TO.
REPRESENT THE ADMINISTRATION
MASTERS I DIRECTED US TO PAUSE
AND DO YOU HAVE. ANYTHING ELSE
TO ADD FOR THE COMMITTEE. BUT
NOT THIS MORNING OTHER THAN- I
MIGHT MIGHT- ADMIN DIRECTOR HAS
ADVISED ME THAT- THE THREE
MONTH MARK THAT I HAD HAD LAID
OUT HIS IS OPTIMISTIC THAT'S IF
EVERYTHING GOES. PERFECTLY WELL
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO YOU KNOW
TO GIVE OURSELVES A LITTLE BIT
MORE I HAVE A WINDOW OPEN FOR
YOU KNOW ANY KIND OF
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT- YOU KNOW
MAY ARISE WHERE YEAH WE DO HAVE
TO STRETCH OUT THE HIRING
PROCESS- BUT OTHER THAN THAT NO
NOT THIS MORNING. OKAY I'M
OBVIOUSLY. I HAVE MORE THAN
PASSING INTEREST AND THIS IS A
TOPIC SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
TALK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THANKS EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL HOLD
THIS MATTER I CAN MOVE ON TO
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AND
IRAQ TO BRING FORWARD THE FISH
AND WILDLIFE- DEPARTMENT AND I
HAVE A PRESENTATION I THINK
THEY'RE VERY STRICT BOTTOM GOOD
MORNING WELCOME TO THE SUB TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND YOU
HAVE A WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
ABOUT OUR FAVORITE SINCE I'VE
BEEN THE CHAIR HERE THE SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING SO- YES. IF THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. HERE BEAR WITH
ME A SECOND I'M GONNA SHARE
SCREEN. AND THIS WILL BE THE
HARDEST. TASKS FOR ME TODAY.
ALL RIGHT WE GOT SCREEN.
PERFECT SO IT'S TRUE MY NAME IS
CHUCK BONHAM AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IT'S GREAT TO SEE EACH OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TODAY I WISH
IT WEREN'T PERSON HELP YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY ARE SAFE AND WELL.
I'M NOT GONNA READ. THIS SLIDE.
STYLE NO NO IN PRESENTATIONS
YOU CAN READ IT. AND THAT TAKES
US TO. THE NEXT SLIDE. SO YOU
SEE THE DEPARTMENT'S MISSION
STATEMENT HERE AND IN MY
JUDGMENT IF YOU PULL DOWN THAT
MISSION STATEMENT IT BOILS DOWN
TO ONE SIMPLE WORD NATURE. IT
IS NATURE FROM BEES THE
BUTTERFLIES WHALES TO MOUNT
LIONS. OUR MISSION IS ABOUT
PRESERVING LAND WATER WILDLIFE
THAT'S A REASON WHY WE ARE ONE
OF THE MOST THRIVING ECONOMIES
IN THE WORLD THAT NATURAL
WEALTH. IF YOU LOOK AT THAT
NATURAL WEALTH WE HAVE. SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BIRD SPECIES
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY MAMMAL
SPECIES SEVENTY FIVE IN THE
BN'S. ALMOST A HUNDRED
FRESHWATER FISH SPECIES UNDER
MARINE FISH SPECIES OF MAMMALS
IN SIX THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
TAXA OF PLANTS. TWO THOUSAND OF
WHICH ARE FOUND NOWHERE ELSE ON
THE PLANET. THIS NATURE'S WHY
PEOPLE COME HERE IT'S WHY THEY
STAY. AND IT'S WHO ARE
DEPARTMENTS SO WE'VE BEEN ON A
LONG JOURNEY SURE YOU MENTIONED
THAT THE JOURNEY ACTUALLY
PREDATES ALL OF US IT STARTS IN
THE LATE NINETEEN FIFTIES. AND
THE CRUX OF THIS JOURNEY HAS
BEEN TO ASK THE QUESTION WHAT
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE TO
SUSTAINABLY FUNDED DEPARTMENT
WHOSE JOB IS THIS MISSION
STATEMENT. MOST RECENT PART OF
THIS JOURNEY IS BEGINNING IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN THE
BUDGET ACT. WHEN YOU THE
LEGISLATURE INSTRUCTED OUR
DEPARTMENT TO COMPLETE
SOMETHING CALLED SERVICE BASED
BUDGET. THAT'S S. B. B. WE HARD
TO AVOID A NATIONAL FIRM THAT
HAS EXPERTISE IN THIS SPACE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE GOALS OF
THE SERVICE BAYS BUDGET PROCESS
DESCRIBED HERE. THE BOTTOM PART
OF THE SLOT. WE'RE DONE WITH
THAT AFTER. WE FILED OUR FINAL
REPORT WITH YOU ONE TIME
ACTUALLY WE RETRACT THAT ABOUT
TWO WEEKS LATER. BUT YOU'RE IN
RECEIPT OF THAT FINAL REPORT.
HERE'S HOW WE STARTED THIS
DYNAMIC ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO. WE
CONVENE AN EXTERNAL DIVISORS
COMMITTEE. OUR DIVERSE
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY WHICH
ALSO INCLUDED ENGAGEMENT WITH
YOUR BUDGET AND OTHER SUBJECT
MATTER COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE
LEGISLATURE. WE STARTED WITH
TRYING TO RETHINK WHAT WE DO
AND DESCRIBING IT USING PLAIN
LANGUAGE AND WE BROKE OUR CORE
SERVICES INTO THE SIMPLER
NARRATIVES. ARE WORKING WITH
EXTERNAL COMMITTEE I DESCRIBE
HERE ON THE SLIDE YOU SEE WE
WANTED TO FIND WORDS THAT WE
THOUGHT THE PUBLIC WOULD
UNDERSTAND MORE EASILY. WORDS
IT WOULD BE MORE TRANSPARENT
ABOUT WHO WE ARE AND HOW WE
DIVIDE OUR WORK APPROACH AT THE
DEPARTMENT. FROM THERE. THE
RESULTS ARE REAL THEY'RE
CONSEQUENTIAL AND I WOULD SAY
INTERNALLY FOR US AT THE
DEPARTMENT THEY'RE KIND OF
BARRIER SHATTERING. WE'RE
REALLY OLD INSTITUTION WE'RE
ACTUALLY CELEBRATING WITH OUR
SISTER COMMISSION ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY. AND WE HAVE A FOOT
IN OUR PAST BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
FOOT IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY OF OUR FUTURE. WE CAN
JEANS. ALMOST A HUNDRED OF OUR
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ACROSS
OUR DEPARTMENT. WE CREATED IT
ADVISORY GROUP WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT FROM OUR LOWEST
NEWEST RANK AND FILE STAFF ALL
THE WAY UP TO MEET THE
DIRECTOR. AND WE TOOK A LOOK AT
EVERYTHING WE DID WE TOOK THOSE
EIGHT CERVECERIAS AND WE
IDENTIFIED OVER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED TASKS WE DO. SO
WE'RE NOT THIS MAMMOTH EXCEL
SPREADSHEET. THAT BREAKS DOWN
EACH PERSON'S LABOR OUR
RELATIVE TO THE TASKS NEEDED TO
ACCOMPLISH THOSE SERVICE AREAS.
WE ALSO DID A REVENUE WHILE
ANNOUNCES OF OUR TOP TEN
ARGUABLY MOST IMPORTANT OR
COMPLICATED FUNDS SOURCES WHICH
WAS PART OF THE ASSIGNMENT YOU
GAVE. WHAT YOU GET WHEN YOU DO
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING IS A
DATA DRIVEN. PORTRAYAL OF YOUR
CURRENT LEVEL WORK WHICH YOU
SEE IN THE SLIDE HERE THE
DARKER BLUE. WITHIN A PROGRAM
AREA AND THEN THE GAP
BENCHMARKED AGAINST THE MISSION
LEVEL WHICH HAS A DEFINITION
YOU KIND OF LOOK AT ALL OF YOUR
STATUTORY ASSIGNMENT YOUR
POLICIES YOUR BEST SCIENCE
COMMITMENT TO UNDERSTAND IF YOU
WERE DOING ALL YOU NEEDED TO DO
HIT THE MISSION AND YOU
UNDERSTAND DATA DRIVEN GAP WITH
CURRENT EMISSION. NOW
IMPORTANTLY THERE ARE MANY WAYS
YOU CAN FILL THE GAP IT'S JUST
NOT HIRING MORE PEOPLE YOU CAN
INVEST IN TECHNOLOGY AND
EQUIPMENT WHICH ARE MENTIONED
IN THE NEXT AGENDA ITEM YOU
COULD PARTNER BETTER WITH YOUR
EXTERNAL COMMUNITY TO REDUCE
COST FIND SAVINGS YOU COULD
IMPROVE YOUR OWN PROCESS SEES
YOU CAN LOOK AT YOUR MISSIONS
AND MANDATES AND YOU COULD ASK
THE QUESTION SOMETHING GIVEN TO
US AS A TASK IN NINETEEN
THIRTY. IS IT STILL RELEVANT OR
SHOULD COME OFF THE BOOKS. IN
HERE'S WHAT YOU GET. WHEN YOU
RUN THIS DATA ANALYTICS USING
AN OUTSIDE FIRM LIKE THE LLOYD.
WORKING WITH YOUR BUDGET STAFF
AND OUR EXTERNAL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. ON THE BOTTOM HERE
YOU SEE ALL OF THOSE EIGHT CORE
PROGRAM AREAS. IN TO BE HONEST
THIS IS NOT NEW NEW. SINCE THE
FIFTIES PEOPLE ASK WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE TO SUSTAINABLY FIND
THIS DEPARTMENT. YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE OF ACTUALLY AMENDED
THE FISH AND GAME CODE TO
EXPRESSLY SAY THE DEPARTMENT'S
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WERE
UNDERFUNDED IT'S A KNOWN ISSUE.
WHAT IS NEW IS THAT DATA BASED
ANALYTICS TO REACH THESE
CONCLUSIONS SO I'M NOT SURE HOW
IT WARRANTS ON YOUR SIDE BUT ON
MY COMPUTER COMPUTER ON THE
LEFT YOU'LL SEE THE AREAS WHERE
OUR GAP IS SMALLEST. OUR
CURRENT LEVEL IS THE HIGHEST
GOING ALL THE WAY OVER TO THE
OTHER SIDE AND YOU'LL SEE THAT
ARE TO LOWEST PERFORMING AREAS
ARE PERMITTING AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION OUR
SPECIES INHABIT. YOU CAN RUN
THE DATA ALL DIFFERENT WAYS.
THIS IS JUST A DIFFERENT VISUAL
DEPICTION USING LABOR HOURS. TO
EXPRESS THE SAME KIND OF
RESULTS WHAT YOUR CURRENT. IN
YOUR MISSIONS. HERE ARE THE KEY
FINDINGS WHICH ARE JUST WORDS
THAT REFLECT THE LAST TWO SLIDE
YOU SAW. AS A GENERAL
PROPOSITION. ROSS THE BOARD
KIND OF ON AVERAGE WE'RE FUNDED
ABOUT WE NEED ABOUT THREE TIMES
MORE INVESTMENT IN CAPACITY TO
HIT THE MISSION LEVEL
ASSIGNMENTS. ACTUALLY SINCE THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES OUR
DEPARTMENTS HAD ADDED ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED STATUTORY MANDATES
AND OBLIGATIONS OVER THE COURSE
OF LAST COUPLE OF DECADES WHICH
IS PART IN PARCEL KIND OF THAT
DYNAMIC THAT'S PRODUCING SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES BROUGHT. OUR
LAST TWO SLIDES THIS IS
ACTUALLY NOT A ONE OFF FOR US
SO THIS SLIDE JUST GIVES YOU A
SENSE OF WHAT WE'VE DONE WITHIN
OUR INSTITUTION. EVERY YEAR WE
WILL UPDATE THIS INFORMATION.
EVERY FIVE YEARS WE WILL UPDATE
THE INFORMATION THAT
ESTABLISHES YOUR MISSION LEVEL
SERVICE AREN'T BASS LINES WE
HAVE TRAINED ALL OF OUR
DEPARTMENTS SO WE'VE
INSTITUTIONALIZED THIS. WE HAVE
THESE DIGITAL TOOLS NOW
AVAILABLE WHERE WE CAN RUN
INFORMATION REQUEST USING ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PLATFORMS YOU
SEE KIND OF DISPLAYED HERE AND
BE RESPONSIVE TO YOUR REQUEST
WE'VE CHANGED OUR DEPARTMENTS
ORIENTATION SUCH THAT THESE ARE
THE TOOLS NOW INFORMING EACH OF
OUR BUDGET CYCLE PROPOSALS-
ENGAGEMENTS WITH FINANCE. AND
ACTUALLY HARDY FULL TIME PERSON
TO MANAGE THIS DATA SAID AND IT
IS OUR NEW WAY OF BUSINESS SO
AT A MINIMUM WHAT'S YOUR
LEADERSHIP HAS DONE IS PRODUCE
THE DATA SAID. THAT NOW GIVES
US THE ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND
THE TRUE PROBLEM. AND CREATED A
CULTURE OF THE DEPARTMENT WHICH
IS REALLY PULLED HERSELF INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
THINKING ABOUT A PRETTY WICKED
HEART PROBLEM THAT'S BEEN
AROUND LONG BEFORE. WE WERE ALL
HERE. SO LET ME STOP THERE
THAT'S THE REPORT ON SERVICE
BASED BUDGETING AND IN A MOMENT
WE HAVE A SEGUE TO A- SEPARATE
AGENDA ITEM WHICH IS ABOUT A
BUDGET CHANGE HOLES ALL SEEKING
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
INFORMATION I DISCUSS THE
PRESENT. I THANK YOU DIRECTOR I
SEE. FINANCE MISS ONE HAS YOUR
HAND UP THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US TO RECOGNIZE. BUT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I JUST WANTED TO
JUST- JUST BRIEFLY- CIRCLE BACK
TO THAT CALDERON- OVERSIGHT
PROPOSAL I'M INTERESTED-
REITERATES ESSENTIALLY THAT-
YOU KNOW WE TOOK A MEASURED
APPROACH- YOU KNOW RECOGNIZING
THE CHALLENGES- THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS HAD- FILLING THE
POSITIONS- AND SO REALLY JUST
WANTED TO- TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE APPOINTMENTS AND SO THAT
THAT IS- IN LARGE PART WHY WE
PROPOSED A- THREE. A THREE YEAR
FACING POSITIONS THANK YOU
RELEVANT WRITTEN RECORD WILL
REFLECT ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO
MISS TAYLOR'S- WHAT THE
CALLIOPE ON THE ON THE A
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING. IT
REALLY SHOWS LL OUR WOUNDS. OF
HOW WONDERFUL AND WHO CLEAR OUT
WE ARE. IN THE GROUP IN THAT
HAVE A TRUE WAY PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU AGAIN RETAILER FROM
pFIRST JUST A KNOWLEDGE IN ALL
OF THE HARD WORK THAT THE
DEPARTMENT HAS DONE ON THIS
THEY SHOULD REALLY BE COMMENDED
FOR HOW THEY EMBRACE THIS I
THINK IT'S WORTH. ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE TOLD THEM TO DO
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY
CAME FORTH AND ASKED TO DO BUT
THEY REALLY DID EMBRACE IT- AND
REALLY RAN WITH IT AND PROVIDE
A LOT OF REALLY AND INFORMATION
THAT WILL BE VERY HELPFUL IN
THE FUTURE. BUT INFORMATION IS
ONLY USEFUL AS LONG AS IT IS
USED SO I THINK THE NEXT STEP
IS REALLY. WHAT WE DO WITH THIS
INFORMATION AND OF COURSE PART
OF THAT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THE LEGISLATURE HOW TO
RESPOND- BUT CERTAINLY ALSO THE
IN MINISTRATION AND SO I THINK
THE NEXT PHASE IS REALLY GOING
TO BE WHAT IT WILL HOW ARE WE
GOING TO ADDRESS THESE GAPS.
AND PARTICULARLY THOSE THOSE
AREAS WILL RECEIVE THE LARGEST
GAPS IN THE SPECIES AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION AND- AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AREAS.
SO WHAT TIME IT IS A LITTLE BIT
AND THEN IN THE NEXT AGENDA
ITEM IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET. AND THIS IS A
DIFFICULT TIME GIVEN THEIR
REVENUES AND UNCERTAINTY TO TRY
AND ADDRESS SOME LONGSTANDING
SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS LIKE THIS BUT
I DO THINK- ENGAGING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND REALLY
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT
IS THE PLAN HOW ARE WE GOING TO
ADDRESSES ON AN ON GOING BASIS
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION IS GREAT TO HAVE IT
HIGHLIGHTED BUT BUT WHAT COMES
NEXT IN. AB WE REALLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO ENGAGE DEEPLY AND REALLY
PRESS THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL TO TRY AND GET SOME LONG
TERM PLANNING THEM. TO HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS THESE.
ARE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT GAPS. I
THERE'S LEGISLATIVE PLAN AFOOT
TO GIVE WHO. THE SERVICE IN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
FURTHER. EXTREME AND VERY HIGH
FIRE- ARE THREATS OF FIRE AREAS
BUT THAT'LL WE'LL SAVE THAT FOR
LATER ON IN THE AGENDA SENATE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR IN A MISTER VICE
CHAIR- THANK YOU TO OTHER
DIRECTOR I HAVE A FEW COMMENTS
AND SOME QUESTIONS FIRST AND
FOREMOST I JUST WANNA. I ALWAYS
TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
DIRECTOR FOR HIS WORK ON ALL
ISSUES- FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE IT'S BEEN A HELL OF
A- SIX YEARS NOW SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WITH SALMON
AND CRAB. AND HE HAS BEEN ON
THE FOREFRONT ON THIS AND I
JUST I CAN'T THINK OF ENOUGH
FOR HIS DIRECTING GAUGE MEANS
ALWAYS- AND THERE'S MORE
CHALLENGES AHEAD. YES SAILORS
ALSO SAID I APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT MOVING FORWARD- ON
THIS ISSUE THIS IS BEING AT
SERVICE FACE BUDGETING. HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE THAT I HAVE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THE ENTIRE SIX
YEARS HAVE BEEN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING. DETERMINING THE
FUNDING PRIORITIES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT. AND ESPECIALLY ON
THE FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE
SIDE. AND DO APPRECIATE THAT-
THE DIRECTOR HAS ADOPTED THIS.
WITH THIS BUDGET SUB MOVING
THIS FORWARD AS WELL. I THINK
THAT IT DOES EXPOSE A REAL
ISSUE OF. SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND
HOURS BEING SPENT PER YEAR ON
SPECIES HABITAT CONSERVATION.
I'M HERE TO THE TWO POINT NINE
MILLION HOURS IN THE DEPARTMENT
WE NEED TO BE A NEED TO MISSION
RIGHT THAT'S A HUGE GAP- AND
JUST BEING CANDID IT'S WE'RE
BACK HERE EVERY YEAR- WHETHER
IT'S STATE PARKS OR ITS FISH
AND WILDLIFE. WITH ONE TIME
FIXES. IN WHAT I WOULD HOPE
RIGHT NOW WE LOOKING AT THE
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
IMPLEMENTATION IS NOW
DEVELOPING A LONG TERM PLAN TO
BE ABLE TO ASSIST THE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER IT'S FISHING
WILDLIFE IS WELL STATE PARKS.
TO MOVE FORWARD BECAUSE THIS
JUST BE HONEST ABOUT IT EVERY
TIME THERE'S A RECESSION HERE
AND BE THE FIRST TO BE CUT. AND
THEN THEY'RE GONNA LOOK FOR THE
THING WITH THESE RIDICULOUS FEE
INCREASE PROPOSALS. THAT WILL
NEVER FLY. QUESTION HERE SO I
GUESS I JUST WANT TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ON THE
ISSUE OF ADMINISTRATIVE TO
MISTER DIRECTOR AGAIN I
SINCERELY MEANNESS I APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR ENGAGEMENT AND
LEADERSHIP ON ALL ISSUES OF
FISHERIES AND AQUACULTURE BUT
THE DEPARTMENT'S MEETING ABOUT
74% OF THE NEED FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT BUT ONLY
26% WHEN IT COMES TO SPECIES
AND CONSERVATION NEEDS SO CAN
YOU TALK WITH US ABOUT THAT HOW
THIS PLAYED OUT. IN YOUR YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE FINDINGS. SO
LET ME START WITH YOUR YOUR
SECOND QUESTION THE FINDINGS.
BROADLY DON'T SURPRISE ME
BECAUSE IT'S A ISSUE MOST
EVERYONE IS A KNOWLEDGE FOR A
LONG TIME. WHAT DID SURPRISE ME
WAS THE SPECIFICITY AROUND HOW
BIG THE GAP IS. IN THOSE AREAS-
THAT YOU'VE MENTIONED SPECIES
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION AND
PERMITTING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION. AND WHEN I'VE
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT WAR. WHAT I
CONCLUDE IT IS. THOSE AREAS ARE
ACTUALLY ARGUABLY HARDER AREAS
FOR US TO FUND. BECAUSE A LOT
OF THAT WORK IS DRIVEN BY FEE
AND WE CAN'T FEED OURSELVES OUT
OF ALL THE RESPONSIBILITIES
WE'VE BEEN ASSIGNED. WHICH
MEANS WHAT'S THE OTHER FUNDS
SOURCE AND HISTORICALLY THE
CONVERSATION HAS CENTERED IN ON
GENERAL FUND. AND OF COURSE
THERE ARE MANY CALLS ON THE
GENERAL FUND. SO FOR ME WHEN I
LOOK AT PERMITTING AND SPECIES
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION. WE
HAVE A VERY HIGH DEMAND FOR
THAT WERE. THOSE FOUR HUNDRED
NEW KIND OF ASSIGNMENTS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ONE. BUT THE
SUPPLY TO DEAL WITH THE DEMAND
IS FEE BASED WHICH CAN ONLY
REALLY AFFECT CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
THE WORK. FOR GENERAL. WE'VE
NEVER FIGURED OUT AN ADDITIVE
FUNDS SOURCE TO HELP US BRIDGE
THAT GAP OF CONVERSELY IF YOU
GO OVER TO ADD BEEN SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY THE
SERVICE LEVEL IS HIGHER. IS THE
WAY WE HANDLED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. WE KIND OF THIS
CHARGE FOR ADMIN CROSS ALL OF
OUR DEPARTMENT. SUCH THAT WERE
ALWAYS BRINGING HAD MEN UP TO
SECURE THE CAUGHT THE SERVICE
LEVEL WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT-
THAT'S I THINK WHY YOU SEE A
DIFFERENCE OVER ON ONE SIDE AND
THEN IN A DIFFERENCE OVER ON
THE OTHER SIDE PERMITTING
INSPECTIONS. THE RESEARCHER
TRYNA TURN THIS BACK OVER TO
THE CHAIR IN JUST ONE MOMENT%
NOW THE SAME RESEARCHER I THINK
THE OTHER CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT. IS
THAT BECAUSE IT'S FEE BASED AND
THERE IS NO CONSISTENT FUNDING
WHEN TIMES ARE GOOD ONE TIME
MONEY FLOWS IN IN TIMES ARE BAD
THEY'RE SLASHED AND THEN WE
PLAYED MAKE UP. A TRYING TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE UP FOR THOSE CUTS
IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS AFTER THOSE
BAD YEARS WHICH IS MAKES THE
PROBLEM WORSE. SO WHAT I WOULD
HOPE AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN THIS
BUDGET SUB WHETHER IT'S THE
ISSUE OF FISH AND WILDLIFE OR
STATE PARKS BECAUSE THEY'RE
STILL IN THERE IN THAT SAME
POSITION. WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WITHOUT
LONGER TERM OF TWENTY PLAN IS
IN MISTER CHAIR SHOULD. I WAIT
ON MY ITEMS AND TWENTY NINE.
YOU'RE MENTAL WITH THAT GET THE-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SECURE.
IS FOR. I'M YEAH I THINK THE S.
B. B. REALLY US BECAUSE WE
OBVIOUSLY ARE BUDGETS
REFLECTION OF WHAT OUR VALUES
ARE IN WHEN YOU GET THIS
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT MEETING.
GETTING CLOSE TO THE MISSION
THAT WE WANT I MEAN I GET
THERE'S A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
ASPIRATION AND THAT'S THAT'S
FINE AND DANDY PUTS BUT PART OF
IT IS THAT HE SAID. WHEN WE
TALK WITH THESE OTHER COMPETING
I HAVE CHALLENGES WHETHER IT'S
AN EDUCATION OR SAID
TRANSPORTATION OR OR OTHER
BUDGET- ALLOCATIONS IT GIVES US
SOMETHING ELSE TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT'S TIMES. EXPRESSIVITY SAY
LET'S JUST GET THE 30% PLUS THE
SCRIPTED 32% OR WHATEVER
WHATEVER IT IS- VICE CHAIR
DOLLY. DIGITAL QUICKER. REALLY
TO PRESENTE I'M I'M GLAD TO SEE
THAT THIS INFORMATION COME FOR
IS THEIR ABILITY TO GET A COPY
OF YOUR POWER POINT PLEASE- SO
I CAN DIVE IN A LITTLE DEEPER
ON THAT. YES AND ALSO- THE
REPORT IF YOU ALL HAVEN'T
RECEIVED HARD COPIES WILL MAKE
SURE YOUR OFFICES EACH HAVE. A
LINKS. WE HAVE A DEDICATED
WEBSITE FOR ALL THIS
INFORMATION. AND THE REPORTS
WE'VE MADE TO THE EXTERNAL
COMMITTEE OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS SO WE'LL MAKE SURE EACH
OF YOUR OFFICES GETS ALL THAT.
A CONNECTIVE ITTY FOR THAT
INFORMATION AS WELL. AND IF I
COULD SHARE REAL QUICK. IN AND
IN A NOD TO ACCESS EACH OF YOU
THAT'S ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WE'VE BEEN ALL THROUGH A LOT
TOGETHER. AND IN MY TENURE AS
DIRECTOR JUST TO GIVE YOU A
FLAVOUR OF THE JOURNEY. I'VE
RAISED FEES IN OUR SEASON
PROGRAM A RAISE FEES AND ARE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED LAKE AND
STREAMBED ALTERATION AGREEMENT
POGRAM OF RAISE FEES TO DO ARE
SICK WHAT. WORK IN THE
DEPARTMENT I TRIED TO RAISE
FEES ON COMMERCIAL FISHING I
THINK THAT'S WHAT MISTER
MCGUIRE WAS ALLUDING TO A
MOMENT AGO. I WE TRIED TO SOLVE
SOME OF THIS FUNDING BY USING
THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT. WE
TRIED AND IDEA OF USING THE
TIRE RECYCLING PROGRAM CAL
RECYCLE. WE'VE TRIED
AUGMENTATIONS OF GENERAL FUND
INCLUDING LAST YEAR WHICH OF
COURSE RAN INTO THE PANDEMIC SO
I FEEL VERY BATTLE SCARRED. BUT
NOW WHAT'S DIFFERENT IS HAVING
THIS DATA I DO SAYING SHOULD
PUT TO REST IN MY MIND AT LEAST
WHETHER THERE'S A PROBLEM AND
WHETHER WE SUBSTANTIATED THE
PROBLEM THERE'S AN ISSUE. I
THINK NEXT IS WHAT WHAT WE DO
ABOUT. GREAT CENTER STERN YOU
RECOGNIZE. THE PERFECT
TRANSITION DIRECTOR BOTTOM- SHE
DID THE DILIGENCE ON ALL THIS
AND PUTTING IT INTO STARK
RELIEF I MEAN THE CUT I WOULD I
GUESS FOR MY QUESTION IS I WANT
TO KNOW. YOU HAVE IT IN YEAH
THIS GAPS IN DOLLARS IT IN SOME
WAY I SAW IT IN HOURS AS ADAM
PERCENTAGES BUT LIKE I I'M
TRYING TO RIGHT SIZE EVERYONE'S
EXPECTATIONS HERE OF WHAT IT
REALLY MEANS. SAID TO MEET THIS
CHALLENGE SO IF WE APPROPRIATE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INSTANCE FOR ALL THE BACKLOG OF
FIRE MAINTENANCE THAT NEED TO
BE DONE IN ALL THE DIFFERENT
HABITATS THAT YOU ALL HELP
MANAGE. THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
GETS YOU HOW FAR ON ONE OF
THOSE BAR CHARTS AND HOW MUCH
FURTHER DO WE NEED TO GET TO GO.
SOONER THIS WILL ALSO COME UP
IN THE NEXT. AGENDA ITEM BUT-
HERE'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO
UNDERSCORE. IT AS I'VE LEARNED
IN THIS BUSINESS DISCIPLINE OF
SERVICE BASED BUDGETING A
METRIC THE WIDGET YOU'RE USING
TO JUDGE IS NOT DOLLARS. IT'S
LABOR HOURS BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS YOU'RE YOU'RE
BENCHMARKING YOUR SERVICES
AGAINST ALL THE TASKS SO I'LL
EXAGGERATE. LIKE SAY A SERVICE
AREA IS UP WE CAN JOIN MEANT OF
YOUR LANDS THEN YOU'RE WORKING
BACKWARDS WELL WE HAVE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY PROPERTIES.
AND THEN YOU'RE DOING ALL THESE
TASKS LIKE CHANGE THE TOILET
PAPER IN THE RESTAURANT RIGHT
AND THEN YOU'RE FIGURING OUT
THE PERSON HOURS ACCUMULATED UP.
SO WE DON'T USE THE METRIC OF
MONEY. BY WE KNOW PERSON HOURS
LABOR HOURS AND WHAT THE DATA
IS SHOWING YOU IS A GENERALIZED
MATTER WERE UNDER IT'S ABOUT A
THREE AXIS PROBLEM. RIDE SO
THEN WHAT ONE CAN DO AND OF
LOGIC WISE IS REALIZE WE'RE
ABOUT THREE THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
AND OUR ANNUAL BUDGET IS ABOUT
YOU KNOW SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR. BOUNCES AROUND.
SO THEN YOU ASK YOURSELF WHAT
THREE ACTS PROBLEM MEANS NOW
THAT TIMES THREE. IT DOESN'T
WORK OUT THAT WAY IN EVERY
ISSUE BUT IT'S SOME GENERALIZED
IT WAYS. AND THAT'S I THINK
REALLY THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN
MOVE INTO THE QUESTION AROUND
MONEY PER SE BECAUSE THE
ANALYSIS IS DRIVEN AROUND
PERSONALS. NOW CAN I TELL YOU
WITH EACH INVESTMENT HOW THE
GAP MAY SHRINK KIND OF. I THINK
WHAT THE TOOL ALLOWS DID WAS
ILLUSTRATE THE GAP AND
UNDERSTAND WHERE IT MAY EXIST.
IT ALLOWS YOU TO THINK ABOUT
INVESTMENTS FOR RETURN ON
INVESTMENT AND REMEMBER THAT
SLIDE IS NOT ALWAYS YOU NEED TO
ADD HE Y. YOU CAN. DO ONE TIME
AND TECHNOLOGY YOU COULD CHANGE
YOUR OWN INTERNAL PROCESSES.
THE OTHER THING IS THE TOOL
REALLY ISN'T SET UP ONLY
PROJECT OR PREDICT THE FUTURE.
IT'S MORE SET UP TO TAKE EACH
YEAR AFTER THE FACT AND SCRUB
THE NUMBERS AND SEE WHAT
CHANGES WITHIN THAT LABOR OUR
AND THEN EVERY FIVE YEARS KIND
OF SCRUB THE NUMBERS AGAIN. SO
I DON'T HAVE COMPLETE OVERSIGHT
WITH THE TOOL I THINK YOU CAN
MAKE SOME REASONABLE
PREDICTIONS ABOUT HOW IT WILL
HELP WHAT I HAVE IS AFTER THE
FACT. YEAH THE NUMBERS IT'S GOT
TO GO- DO YOU. DO YOU HAVE
BESIDES AFTER THE FACT NUMBERS
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEAS DESPITE
YOUR SCARS HERE ANY ANY GREAT
IDEAS HOW DO WE FIX THIS. ARE
YOU CAN I MEAN THERE'S IN KICK
IT TO US TO TRY TO FIGURE THAT
OUT BUT- I THINK I MEAN I WOULD
I WOULD URGE YOU TO. JUST WHERE
THOSE CARS AS YOU KNOW BATON.
MEDALS OF HONOR OF SOME SORT
AND KEEP COMING BACK. WE NEED.
WE NEED SOME KIND OF CREATIVITY
HERE- AND BONDS ARE GOING TO
FIX THIS. RIGHT I MEAN IT'S
WE'RE TALKING OPERATIONS. FOR A
LOT OF IT SO. ANY ANY NEW
BRIGHT IDEAS. TWO ANSWERS TO
THAT QUESTION. BUT OF COURSE.
IF THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE WOULD
LIKE TO WAY AND NOW I'M BE GLAD
TO SEE A HAND RAISED BY. FIRST
ANSWER IS. YOUR STAFF RECOMMEND
HOLD OPEN I UNDERSTAND THAT
WHEN WE GET TO ISSUE TWENTY
NINE. AND IN MY OPINION I'VE
EXPERIENCED HOLD OPEN IS A WAY
IN WHICH DISCUSSIONS CONTENT
CAN CONTINUE. AND THEN SECONDLY
I'LL JUST NOTE THAT IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND SUBCOMMITTEE THREE
MISTER BLOOM AT MONASH MAY WITH
A DIRECT REPORT BACK. I
RESPONSIBILITIES. WELL LOOK
FORWARD TO I AM THE SAME EAGER
ANTICIPATION I GUESS I WOULD
SHARE WITH MY ASSEMBLY
COUNTERPART THERE AND VERY
CURIOUS YOU FROM DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST WHAT THE WHAT THE
THINKING IS THERE A STRATEGY
HERE MISTER IDEAL ARE YOUR
RECOGNIZE. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBER SERGIO AG
LOWER THE PUBLIC FINANCE-
CITING JUST KIND OF THINKING
OVERALL STRATEGY IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THE THURSDAY BUDGET
GAPS. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE SLIDE
THAT THE DIRECTOR HAD WAS ON
DIFFERENT APPROACHES- THAT
COULD BE USED TO ASPHALT THE
GAS OVERALL IN TERMS OF
CLARIFYING MISSION. ALL THESE
MANDATES PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS.
ARE WORKING WITH EXTERNAL
PARTNERS TO CLARIFY- TECHNOLOGY
AND EQUIPMENT WHICH REALLY DOES
HOLD INTO THE NEXT AGENDA ITEM
WE'RE WE'RE MAKING SOME KIND OF
INITIAL ONE TIME. SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT AND DIFFERENT
ACTIONS THAT SUPPORT TECHNOLOGY
AND EQUIPMENT WHICH- YOU KNOW
WILL HELP REDUCE THAT GAP AND
THEN THIRD WHICH IS THE BIGGEST
PIECE OF THE LABOR HOURS WHICH
IS- YOU KNOW KIND OF HOW I WHAT
WE USED TO- TO. LOOK AT THE
DATA GAPS WINDSOR'S STATE
BUDGET AND YOU KNOW WITH
KNOWLEDGE THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ON. WHAT WE WILL BE
DOING TO KIND OF ADDRESS THAT
THE ON GOING- GAP I THINK THIS
BUDGET REALLY DOES FOCUS ON
THAT ONE TIME INVESTMENT AND
PART OF THE- STATE THAT TAKING
A STEP BACK AND THE OVERALL
BUDGET FRAMEWORK. I WE ARE
LOOKING OVERALL AT WHAT WE CAN
DO TO MAKE EFFICIENCIES- AND
JUST MAKE PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS
WITH A ONE TIME INVESTMENT. BUT
WE DO PLAN TO CONTINUE
EVALUATING AND WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ON EVERY KIND OF
ONGOING SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION-
WE DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL AT
THIS TIME. BY THIS DATA SAID
REALLY DON'T PROVIDE US A LOT
OF GREAT INFORMATION TO BE ABLE
TO DIG IN FURTHER AND SEE WHAT
THE BEST AND MOST APPROPRIATE
APPROACHES ARE. NOT MISLEADING
LEVINE- FOLLOW UP THERE- YOU S.
IS DAD. THAT- YOU'RE FIRST. TO
VERSUS SO ARE WE GONNA HERE
SOMETHING BACK THIS YEAR. WE'RE
GONNA HEAR OMETHING BACK
BEFORE THE MAY REVISE YOU THINK
WERE YOU GUYS ACTUALLY PUT
SOME. IDEAS ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE HEARING
OF WILLINGNESS FROM. AT LEAST I
DON'T YOU KNOW. HOW TO SPEAK
FOR THE CHAIR BUT CERTAINLY
FROM. YOU KNOW YOUR CHAIR ON
THE OTHER SIDE I THINK AN
EAGERNESS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE TO HEAR SOME. SOME NEW
THINKING SO IS THAT SOMETHING
YOU WOULD ANTICIPATE THIS YEAR.
OR IS THAT A FUTURE YEARS
CONVERSATION. AND SO. AT THIS
POINT CAN'T MAKE A COMMITMENT
ON TIMING- I THINK THERE'S
STILL SOME UNCERTAINTY THAT WE
CAN MAKE A COMMITMENT AWAY
ANOTHER. YOU KNOW I THINK WE
ARE CONTINUE TO VALUE DEPENDS
OF TIMING WISE- YOU KNOW WE CAN
MAKE COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL
HAVE. A- PLAN FOR THIS YEAR BY.
REALLY THE- DATA WAY.
DEPARTMENT HAD THE- TONS OF. IN
A TO DEVELOP REALLY DOES
PROVIDE THAT. BAGRI DATA AND
PROVIDES THE ESTATE. AND A
ALLEGE- IN A LOT OF COLLECTING.
YOUR TO DETERMINE YOU KNOW
FUTURE. CAN I CAN I SAY A TWO.
NO YOU CAN'T PROMISE. THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET A SOMEBODY
THIS- BUT- YOU KNOW DOESN'T
MEAN YOU'RE FOR. UP OF DOING SO.
MAY I MEAN THAT THAT THERE ARE
STILL BECAUSE BE A WIN HERE TO
PUT SOME. BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
VERY QUICKLY HERE. NAY YEAR
ANOTHER. CYCLE OPPORT. ALSO TO
PUT IDEAS VOTERS POTENTIALLY I
THINK PEOPLE ARE EAGER TO DEAL
WITH IT I KNOW WITHIN THE RANKS
PEOPLE LOVE THEIR POWER.
RANGERS THEY LOVE THEIR WARDENS
A LOT OF YOU KNOW WHETHER
YOU'RE A RECREATION OR HUNTER
OR JUST SOMEBODY LOVES YEAH.
LIKE THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
NEEDS NEED MORE OF THESE. WE
WANT PEOPLE HIRED IN THIS SO-
AND WE'RE COMING AT I MEAN I
CAN I RECOVERY HOPEFULLY AT A
COPAY DAY. THIS SET. IS IN AND-
RICH SECTOR TO FURTHER INVEST
IN SO I JUST WANT TO GET
CLARITY THAT YOU'RE NOT CLEAR
ON WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE SINCE. SOLUTION IDEAS
RIGHT NOW BUT YOU'RE NOT SAYING
YOU WON'T. THAT FAIR TO SAY.
YEAH THERE'S A NOT MAKING A
COMMITMENT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
OKAY I'LL TAKE THE OTHER BUT
I'LL TAKE IT THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FINANCE FOR THAT.
MISS TAYLOR SWIFT THE ALEJO
YOU'VE YOU'VE- ARE BROUGHT TO
OUR ATTENTION I GUESS WE WOULD
SAY. FORMER LEADERS WOULD SAY
YOU'VE PUT IT IN I TELL X.
UNDERSCORED PUT IT IN BOLD THAT
THAT AND MOST OF THE SERVICERS
WE'RE NOT EVEN AT A THIRD OF
WHAT THE FUNDING SHOULD BE I
MEAN I MEAN SORT OF LIKE A PUNY
LITTLE GOAL MAY BE. TO GET TO A
THIRD OF WHAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING CAN YOU. OUR
COMMENT ON THAT. YEAH I MEAN I
THINK I THINK IT'S NICE TO HAVE
THE DATA IN IN PICTURE FORM
ISN'T IT BECAUSE IT REALLY DOES
BRING YOUR EYES TO IT AND I
THINK IT IS- PARTICULAR.
STRIKING THAT THE LARGEST GAPS
AND THE LARGEST NUMBER OF HOURS
NEEDED TO MEET THE MISSION- ARE
IN THOSE KIND OF CORE PUBLIC
TRUST AREAS THE SPECIES
PROTECTION ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION WHERE THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC TO HOLD
OUR OUR RESOURCES M. TO PROTECT
AND CONSERVE OUR RESOURCES. AND
ALSO I THINK WORTH HIGHLIGHTING
THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT WILL FACE INCREASING
CHALLENGES BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE- AND SO THAT THE NUMBER
OF HOURS TO MEET THE MISSION
COULD. HAVE CONCEIVABLY GROW IN
THE COMING YEARS AND COULD TAKE
A ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITIES
SO- I THINK I THINK THAT THAT
THE GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
DROPSHIP WE HAVE OUR CHALLENGE
BEFORE US IT'S NICE TO HAVE THE
DATA. TO UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE
OF THE PROBLEM AND I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION THAT THE THAT
THIS REALLY IS WHAT WE NEED TO
BE DOING IS STARTING TO GRAPPLE
WITH WHAT WHAT DO WE HOW DO WE
HANDLE THIS WHAT ARE THE NEXT
STEPS- BECAUSE- AT THE GAPS ARE
SIGNIFICANT. WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THERE'S REALLY NO
ACTION THAT NEEDS TO BE TAKEN.
DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR THE
UPDATE YOU KNOW. I GUESS I'M A
SIMPLE PERSON I THINK I LIKE
THIS SHORT TERM GOAL OF LOOKING
AT ONE THIRD OF WHAT WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE DOING. WE ALWAYS
TALK ABOUT WHAT A GOOD JOB
GOVERNMENT'S DOING SO IF WE DO
A THIRD OF WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING I GUESS THAT'S A-
THAT'S A- THAT'S THE CEILING SO
FAR NOW BUT- LET'S. THANK YOU
FOR THE- INPUT KNOW SOME PEOPLE
BEEN EAGER TO TALK ABOUT BIO
DIVERSE- AND ARE TIME. ON THE
AND A THAT THE REST. CIVIL
DIRECTOR. OF ONCE AGAIN PLEASE
PROCEED. BASICALLY. NINE- ISSUE
TWENTY NINE. AND COMING OUT OF
THE CAR WE JUST. RECALL ONE OF
THE SLOW. THOSE THE IN WHICH
YOU CAN DEAL WITH YOUR GAS. SO
IN THAT SPIRIT WHAT IS BEFORE
YOU IS A BUDGET CHANGE PURPLE
WHICH A COME TO US OF. AMOUNT
OF ONE AND IN THE- IT'S JUST A
TOUCH OF FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. ON FORTY TWO MILLION
OF THAT IS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND AND THREE MILLION IS ONE
TIME USE THE LAST BEST OF
PROFIT. TWO THROUGH THIS I WHY
TIME INVEST I THINK WE CAN MAKE
NOTE OF DE. IMPROVE IN AREAS
THAT MATTER FOR A MISSION. WE
SHAPE THIS. USING DATA YOU JUST
ME YOU THROUGH IN THE AGENDA
ITEM. AND THROUGHOUT THE VERY
INVESTMENTS IS THIS YEAR IN
THIS ERA OF. WE CAN DO BETTER
WE NEED TO DO BETTER ONE TIME
INVEST IS A WAY TO DO BETTER.
HERE'S HOW FORTY FIVE BROUGH
OUT AT A OVERVIEW OF. AND THEN
BECAUSE TAKE ANY- FOR AREA OF.
INVEST IS INTO CHIU. WILDLIFE
YEAH THOUSAND OF ANIMAL AROUND
THE- ARE PEOPLE POPPING. HAS
LAW BEEN IN WHAT IS AN HABITAT.
THAT PRODUCES ALL. IT AND WHY.
INTERFACE WITH THE JOB. I AND
IN A. FLANDRIA CAN A- FROM
STALKING WHY LIVESTOCK. FREE
CONSTRUCT DEPLOY ANIMA CAGES
WHEN WE- CAPS M. OUTLINE WHO'S
ON THE HOME FORTUNATE AND. AND
MOVED THEM BACK TO WILDER IN
INTO WITH. CAN CREE ENOUGH.
WITH HELPS ON THE MEASURE TO
OUR- THE NEXT EXAMPLE IS WITH
OUR. AIR SUPPORT UNIT R. Y.
OFFICE A SUB ARE. WE PLANES FOR
A VARIETY OF THINGS. MORE OF
OUR FLEET IT IS FORTY FIFTH.
YEARS OLD IT CREATES A
EQUIPMENT AND MAINTENANCE.
BECAUSE IN IN A WING AIRCRAFT.
AND HELP US THIS WAY. THAT'S
BECAUSE CHANGES. WAY MY THE UP
OUR- THERE ARE MORE READ
INTERSPACED WITH. CROWD FISHING.
WE ARE NOW. PLAY OVER THE-
OCEAN DURING THE CRY SEASON. TO
MAKE REAL TO AND- OR ARE
FISHERY. SUCH A THINKING HIM
FISHING. PUT. THE DAY CRAB ON
P. PLAY. WHILE BETTER AVOIDING
WHALE. A EXAMPLE IS OUR
HATCHERY. WE WILL. OUR THE WERE
LAW. HATCHERYPROGRAM BOTH IN.
TROUT IN OCEAN GOING AND HAD.
IN MANY OF THOSE WE ARE USING.
SQUEEZE THE FISH. TO TAKE HEY
AS PART OF THE HAD BROOD
PROCESS IF YOU'VE BEEN OUT. TO
HATCHERY- ON THE AMERICAN RED
JUST IN IN IN EGGS SO MACHINE.
IN SH YOUR PER OUR IN YOUR. IF
HELP YOU ACHIEVE YOUR MISSION.
WETLANDS WE OWN AND. MANAGE
OVER A ACRES WHICH PUTS US
CLOSE THE STATE. IN MANY OF OUR
Y. PROPERTIES ARE THE ROOM. WE
STILL HAVE DR OUT TO STAR A
PUMP. SHE THAT INTO OVER JUST
ARRAY FROM DRIVEN WATER PUMPS
REDUCES OUR CLIMB IMPACT.
IMPROVES OUR BUSINESS
EFFICIENCIES AND ALLOWS US TO
ACTUALLY WET WET LANDS BETTER
FOR THE BENEFIT OF BIRD HABITAT.
ANOTHER EXAMPLE WITHIN THIS
ATTACK. IS INVEST TO COMPLETE
THE- MAPPING FOR MORE OF NORTH
CALIFORNIA FOR THE CLOSE
MAPPING IS A- IT WILL FUEL THE
CONVERSATION- HOW YOU PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY IN THE STATE IS
VERY CAN WITH THE GOVERNOR'S A-
ORDER AND EIGHTY DASH. IT IS
ALSO THE DAY WE- THAT TRY. AND
HOW IN OTHER RELY ON. TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO PERMITTED
DEVELOPMENT RIGHTS. TO MORE
AREAS WE WOODS ABOUT FIVE NINE
DOLLARS TO PURCHASE A NEW
MARINE PATROL VESSEL. SEVERAL
YEARS YOU ALL OF. ON DOING THIS
AND HOW AIM PATROL VESSEL IN
WHAT I BELIEVE WILL FOR BRAG WE
ON THE BRINK OF THAT BALL
DELIVER. AN NOW WITH TO UPDATE
OUR FLEET WITH ANOTHER BOAT.
AND ALLOW. OUR ACCESS ROLE THAT
BAYSIDE HIS AS ORANGE AROUND
HUNDRED AND ANGLERS AND THE USE
FOR AND HOW WHICH IS A STRONG
AND NEED AND OF IN CULVER WE'RE
SEE WRECK USE OR THE RIVER OF
OPERA. WHAT WE HAVEN'T DONE
WITH LAND BAY. IS REALLY
THINKING INTRODUCING IT TO
URBAN COMMUNITY. ISN'T
COMMUNITIES WHO DON'T OFTEN OF
US AS A PARTNER DIRECTLY NOW. A
LOT OF OUR- THAT ARE MORE.
URBAN AREA DON'T HAVE RESTROOMS.
THEY DON'T HAVE SIGNAGE. SO WE
LIKE TO IN. ARLA MANAGE. WITH
OUTREACH TO COME. AND BROUGH
THE OF EARLY FOR CALIFORNIA.
ENJOY COMMUTER IN. OR LOT OF
OUR- DON'T HAVE WHICH HAVE
BETTER SIGNED ABOUT THE TRUE.
ANKLE VALUE AND THE DIE WITH
NAY AMERICAN SOVEREIGNTY. AND
THEN ONE SMALL WIND ITEM SEVEN
HOW FIFTY DOLLAR WHICH WE WOULD
USE FROM THE FUND. MODERNIZE
OUR LIFE PLAN FOR HUNTER. AND
ANGLERS WHY. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
ALL WE'RE MOVE OUT OF PAPER TO
DIGITAL THIS CREATES BUSINESS
EFFICIENCY FOR US. ALSO OUR-
ISSUE ABOUT. ONE THOUSAND- IN
THE FOR AND SHE- MORE OF THOSE
WARNINGS ARE BECAUSE A HUNTER
AND ANGLER. DOESN'T KNOW WHERE
THEY ALL ON THE LAN REAL OF THE
REGULATE THAT UP. I DID YOU
THIS. MAKING IT. VERY AND APPS.
WE BOTH. I AM. WILL CHANGE AND
OUR ONE OFFICER WILL HAVE
FREEDOM TIME. TO DEDICATE THAT.
FREED UP TO MORE. BERMAN THE
WITH THE PLAN WHY. BOB TRUST.
THAT'S. TOUGH TO BOTTOM KIND OF
QUICK SUMMARY OF THE
FIVE NINE I'LL STOP THERE ANY
BY SO THEORY IS THE WAR THERE
THE. PERSON OR THE HIGH OUT
THERE THEY STOPPED TO ASK. FOR
THEIR LAW TO DON'T HAVE A
SENSORY PLAY YOUR PHONE HERE'S
THE APP. THE HIT YOUR CREDIT
CARD OR IT RIGHT NOW MOVES TAKE
CARE THIS I KNOW YOUR LIFE.
FIRST ISSUE. WAR JUST GET YOUR
LICENSE RIGHT NOW IS THAT SORT
OF WHAT YOU WERE. BE ALL. NINE
FISH AND HUNTING IN THE- WE.
ALLIES IS IF I. WHAT I SHOULD
CLARIFY. IS WHEN PEOPLE ARE IN
THE- THERE ARE UP TO. RIVER
THEY MAY. NOT KNOW THE FROM THE
BRIDGE. OF TO THE ROCK DOWN. IS
A- NO TAKE STRESS OF THE RIVER
YOU CAN. TAKE A HOME. BECAUSE
THEY MAY. REALIZE THE REGULAR.
OF TO THE WATER. ARE SCHOOL WAY
OF DOING. IS HAD TO CARRY
AROUND A PAPER. THAT LIKE ONE.
RUN ONS. OVER HUNDRED PAGES.
DESCRIBING ALL THESE REGULATE.
WE ARE NOW. TO ALL. SO THAT IN
ANGLER IN THE- ASSUMING SERVICE.
COULD FIVE THEIR- LOOK. AND
THEN HAVE THE- FOR THEM RIGHT
THERE IN THE. FIELD YOU COULD
WE WILL BE ABLE TO PUT. WERE
THE BEST FISHING ON THAT PATH
THAT THEY WOULD BE TO HACK THAT
WE'RE NOT SLATED. TO CAN. THERE
EVEN IF YOU WANTED TO STICK
WITHIN THAT SAME- PROPOSED
DOLLAR AMOUNT YOU COULD- FUND
DIFFERENT MIXES OF OFFENDING
WITHIN THESE PROPOSED
ACTIVITIES ARE FUN DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES. I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS
JUST THAT MOUNTAIN MOST OF
THESE ACTIVITIES DO NOT FOCUS
ON THE SPECIES AND HABITAT
CONSERVATION AREA THAT WAS
HIGHLIGHTED AS WHERE THE
BIGGEST GAP IS. ONE EIGHT ONE
THAT DOES IS THE VEGETATION
MAPPING SO IF YOU WANTED TO FOR
EXAMPLE PUT GREATER EMPHASIS ON
ON THAT CATEGORY OF ACTIVITIES
YOU CULD. SHIP SOME FUNDING TO
FIND A HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THE
STATE FOR THE VEGETATION
MAPPING OR SOME OTHER ONE TIME
ACTIVITIES THAT ADDRESS THAT-
AREA OF ACTIVITY SO- DECENT
PROPOSAL FOR YOU BUT NOT YOUR
ONLY APPROACH I THINK THE ONE
AREA THAT WE WOULD HIGHLIGHT IS
FOR THAT SMALL LINE ITEM THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. DOLLARS FOR THE
HUNTING AND FISHING LICENSE
SYSTEM UPGRADES THAT DOES SEEM
LIKE SOMETHING THAT COULD VERY
JUSTIFIABLY BE FUNDED THROUGH
USER FEES RATHER THAN THE
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE THERE ARE
VERY CLEAR BENEFICIARY SO YOU
COULD ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO
LOOK INTO WHETHER THERE MAY BE
OTHER FUNDING AVAILABLE- FROM
THOSE USER FEES TO SUPPORT AT
LEAST A PART OF THAT COST TO
FREE UP SOME OF THE GENERAL
FUND FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES- BUT
OVERALL AT REASONABLE PACKAGE
BEFORE YOU TO CONSIDER. THANK
YOU- VICE CHAIRS DOT DOLLY. YOU
RECOGNIZE I JUST WANTED. THIS
IS FOR THE DIRECTOR- AS
SOMEBODY WHO IS AN AVID HUNTER
AND FISHERMAN AN OUTDOORS
PERSON I'M SUPER EXCITED ABOUT
THE OVERLAY FOR THE MAPPING- I
ACTUALLY PAY- I THINK IT'S
THIRTY DOLLARS A YEAR TO ONYX
HOT WHICH IDENTIFIES THE ZONES
AND- PARCELS SO YOU KNOW YOU'RE
ON WHERE YOU'RE AT ACTUALLY IS
CRITICAL AND IT I THINK THAT'S
A GREAT TOOL FOR. THOSE OF US
WHO RESPECT PRIVATE PROPERTY
RIGHTS TO BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE ON THE WAY WE WANT TO BE
AND NOT ON SOMEBODY ELSE'S
PROPERTY BUT MY QUESTION IS
THERE ABILITY- TO. ALLOW I MEAN
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU GO IN AND
PURCHASE YOUR TAGS OR YOUR
LICENSE IN YOUR IN A DRAW FOR
EXAMPLE EVEN IF YOU GET DRAWN
FURTHER SAID TAG. AND- YOU KNOW
IT'S IF IT'S A PIECE OF PAPER
THAT TELLS YOU HOW THE TAX SO
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE- PROBLEMS
IS WITH MOST PEOPLE THAT ARE
OUT AS IT SOMETIMES YOU LOSE
THAT SOMETIMES YOU. NEED A
STAMP ON IT IF IT'S A YOU KNOW-
MIGRATORY BIRD LYSONS AND SO IS
THERE SOME WAY TO DIGITIZE THAT
SO THAT. YOU COULD JUST PUT MY
NAME IN BRIAN DOLLY AND YOU
KNOW. WHAT I'VE ALREADY
PURCHASED THAT I PURCHASED MY
TECH ONLINE SO I KNOW YOU HAVE
A STAMP ON THE FEDERAL SIDE.
FOR LIKE A MIGRATORY BIRD BUT
YOU'RE UP LINK UP JAN GAME AND
THOSE I KNOW ARE ON THE STATE
SIDE. ARE RIGHT ON YOUR RIGHT
ON YOUR LICENSE SO IS THERE
SOME WAY WE COULD. MAKE THAT SO
THAT THE ONE THAT WHEN YOU
ENCOUNTER WITH THE WARDEN THEY
GO HEY WHERE'S YOUR ID YOU SHOW
YOUR ID'S GOT YOUR PICTURE ON
IT THEY KNOW WHAT YOU. AND THEY
ARE ABLE TO TOUCH THEIR
COMPUTER AND KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU PURCHASED. YES THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE HEADED. AWESOME THAT'S-
PART OF. THE THEORY BEHIND THIS.
A MINUTE AMOUNT OF MONEY. WE
MAY NOT GET THERE COMPLETELY
YOU KNOW IN THE NEXT BUDGET
YEAR. OFTEN WHEN WE'RE DOING
TECHNOLOGY CHANGE WE HAVE A
FAIR AMOUNT OF PROCESS WE NEED
TO GO THROUGH WITH THAT.
CALIFORNIA ARMINE TECHNOLOGY
AND SENATOR ANOTHER ASPECT
WITHIN THIS SPACE IS- WHEN YOU
PURCHASE A LICENSE PARTICULARLY
WITH FISHING. OUR WHOLE WAY HAS
BANNED ITS GOOD FOR JUST THE
REMAINDER OF THE CALENDAR YEAR
OF COURSE IF YOU BUY IT IN
SEPTEMBER IT'S NOT AS- BAD AS
MUCH VALUE IF YOU HAD BOTHERED
AND- YOU KNOW JANUARY. AND
WHERE WE'RE HEADED TO ENSURE HE
IS. FROM THE DATE OF PURCHASE
IT'S GOOD FOR THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS. ALL OF THESE
ARE TECHNOLOGY IMPROVEMENTS
WHICH CAN INCREASE THE ABILITY
FOR PEOPLE TO BREAK THE
BARRIER. AND BE OUTSIDE WAR.
BEING OUTSIDE MORE AS PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS IT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS WE'RE NOTICING IN THE
PANDEMIC. AND AS THE FEES OUR
HUNTERS AND ANGLERS IN THE
STATE THEY DON'T PAY THE
HIGHEST FEES IN THE NATION- BUT
THEY PAY SOME OF THE HIGHEST
FEES- I DO THINK THERE IS A
BROAD BENEFIT WHEN WE CAN MAKE
THESE TECHNOLOGY. IMPROVEMENTS
FOR HUNTERS AND ANGLERS I AM IN
FULL AGREEMENT WITH YOU I
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. THE AROUND IT
WHENEVER YOU PURCHASED A
LICENSE IT'S GOOD FOR LIKE A
FISHING LICENSE THREE OR SIXTY
FIVE I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HAVE
THEM IN MY OPINION THIS IS A
PLACE WHERE WE SHOULD SPEND
MORE MONEY BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'LL ACTUALLY. RECEIVE MORE
MONEY IF THE PROCESS WORKS IN A
BETTER WAY AND IT LOOK. THOSE
OF US WHO UDERSTAND. THE
IMPORTANCE OF GETTING OUT IN
THE IN THE OUTDOORS AND
RECREATION IN THE FAMILY VALUES
IN THOSE THINGS. IT'S NOT SO
MUCH THE MONEY IT'S IT IT'S
ABOUT MAKING IT EASY SO WE CAN
ABIDE BY THE LAWS AND ACTUALLY.
WE WERE SUPPOSED TO BE AND
ENJOY THE THINGS AND THOSE OF
US WHO ARE CARED ABOUT THE
PROTECTIONS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT TAKING. A FISH
IN THE WRONG PLACE OR OR IT'S
JUST CASUALLY SORT OF BARTLETT
TOOK I MEAN THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF AS YOU KNOW. RESTRICTIONS
AND THERE'S REASONS FOR THOSE
BUT WE WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
DOING RIGHT SO I APPRECIATE.
YOUR WORK ON THIS. AND I
THOUGHT WHEN THE RANGER PUT
YOUR NAME IN THE MACHINE IT LIT
UP LIKE A LAS VEGAS SIDE. SLOT
MACHINES NOW THAT'S A- VERY
GOOD THAT'S A CLARIFICATION
SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT MR HERE. I'LL BE QUICK
LOOK I THINK THE ONE THING I
JUST WANNA SAY IN REGARDS TO
YOU HAVE THE DIRECTOR SAID
BECAUSE OF THE ADDITIONAL FOUR
HUNDRED MANDATE SIX ADDRESS
THAT'S BEEN ADVANCED BY. THE
LEGISLATURE IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THEY'RE SEEN-
CHALLENGES WITH THEIR BUDGET
BUT- I GUESS THIS IS IT. BEGS
THE QUESTION WHY DOESN'T THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
ADVANCE SOMEBODY CHANGE
RIPPLES. IF THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO SEE A DIFFERENT
DOLLARS. THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE DEPARTMENT IS ALWAYS
WELCOME TO GO TO PUT ADDITIONAL
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
FORWARD. TO BE A RECOVER WHAT
THOSE POTENTIAL MANDATES MAYBE.
I THINK THAT GETS US BACK TO
THE BIG PICTURE. IS THAT. LOOK
THERE IS A LOT TO LIKE. IN THIS
FORTY FIVE MILLION. I THINK IT
MAKES SENSE. I DON'T
NECESSARILY AGREE THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WHEN HE SAYS WHY DON'T WE JUST
KEEP GOING IN AND POTENTIALLY
LOOKING AT USER FEE INCREASES
WE'VE SEEN SIGNIFICANT USER FEE
INCREASES. IT'S NOT A
SUSTAINABLE STRATEGY. FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
OR ANYOTHER DEPARTMENT- IF
WE'RE SERIOUS ABOUT FINDING-
WILDLIFE. AND CONSERVATION. AND
HABITAT. THEN WE HAVE TO PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS.
AND DEVELOP A LONG TERM PLAN.
TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
RESOURCES IN THE STATE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE AGE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. AND WE'RE NEVER
GONNA GET AHEAD IF WE'RE DOING
THIS YEAR BY YEAR. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE CONTINUED TO FOR SIX
FLIPPING YEARS WE'VE DONE THIS
YEAR BY YEAR. AND I SAY THAT
IS. THIS ISN'T JUST THE
LEGISLATURE'S FAULT. THIS IS
JUST AS MUCH. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FAULT THE
DEPARTMENT'S FAULT. FOR NOT
PUTTING FORWARD A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. THAT'S THE BOTTOM
LINE. SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THAT. THAT
CONVERSATION I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL. BECAUSE I HEAR ABOUT
THE MANDATES. BUT AGAIN. DURING
ANY BUDGET- LONG TERM FULL TIME
FINDING IS ALWAYS WELCOME- BYE
ONE QUESTION I WOULD SAY TO.
THE DIRECTOR MISTER DIRECTOR
AND WE CAN TAKE THIS OFFLINE.
IN THIS IS. VERY SPECIFIC TO
THE NORTH COAST. BUT IT WOULD
BE GREAT TO GET A UPDATE ON THE
L. STAY. OUT FOR. HOME AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE AGAIN
DIRECTOR WE CAN TAKE THAT OFF
LINE. IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION AND EXPECT YOU TO
HAVE IT IS THAT'S- VERY.
FOCUSED ON THE NORTH COAST AND
THINK YOU CAN MISTER DIRECTOR
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. SOONER
I'LL ASK. JUST CONTACT YOURS
NEXT WEEK RELATIVE TO THAT
QUESTION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANKS VERY MUCH. BEFORE GOING
TO CENTER STERN WITH GO BACK TO
VICE CHAIR DOLLY HAS A FOLLOW
UP. SO ONE OF THE THANK YOU.
FOR THE DRUG DRUG ONE OF THE
THINGS I DID NOT SEE. IN THIS
PROPOSAL IS THE- THE MARIJUANA-
PROLIFERATION AND THE- AND THEN
BAYERN MENTAL PROBLEMS AT WORK
ARE FACED WITH THE ILLEGAL
GROWS- MAINLY. ELISE MY
DISTRICT CITY COUNTY IS JUST.
COMPLETELY CRAZY RIGHT NOW SO
IS THERE WHAT'S THE PLAN. FOR
CEMENT AND- THOSE TYPE
ACTIVITIES- IN YOUR BUDGET. SO
THE REASON YOU DON'T SEE IT IN
THIS AGENDA ITEM SENATOR IS
THIS IS A SET OF ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS PRIMARILY GENERAL
FUND. AND THE ITEMS IN THIS
PACKAGE ON THIS ISSUE SHOULD BE
KIND OF FAMILIAR BECAUSE WE
PROPOSED MANY OF THEM ALMOST A
YEAR AGO. AND THEY ALL HAD TO
BE TABLED ON BECAUSE OF THE
ECONOMIC KIND OF. WHIPLASH
COMING OUT OF THE CODED
EXPERIENCE WHICH A YEAR AGO WAS
MUCH NEWER FOR ALL OF US. THIS
PACKAGE ALSO HAS HAD A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDER. I HAVE ENGAGEMENT
AROUND DESIGN SO WE THOUGHT
THROUGH WHAT MIGHT BE A BROADLY
REPRESENTATIVE SAID A ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THAT ENOUGH OF OUR
DIVERSE STAKEHOLDERS MAY BE
ABLE TO SEE THEIR INTEREST AND-
ALSO THE CANNABIS WE HAVE A
GRANTING PROGRAM UNDER PROP
SIXTY FOUR. AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A BUSY AND GROWING NO PUN
INTENDED- ENGAGEMENT WITH EACH
OF THE COUNTIES PARTICULARLY
THE SHERIFF LEVEL. THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT REALLY RELATES TO
OUR PROGRAM. IN OUR PROGRAM IS
REALLY DRIVEN AROUND THE
ONGOING PERMANENT NEED. WHEREAS
THESE ARE ONE TIME INVESTMENTS
WHICH IS WHY. IN MY OPINION LA-
MAKES A FAIR CRITIQUE OF THIS
ONE TIME PACKAGE YOU'RE NOT
INVESTING AND SPECIES OR
PERMITTING. MY ANSWER IS TO
REALLY MOVE THE NEEDLE IN THOSE
SPACES. IT REALLY NEEDS TO BE
ONGOING PERMANENT INVESTMENT
NOT ONE TIME. SO SIR MOST OF
OUR CAMPUS WORK IS OVER IN
ANOTHER PART OF OUR BUDGET
THAT'S AROUND ONGOING AND
PERMANENT. NOT THIS ONE TIME.
FIVE FINANCE MISTER AGUILAR
VIEWER WOULD LIKE TO WEIGH IN.
YES I GUESS- DRIVE OVER THE
HEART OF FINANCE- SO JUST- KIND
OF ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND INTO WHAT DIRECTOR OUTSIDE
ON THE KIND OF TAX FUND SO
THERE'S ABOUT SIXTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS PROPOSED AND
THE BUDGET YEAR FOR DEPART OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE I RELATE THAT
TO THEIR CANNABIS EFFORTS
ADDING SPECIFICALLY- M. PROP
SIXTY FOUR ONE OF THE
ALLOCATIONS- DEPARTMENT
RECEIVES- IT IS BASED OFF OF.
CANNABIS TAX. WE'RE ACTUALLY
SEEING FUNDING AND THAT REVENUE
AS A YEAR OVER YEAR OTHER
DEPARTMENTS GETTING AN
ADDITIONAL TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS NEXT YEAR- AND A LOT OF
THAT DOES GO TO CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT. DOES NOT IN THIS
B. C. V. BUT IT IS IN THEIR
BUDGET AND THAT'S CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED SO THAT'S WHY YOU
DON'T SEE IT- IN THE AGENDAS
AND OF THE PROPOSAL- THE
INCREASE JUST GOES INTO THEIR
BASELINE BUDGET. AND ALLOW THEM
TO DO THAT WORK FOR CANDIDATES.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION CENTER STARTED
TO RECOGNIZE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I APPRECIATE ACTUALLY
YOU'VE BEEN SORT OF- DIRECTOR
TOUCHED ON WHAT MY QUESTION IS
CAN BE ABOUT WHICH IS THAT. ONE
TIME VERSUS LONGER TERM I JUST
WANT TO PULL THAT THREAD A
LITTLE MORE HERE G. IS BECAUSE
IT IT SEEMS LIKE. I MEAN. IT'S
NOT ALL OR NOTHING RIGHT YOU
CAN DO SOME MULTI YEAR FUNDING
PLANS THAT DON'T HAVE A MIX
THERE'S NOT THERE'S NOT
SOMETHING PRECLUDING YOU SAY
FROM. WE KEEP GIVING YOU A
LONGER TERM ENCUMBRANCE PERIOD
AND SAY YOU KNOW WE WANT TO
TACKLE- THIS SPECIES RECOVERY
PLAN. OR YOU KNOW FOCUS ON SOME
SOME SORT OF MORE PUBLIC FACING
VISIONARY MISSION DRIVEN GOALS
AND MAYBE MIXING THOSE IN WITH
THAT REALLY CORE OPERATIONAL
STUFF BUT JUST SO WE CAN SHOW
EVEN WHAT WE MEAN YOU KNOW. AND
I AND I AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONSERVATISM IN SOME WAY THAT
THEY'RE NOT ONE OF PROMISE OVER
PROMISE AND THEN NOT BE ABLE TO
DELIVER AN IN YEAR. FOUR FIVE-
THAT'S ACTUALLY WE WE'RE GONNA
HIT A CLIFF BUT I THINK WE NEED
THAT URGENCY WE HAVE TO SET UP
THAT- THAT EXPECTATION FOR
OURSELVES AND SO I JUST. I
DON'T KNOW IF. LMAO OR THE
DEPARTMENT HAVE JUST
HYPOTHETICAL- SORT OF- YOU KNOW
SORT OF EXAMPLES OF WHAT THAT
KIND OF MULTI YEAR. BUT THE ONE
TIME MULTI YEAR APPROACH COULD
LOOK LIKE AND MAYBE WHAT
OPTIONS WERE. ASSESSED OR
WHETHER. IF IN DEPARTMENT LAND
YOU'RE JUST SAYING YOU KNOW
THIS IS ONE TIME WE'RE JUST
GONNA STAY IN CAPITAL
INVESTMENT AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE OKAY. SO THEN YOU
HAD YOU DIDN'T REALLY D THAT
THINKING THERE BUT IT'S GOT AT
LEAST BEING YOUR SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING. THINKING RIGHT OF
WHERE IN SOME OF THOSE EARLY. I
DON'T COME SHOVEL READY MISSION
DRIVEN MULTI YEAR INITIATIVES
THE THINGS THAT WE KNOW WE HAVE
TO DO RIGHT NOW- CAN EITHER OF
YOU JUST WAIT WAIT ON THAT A
LITTLE MORE. MISS SELLERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO GO FIRST. HI YOU'RE
PROBABLY DIRECTED BETTER
POSITION THAT THAT EXAMPLE WE
GAVE IN OUR REPORT WAS THE ONE
THAT SENATOR STERN MENTIONED
WHICH IS THAT RECOVERY PLANS
FOR INDIVIDUAL SPECIES THAT
SEEM LIKE A DISCRETE ACTIVITY
BECAUSE AS YOU. AS YOU
MENTIONED SENATOR IF IT'S ONE
TIME MONEY EVEN FOR SPRING AND
ACROSS MULTIPLE YEARS WE WANT
TO BE SURE THAT IT'S A DISCRETE
ACTIVITY THAT DOESN'T KIND OF.
LIVE LONGER THAN THE FUNDING SO
THAT SEEMED LIKE A GOOD
DISCRETE ACTIVITY TO US AND
WHEN IT WAS PROPOSED IN LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET FOR ONGOING
FUNDING THAT THEN- HAD TO BE
RETRACTED DUE TO THE- AND- I
MAKE. PHYSICAL CONDITION BUT
WITH GETTING AT THOSE SPECIES
AND HABITAT CONSERVATION GOAL
THAT WE HAVE ARTICULATED- THAT
THAT R. AS BEST PRESENT IN THIS
PACKAGE BUT DR BONHAM OUGHT.
FOR TO YOU. IS SANDRA I'LL TRY
TO. THINK OF OUR EXAMPLE
HYPOTHETICAL THAT MAY RESONATE
WITH THE PANEL THE MEMBERS. SO
I CAN THINK OF TO. SO WE
PROPOSE A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
TO PURCHASE A NEW OR FIXED WING
AIRCRAFT. WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
CLOSE TO COMPLETING A FEDERAL
PERMITTING PROCESS TO GET THE
FIRST EVER OCEAN HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN FOR WALES. I
THINK IN THE NATION. AND WE
HAVE NEWLY CREATED STATE
REGULATIONS TRYING TO MANAGE
THE DELICACY BETWEEN MARINE
MAMMALS AND ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT COMMERCIAL FISHERIES
CRAP. SO IF ONE WERE TO THINK
ABOUT THE FUTURE I COULD
PROJECT WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
WORK IN THIS SPACE. AND THIS
ADDITIONAL WORK COULD MEAN YOU
TRY TO BUILD OUT- MARINE MAMMAL
PROGRAM. YOU KNOW THAT THAT IF
WE'RE SUCCESSFUL WE HAVE LESS
THAN TEN MONTHS OF WALES. AND
WE CAN KEEP A COMMERCIAL
DUNGENESS CRAB FISHERY THAT'S
IN OUR THIRD MOST VALUABLE FOR
HARD WORKING MEN AND WOMEN. SO
YOU COULD USE THE ONE TIME
INVESTMENT TO GET A BOMB AND
YOU COULD TRY TO FIGURE OUT
OVER TIME HOW YOU TAILOR THAT
TOOK US. I GIVE YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE. NOW LANDS NOT THAT I
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT AN
INTEREST OF YOURS- SO AS YOU
KNOW WE'RE GOING THROUGH OUR
SCIENTIFIC PROCESS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THEY SHOULD BE
PROTECTED UNDER STATE LAW.
WHETHER THEY SHOULD OR
SHOULDN'T THE FACT IS THEY
EXIST ACROSS LARGE PARTS OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. AT THE
SAME TIME WE NEED TO MODERNIZE
A LOT OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
GRID. WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION WHILE LIFE AT
THE SAME TIME YOU CAN THINK
ABOUT CONNECTIVITY. SO YOU MAY
BE. YOU KNOW WHY YOU'RE DOING A
ONE TIME INVESTMENT AROUND
CREATING CHANGES TO CAPTURE
ANIMALS WHEN THEY'RE IN HARM'S
WAY AND MOVE THEM YOU CAN ALSO
BE THINKING ABOUT HOW DO YOU
BRING A MARRIAGE- BETWEEN
TRANSPORTATION WILDLIFE SIMPLY
BILL TWELVE EIGHTY TWO STARTED
THIS. AND THEN THINK ORIGINALLY
ABOUT CONNECTIVITY PROJECTS
WELL TO DO THAT YOU NEED PEOPLE
WHO CAN DO MAPPING IN PLANNING
AND YOU ALMOST NEED A MULTI
UNIT YOU KNOW IT NEVER. I THINK
THERE ARE WAYS YOU CAN DO THAT.
HERE'S THE CABBIE OUT- YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR IN THIS WE'RE IN A
TOUGH ECONOMIC SITUATION AND I
YOU KNOW I'M FOCUSED ON ONE
TIME BECAUSE ONGOING AND
PERMANENT IS MORE CHALLENGING.
WHERE DO I FIND REVENUE SOURCES
FROM GOING IN PERMITTING. V. P.
N. CREASES WON'T DO IT GENERAL
FUND IS CHALLENGING YEAH THAT'S
PART AND PARCEL OF THE STRUGGLE
I THINK AND IF YOU KNOW FINANCE
WITH ONE AWAY IN THERE I THINK
THAT'S EMBLEMATIC OF THE-
DESIRE. BUT THE DIFFICULT. BUT
I WOULD BE I WOULD APPRECIATE
IN IN SAY JUST GIVEN OUR LAST
CUT- THE LAST ISSUE WE SORT OF
WRESTLED WITH. WHAT'S A STABLE
FUNDING STRATEGY COULD LOOK
LIKE BUT IS THERE A VERSION AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THAT
SORT OF MAKES OF. ONE TIME
STARTED AT CAPITAL INVESTMENT
THE DIRECTORS TALKING ABOUT BUT
THEN MAYOR BUT THAT'S SORT OF
MARRIAGE TO- YOU ARE I DON'T
CALL IT A FULL ON GOING BUT I
GUESS- A MISSION COMMITMENT
THAT KIND OF MULTI YEAR BASIS
IS THEIR OPENNESS TO THAT. THAT
KIND OF HYBRIDIZED APPROACH IF
YOU WILL. SIR DR APARNA
FINANCE. YEAH I THINK I WOULD
SAY AS AN EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING
WE DID LAST- RELATED TO. THE
STATEWIDE BOBCAT MANAGEMENT
PLAN THAT WAS. LIKE THE FIRST
TWO YEARS WERE HIGHER
INVESTMENT I THINK A COUPLE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THEN IT-
PROVIDED A KIND OF A SMALLER
ALLOCATION FOR THE DEPARTMENT
THE OUT YEARS THAT DID ALL THE
ONE EXAMPLE OF YOU KNOW ARE
VERY RECENT. REVOLTED BY THE
MINISTRATION WHERE IT IS NOT IN
THE SPECIES MONITORING REALM
WHERE WE DID KIND OF TAKE A
HYBRID APPROACH OF A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER INVESTMENT IN THEFIRST
COUPLE YEARS ACKNOWLEDGING
AVAILABILITY ONE TIME BUT THEN-
KIND OF WAR A MORE MODERATE-
OUT HERE- SO YOU KNOW THAT
THERE ARE EXAMPLES THAT YOU
KNOW IT RECENTLY. I HAVE A LAST
YEAR ADMINISTRATION HAS DONE-
IN THAT KIND OF SCENARIO I YOU
KNOW AGAIN YOU KNOW OPEN TO
CONVERSE. ON THIS I BEEN JUST
KIND OF ACKNOWLEDGE- STAFF
CAPACITY WEIGHT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT AND SO IT'S AN
EXPENSE THERE IS- YOU KNOW.
ADDITIONAL NEEDS THAT REQUIRE
STAFFING AND THEN YOU REQUIRE
PERMIT LEVEL STAFFING BUT THERE
IS ISN'T AN AGREEMENT- NO LEVEL
OF FUNDING FOR THEIR STAFFING
THEN YOU'RE CREATING I NOW YOUR
GAP. OR YOU HAVE PERMITS THAT
POTENTIALLY BUT THEY'RE NOT THE
FUNDING BEHIND IT AND THAT DOES
CREATE YOU KNOW LIABILITY THEN
IT KIND OF ONGOING FUNDING
LIABILITY AND SO I THINK YOU
KNOW IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
DETAILS OF THE PROPOSALS- BUT
YOU KNOW AS AS HE DOUBLED FROM
LAST YEAR WHICH WHICH WE DID.
PUT INTO THE BUDGET OTHER
EXAMPLES- ARE SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. THANKS SO MUCH
FOR THAT. LOOK AT WHAT FURTHER
ENGAGEMENT THERE. YEAH THOSE
EGGS SUPER HELPFUL. I THINK
PART OF THE- THANK OUR LEASE
WITH SENATOR STERN UNDERSCORES
A SORT IT'S LIKE IN THE SCHOOL
SPACE AND EVERYBODY WANTS TO
GET COMPUTERS FOR KIDS BUT YOU
WANT TO GO OUT AND BUY A 100%
OF ALL THE COMPUTERS THIS YEAR
BECAUSE IN THREE YEARS A 100%
YOUR COMPUTERS CAN BE WORN OUT
SO. SO WE ASSUME THAT WITH ONE
AIRPLANE AND MAYBE ANOTHER
AIRPLANE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT THAT MODERNIZES
THE FLEET I GUESS WHAT'S
MISSING HERE IS SORT OF. WOULD
WOULD I THINK WE'VE MET THE
SENATOR IS GETTING AT IS YOU
KNOW WHAT'S WHAT WOULD BE THE
NEXT STEP OF FOR INSTANCE THE
VISITOR AMENITIES AND STATE
LANDS IT'S GREAT THAT THERE'S
SIX MILLION IN HERE. ONE TIME
GET SOME TOILETS SOME
VISIBILITY DONE BUT IF WE WHAT
WILL BE THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP
IS SIX MILLION AND A SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM OR IS IT
SIX MILLION AND A TEN MILLION
DOLLAR IN IOWA. A BILL DOT SO
WE GET SOME. R. I. OF HOW
THAT'S GOING TO WORK AND WHEN.
AND IF WE'RE TALKING BOATS IS
THAT YOU KNOW IS THAT ONE VOTE
IT'S ONE VOTE ARE THERE. I
CAN'T REMEMBER SHE PROBABLY
KNOW THIS BUT IS THAT HOW MANY
BOATS ARE IN THE FLEET AND IT
WHAT IS OFF THE COAST VERSUS
WHAT'S IN LAND AND ALL THOSE
THINGS SO WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
THE MATTER ALSO. ARE SO WE CAN
HAVE THOSE. A LIMITING
DISCUSSIONS LATER ON AND SEEING
NO OTHER HANDS OUR GROUP HOLD
THAT MATTER THE MOVE INTO
ISSUE. NUMBER THIRTY END OF AN
INVITE TO FORCE THE FIRE
PROTECTION DEPARTMENT TO
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. AND- THE DEPARTMENT%
OF WATER RESOURCES TO TALK
ABOUT. ONE TIME DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ALLOCATION. FOR CAL
FIRE IS T. W. R. AND- THERE ARE
PARKS SYSTEM AND I BELIEVE. WE
HAVE. HI DIRECTOR DUGAN IS
GOING TO START US OFF. THE CAT
LITTER FOR GEORGIA GOVERNOR
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALL
KICK AT ALL OKAY THEN WE HAVE-
I HAVE A COLLEAGUE FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS WHO COULD SPEAK TO
A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAILS- SO
THE BUDGET DOES INCLUDE A
HUNDRED AND FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TOO. THE
PERSON CRITICAL DEPARTMENT
NEEDS OR DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES ARE FACT CAL FIRE
ALTHOUGH THIS PROPOSAL IS PART
OF A BROADER ADMINISTRATION
PACKAGE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION. INTENDED FOR
MAINTENANCE. HOWEVER DIFFERENT-
INTERSTATE EVEN BETTER IN. HELP
SUPPORT THE BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS. YOU KNOW REDUCE
THE NEED TO BUILD MORE
COSTLIER- INFRASTRUCTURE AND IF
YOU KNOW IT IS WRONG REALLY
SUPPORTED THE ADMINISTRATION'S
CLIMATE RESILIENCE GOALS- AND
AGAIN WE HAVE REPRESENTED FROM
DEPARTMENT THAT COULD SPEAK. TO
THEIR SPECIFIC DEPARTMENTS-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROPOSALS
EITHER MORE QUESTIONS WHAT I
FOUND I WANT TO HEAR FROM ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS I THINK. I
DON'T WANT TO PUT WORDS INTO
THEIR MOUTHS PART OF THIS
STARTS WITH FINANCE IN AND PART
OF IT. IT TALKS ABOUT THE WEEK
THAT WE HAVE GIVEN IT OUT-
GIVEN THE AMOUNT OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCETHAT WE HAVE IN IN
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AT N.
TWENTY MILLION. DOLLARS FOR
PARK IS THAT. GIVEN THE FAULT
IS THAT THAT'S THAT'S A- TO IT
IN EVERY THANKFUL FOR THAT BUT
GIVEN YOU KNOW. MAYBE TWENTY
SIX BILLION DOLLARS EXTRA THE
BUDGET AS A STAFF REPORTS
ANALYZE IS REALLY IS THIS THE
TIME NOT TO- BE MORE-
AGGRESSIVE AS FAR AS HE'S ONE
TIME- DEFERRED- AS IN
INVESTMENTS I GUESS THAT'S IT
BECAUSE I'M SURE THE PARK
PEOPLE IN THE US CAL FIRE GONNA
SAY MORE IS BETTER RIGHT- BUT
THE CHOICES THAT YOU MADE YOU
KNOW YOU GOT. FIVE THOUSAND
PROJECTS WITH THE PARKS WITH
ONE POINT TWO SEVEN. BILLION
DOLLARS IN RENT TWENTY MILLION
I DON'T KNOW WHAT PERCENTAGE IS
BUT IT'S A LOW PERCENT. FOR
YEAH I GOT. I THINK WE ALL KNOW
IT REALLY IS JUST YOU KNOW-
ACKNOWLEDGING THERE'S MANY
INVESTMENTS IN THE BUDGET
ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT AREAS AND
A BIG PIECE OF THE INVESTMENT
THIS YEAR WERE ALSO PART OF THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE- WOULD
REALLY HELP SUPPORT ECONOMIC
STIMULUS- YOU KNOW BROUGHT. AND
SO. IT IS PART OF THE BALANCING
OF THE PARTY THAN THE BUDGET WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT INFORMATION IS
ALL. YOU NEED WHICH IS WHY WE
ARE PUTTING FORWARD TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ACROSS
THE STATE- BUT AGAIN IT REALLY
IS ABOUT THE AGAINST ALL THE
OTHER PRIORITIES I WOULD YOU
ALSO SEE ENDED BUDGET. WITH YOU
KNOW RT FOR A PARTITION WALL
LIFE- YOU KNOW- AGENDA ITEM IN
A COUPLE- YOU KNOW MINUTES WILL
BE THE CAL FIRE- YOU KNOW. BY
RESILIENCE PACKAGES SO THERE'S
A LOT OF. THAT DEMONSTRATION IT
IS A FOCUSING AND TRY TO
SUPPORT- AND A TWO HUNDRED
THIS IS ALSO A PRIORITY- BUT
THERE THERE'S OTHER PARTY NEEDS
ABOUT EIGHT. AND WE'RE HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS MISS EHLERS-
YOUR INPUT. YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
REVIEWED ALL THE PROPOSALS AND-
I THINK THEY'RE ALL REASONABLE-
WE'VE DISCUSSED MANY TIMES IN
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE PAST THAT
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS A GOOD
USE OF ONE TIME MANY- IT RALLY
WITH THAT ADDRESSES AREAS OF
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AND IS A-
THAT IS ONE OF THOSE DISCRETE
PROJECTS THAT HAS A BEGINNING
AND AN END- ALL THE DEPARTMENT
HAD GOOD JUSTIFICATION AND A-
CLEAR PRIORITIZATION PROCESS
FOR HOW THEY'RE GOING TO USE
THE FUNDS. SO NO CONCERNS TO
RACE HERE YEAH NO I JUST SAY
JUST IF THERE IS A TWENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS WERE
PUT THE HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S
LIKE ONE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTIETH- AT AND THIS IS. THE
LEAST OF ALL THE TIME THAT I'VE
SAT IN THIS CHAIR IT'S WHEN WE
SEE WE HAVE ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS THIS IS THE TIME TO
DO IT AND I'M THINKING ONE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTIETH SEEM SKIMPY
BUT- LET'S GO TO LET'S LET'S
WAIT HAVE THE PARKS WHERE YET-
MISS MCCOURT. DEPUTY MAKE WORK
WITH THE WITH THE PARKS HERE'S-
YOUR PROPOSED TO GET TWO
HUNDRED MILLION OUT OF ONE
POINT TWO SEVEN BILLION THE
FIVE THOUSAND PROJECTS OUTLOOK
FOR THE- WHAT WOULD YOU PROPOSE
TO DO WITH THAT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I ACTUALLY
HAVE BRAIN DO WE HEAR FROM THE
PARKS RIGHT IN THIS IS LIZ
MCGRATH CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FOR STATE PARKS AND I HAVE
BRIAN DO WE HERE TO SPEAK TO
THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
PROPOSAL. FIFTY WE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING THE- BRAIN TO THE
STATE PARKS ON THE CHIEF OF
FACILITIES AND DEVELOPMENT-I
WOULD I WOULD NOTE THAT THE-
THE TWENTY MILLION. DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET- ISN'T VERY HELPFUL
TO THE DEPARTMENTS- WORDS-
FINALIZING A LIST NOW OF-
HIGHEST PRIORITY PROJECTS. AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. IN IN I KNOW THAT
YOU DON'T HAVE A SERVICE BASE
BUDGET TODAY LIKE WILDLIFE HAS
BUT BUT WHAT ARE THOSE GIVE CAN
YOU GIVE US SOME IDEA OF THE
ONE POINT TWO SEVEN BILLION
WHAT IS IN CRITICAL NEED. RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE THESE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES THAT YOU KNOW THAT
SOME. A RECENT PARK ARE CLOSED
BECAUSE OF. ANOTHER OF HIS
DAMAGE HAS OCCURRED THERE THAT
THEIR PEOPLE ARE UNABLE TO GET
ACCESS TO WE HAVE SOME IDEA OF
WHAT THAT NUMBER MIGHT BE-
WE'VE DONE US SO THAT WE DO
ASSIGN A STATEWIDE SURVEY OF
ALL OF THE- THE PROJECTS AND-
THE CURE YOUR AGENDA NOTED THAT
WERE AROUND FIVE. THOUSAND
INDIVIDUAL PROJECTS WE THEN I'D
TAKE THAT LIST OF PROJECTS AND
WE- WE BRING THEM INTO HIGH
MEDIUM AND LOW PRIORITY AND I
BELIEVE LAST TIME WE HAD THAT-
THAT. THE RANKING- IT WAS- AND
THEN THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR RANGE OF THE HIGHEST OF
PRIORITIES FOR STATE PARKS.
VERY GOOD. D. W. R. I THINK WE
HAVE- A DIRECTOR NEMETH YOU'VE
GOT. TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THIRTY YEARS AT WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND YOU GET
THE LION'S SHARE OF THIS ONE
TIME MEET HIS COLLOCATION- WITH
THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION CAN
YOU GIVE THE SUBCOMMITTEES HOW
DO YOU- HOW DO YOU. HOW DO YOU
BEST SUPPLY THIS BAND AID TO
THE PROBLEM. YEAH THANK YOU- MR
CHAIRMAN- THANK YOU TO ALL THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING
ME TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS SO- AS A GENERAL
MATTER- IN THE FLOOD WORLD ONE
OF OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES WITH
ONGOING- FLOOD PROTECTION AND
MAINTENANCE. IS HOW WE CONNECT
STATE DOLLARS WITH LOCAL
DOLLARS WITH FEDERAL DOLLARS
AND- THE CHALLENGES OF- FEDERAL
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS HE'S
WORKING WITH STATE
APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS SEES AT
THE RIGHT TIME. WHEN LOCALS
HAVE THE MONEY IS WHY- ON THE
STATE SIDE WE'VE GROWN THIS
BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- IF YOU ALL
REMEMBER PROPOSITION ONE EIGHTY
WHICH PASSED I THINK IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX. WE JUST FINISHED
SPENDING ALL THAT MONEY REALLY
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AND THAT'S
CHALLENGING BECAUSE IT IT TAKES
A LONG TIME AND PART OF WHY IT
TAKES A LONG TIME IS- HOW WE
CONNECT ALL THESE VARIOUS
FUNDING SOURCES- TO. SUPPORT
THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS SO THAT
HAS ESSENTIALLY GENERATED WHAT
WE'VE ESTIMATED AS ABOUT. SIX
pBACKLOG IN MAINTENANCE FOR HIGH
PRIORITY MAINTENANCE THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION THAT- IS
PART OF THIS REQUEST TODAY. FOR
HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS OUR
TOTAL HIGH PRIORITY PROJECT
NEED IS ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- WE HAVE A LONG
LIST OF PROJECTS THAT ARE IN
THE QUEUE IF YOU WILL AND-
THESE ARE THINGS LIKE- LET THE
EROSION AND SEDIMENTATION
ACCUMULATION- AND THOSE SORTS
OF THINGS SO. THAT'S THE
BROADER CONTEXT OF THE NEED I
THINK AS A GENERAL MATTER- IF
OUR IF THE STATE CONTINUES TO
IMPROVE ECONOMICALLY AND WE SEE
THE POTENTIAL FOR CLIMATE
RESILIENCY BOND- IT'S BEEN A
WHILE- SINCE THE STATE HAS HAD-
BOND ISSUES THAT ARE INVESTING.
IN FLOOD PROTECTION NINE PROP
ONE WE HAD ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION AND WHAT WE CALL MULTI
BENEFIT FLOOD PROTECTION
PROJECTS AND I'M PART OF THAT
WAS BECAUSE- WE WERE STILL
WORKING ON OUR PROPOSITION ONE
EIGHTY- AND DISTRIBUTION OF
DOLLARS. SO THAT'S SORT OF THE
FULLER CONTEXT IN TERMS OF
FUNDING NEEDED FLOOD AND- HOW
WE GET TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY
AND- IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THANK FOR THAT SIR BILLION
GRANTS IT IS ALMOST. THAT THIS
THIS LEGISLATURE WOULD RESPOND
WITH ADDING IS ZERO TO THE
GOVERNORS- HUNDRED FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR. PROPOSAL JUST THIS ONE
TIME MONEY BUT LET'S HAVE CAL
FIRE A DEPUTY- DUGAN. YOUR
YOU'VE GOT A HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION BACKLOG AND
YOU'RE GONNA GET TEN. THAT IS
CORRECT HI GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
MICHAEL DUGGAN WITH- THE CHIEF
TECHNICAL SERVICES WITHOUT MY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR TONY FARROW AND
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FACILITY FINANCE MANAGER- MR
TRAY HUNTER- THE DEPARTMENT IS-
WILL USE THAT INFORMATION IS
FUNDING FOR A HUNDRED AND TEN
IDENTIFY PROJECTS TOTALING TEN
MILLION DOLLARS- THESE PROJECTS
ARE LOCATED AT FIRE STATIONS
CONSERVATION CAMPS.
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICES IN OTHER
STATES- FACILITIES STATEWIDE.
ROGER DODGER- DRESS CRITICAL
FIRE LIFE SAFETY ISSUES AND
ENSURE CONTINUED OPERATIONS-
ALL THESE FACILITIES OPERATE
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR. A
COUPLE HOURS WORKED VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
TO BUILD A SOLID FINANCIAL PLAN
TO ENSURE THAT- YOU WILL BE
ABLE TO SEE THESE PROJECTS
THROUGH TO COMPLETION. AND THIS
APPROACH- THIS PROPOSAL ALIGNS
WITH THE APPROACH- FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE REDUCTION. AND
REFLECTS THE DEPARTMENT'S TOP
PRIORITIES. FOR THIS FUNDING WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE- THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND ARE HAPPY
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YOU HAVE- YEAH IF YOU
COULD IF YOU COULD HIGHLIGHT TO
US. OF THE CRITICAL ARE THE
EXTREME I KNOW WE'RE TALKING
CAL FIRE SUIT I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR A HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN IS
ALL EXTREME BUT BUT WHAT IS
THAT TOP. I CATEGORY OF WORK
THAT YOU WOULD NEED TO DO TO
TAKE CARE OF THE MOST GLARING.
SHORTFALL SAID YOU HAVE. ARE
PRIMARILY IT'S- FOR CONTINUED
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS BUT ALSO-
INSURING THE STATE MISSION- IN
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT AS WELL ONE
OF THESE PROJECTS- IS TIED TO
THE LA MER- MORAN REFORESTATION
CENTER. SO PRIMARILY IT'S TO.
CONTINUE OPERATIONS- AND THEN-
REALLY THE CRITICALITY OF HOW
THAT AFFECTS- TAKING A STATION
DOWN OR- HAVING US TO. KIND OF
RE PLANNED DUE TO A FAILURE.
OKAY LET'S SEE IF I HAVE HANDS
UP BY MEMBERS. BUT IT'S JUST
THE THOUGHT THAT IF WE ADDED
ZERO TO THIS AND WE GIVE CAL
FIRE A HUNDRED MILLION TO TAKE
CARE OF THEIR BACKLOG OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN MILLION AND
WE GIVE PARKS TWO HUNDRED
MILLION TO TAKE CARE OF A ONE
POINT TWO WHICH IS LIKE A SIX
TO WHAT THEY HAVE. IN IN IN IN
D. W. R. WE GET SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION WHICH IS NOT EVEN
YOU KNOW WHICH THEY GOT THREE
BILLION OR FOUR SEVEN BILLION
OF CRITICAL IT'S AN EXPRESSION
OF A ONE TIME ADJUSTMENT-
INVESTMENT TO THESE THINGS
STILL TO GET US ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE BUT IT SAYS
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT WE THINK
ABOUT. THE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND IT'S IT IT
REFLECTS CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE AS
WE LOOK TO THE EAST COAST AND
IN WASHINGTON DC ON WHAT TYPE
OF INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY THEY
WOULD GIVE TO US SO. WE'RE
GONNA KEEP THIS MATTER OPEN
OBVIOUSLY WOULD LIKE TO TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT AND SEE HOW
EXPENSIVE WE CAN GET IN THIS-
AT THE TIME WERE FLUSH WITH
MONEY THANK YOU ALL- N. TALK
ABOUT D. W. R. WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT. OF RESOURCES WE
HAVE A GRAM OF WATER
MANAGEMENT- PROPOSAL SIXTY
MILLION FROM A GENERAL FUND
THIS YEAR AND- THIRTY MILLION
NEXT YEAR ARE CONTINUING EXCUSE
ME. FROM AGAIN HER NAME IS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES WE DO HAVE A
FUNDING- PROPOSAL FOR A THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THIS- BUT IN
THIS CURRENT YEAR AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR FOR A TOTAL OF
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS- THIS IS
FOR A GRANT PROGRAM THAT CAN
SUPPORT- PROJECTS THAT AR
IDENTIFIED IN CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED GROUNDWATER BASINS- AS
YOU MAY BE AWARE OF THE
DEADLINE FOR GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN SUBMITTAL-
WAS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THE
DEPARTMENT HAS- TWO YEARS TO
REVIEW THOSE PLANS FROM
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
GROUNDWATER BASINS SO WE ARE ON
TRACK TO MAKE A DECISION- ON
THAT INITIAL SET OF PLANS. BY
ESSENTIALLY JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- THE DOLLARS- WOULD
GO FOR PROJECTS THAT SUPPORT-
THINGS LIKE STORMWATER CAPTURE-
SMALLER KINDS OF CONVEYANCE
PROJECTS THAT CAN ASSIST WITH
GROUND WATER RECHARGE
CONSERVATION PROGRAMS AND OTHER
KINDS OF THINGS THAT- THAT ARE
NEEDED IN THESE COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE ARE DEALING WITH THE
MOST INTENSIVE GROUNDWATER
OVERDRAFT PROBLEMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA- AS A GENERAL
MATTER- THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED A
PROGRAM IN THIS CURRENT YEAR. A
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT WILL
ENABLE US TO ACTUALLY ISSUE
THOSE GRANT DOLLARS BY THE
CLOSE OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AS
I MENTIONED WHILE- THE
DEPARTMENT IS REVIEWING THESE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED PLANS-
THOSE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES ARE
RIGHT NOW IMPLEMENTING THOSE
PLANS WE WILL HAVE A PROGRESS
REPORT AND- APRIL FIRST IN
ABOUT A MONTH AND THEN WILL
HAVE ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS
AFTER THAT SO WE THINK IT'S
CRITICAL- THERE. IS AN ENORMOUS
NEED FOR THESE KIND AS A
DOLLARS AND- TO SUPPORT THAT
AND- OF A SUSTAINED GRANDMA
MANAGEMENT SO I'LL STOP THERE
BUT DIRECTOR NAME IF YOU'VE
READ THE ALLY OWES REPORT
THEY'RE SAYING WE SIGMA WE
UNDERSTAND IT'S ALL CRITICAL
PUSH THE SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS
OUT. IF IT TRICKLES INTO NEXT
JANUARY AS FAR AS THE WORKING
DONE IT'S NOT LIKE THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND COULD
IMPROVE I MEAN IT'S ALREADY BAD
IT'LL BE BAD IN NINE MONTHS OR
TEN MONTHS WHATEVER IS. I KNOW
THAT FINANCE IS SITTING THERE
AND THEY GOT THEY GOT A
DIFFERENT ANGLE YOU'RE THE
DIRECTOR. OF ARTIST DOESN'T
THAT MAKE SENSE THE LA ROSE
OBSERVATION HERE. I APPRECIATE
THEIR OBSERVATION I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING AT- A PREVIOUS YEAR
WHEN WE HAD- TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS AVAILABLE WE GOT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN- AND FUNDING
REQUESTS SO WE KNOW THE NEED IS
THERE THE DEPARTMENT- AS AS YOU
KNOW- THERE'S A LOT OF ANXIETY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ON- HOW
WE'RE GOING TO ADDRESS- THE
NEED TO BRING. GROUNDWATER
BASINS INTO SUSTAINABILITY AND-
YOU KNOW FRANKLY JUST TO USE AN
INFORMAL TERM I TAKE THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
IS ALL IN AND I'M GETTING GOD
CURRENT GRANT PROGRAMS OUT THE
DOOR- AS SOON AS POSSIBLE- SO
THAT WE CAN DEMONSTRATE
PROGRESS. I THINK ONE OF THE
BIG CHALLENGES OF- THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT EIGHT- NEED IS THAT
THERE'S A HIGH LEVEL OF ANXIETY
AS AS EVERYONE LOOKS AT THE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
TRANSFORMATION THAT'S GOING TO
NEED TO HAPPEN IN THIS KIND OF
A RESOURCE SCARCITY ISSUE
PARTICULARLY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND PARTICULARLY- AND
SOME OF THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU KNOW STRUGGLE WITH-
ECONOMIC. INEQUALITY IN THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS SO THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY WANTS TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN TO GET
MONEY OUT THE DOOR AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE IN THESE
COMPETITIVE GRANT MAKING
PROGRAMS AND WE THINK WE CAN DO
THIS- WITH- THIS KIND OF A
BUDGET ALLOCATION BUT POINT
CERTAINLY NOTED OBVIOUSLY BY
THE L. A. MISSY TAYLOR SWIFT
BUT CAN YOU LET US KNOW ABOUT
THE- WHY THIS IS SORT OF AN
UNNECESSARY ADMINISTRATIVE COST.
YEAH THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
RETAILERS WITH THE LEGEND LAST
OFFICE SO WE- WE DO IN
REVIEWING THIS AGREE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ANY ADMINISTRATION
THAT THIS IS A HIGH PRIORITY M.
AS A DIRECTOR MENTION THESE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS.
HAVE THAT KIND OF DUAL
CHALLENGE OF THEIR THEIR THE
MOST OUT OF BALANCE AND THEY
HAVE THE MOST EXPEDITED
TIMELINES FOR GETTING BACK INTO
BALANCE SO WE THINK IT'S A
WORTHWHILE STATE INVESTMENT IT
IS JUST THE TIMING ISSUE THAT
WE RAISED SOME CONCERNS ABOUT-
IT'S ALWAYS NICE TO GET DOLLARS
EARLY I THINK PROBABLY EVERY
DEPARTMENT YOU WOULD TALK TO
WOULD SAY YES WE WOULD. LIKE AN
EARLY ACTION ITEM SO WE CAN
START A FEW MONTHS EARLY- BUT
WE THINK YOU KNOW AS WE HAVE
I'VE DISCUSSED IN PREVIOUS-
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THERE
THERE'S A PRETTY HIGH THRESHOLD
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT GENERAL FUND BECAUSE IT
DOES LIMIT YOUR- FLEXIBILITY
WHEN YOU COME TO PUTTING
TOGETHER YOUR WHOLE BUDGET
PACKAGE IN JUNE WHEN YOU HAVE
TAKEN DOLLARS OFF THE TABLE AS
EARLY. AND WE DON'T THINK THAT
THIS MEETS THAT HIGH THRESHOLD
IT'S NOT A CRITICAL EMERGENCY
IT'S NOT RESPONDING TO COATED-
THESE ARE LONG TERM PROJECTS
THAT WILL TAKE. MANY MONTHS IF
NOT YEARS TO UNDERTAKE SO
WAITING A FEW MORE MONTHS AND
THERE IS- BROCK PROP SIXTY
EIGHT DOLLARS THAT ARE IN
PROCESS NOW THAT WON'T GET OUT
THE DOOR UNTIL MAY. SO WE THINK
WAITING A FEW MORE MONTHS
RUNNING ONE GRANT CYCLE RATHER
THAN TO THAT ARE JUST A FEW
MONTHS APART- WELL WILL NOT
ONLY BE KIND OF
ADMINISTRATIVELY EASIER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND FOR APPLICANTS
BUT ALSO- IN TERMS OF YOUR
OVERALL BUDGET STRUCTURE MAKE A
LOT MORE SENSE- SO WE WOULD
RECOMMEND TO CONSIDERING THE
FULL AMOUNT. AS PART OF YOUR
REGULAR BUDGET PACKAGE. MR
FULLER FINANCE PLEASE A GIVE US
YOUR INPUT GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS BRYAN FULLER PART OF
FINANCE- BRIDGET KELLY WAS
COMMENTS ON THE FULL SIXTY
MILLION I JUST TO BUILD ON THE
DIRECTOR'S COMMENTS EARLIER ON
KIND OF THE PROGRAMMATIC SIDE
OF- THE NEED FOR THE THIRTY
MILLION IN THE CURRENT YEAR
JUST JUST KIND OF HANG OUT A
LITTLE BIT. REALLY JUST
IDENTIFY THAT THE THIRTY
MILLION BEING PROPOSED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR REALLY ALIGNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S BROADER
EFFORTS- TO- PROVIDE ECONOMIC
STIMULUS AND SUPPORT OF ROBUST
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SO GIVEN KIND
OF THE- BROADER GOALS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WE BELIEVE THAT
THE ACCELERATING OUT THIRTY
BILLION OCCURRING HERE WILL
WILL HELP FACILITATE SOME OF
THOSE THOSE BROAD BASED
ECONOMIC RECOVERY- DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS. THAT
WE'RE BUILDING TOWARDS. I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS UP. OKAY NO
SENATOR STERN YOU RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MR- AND THANK YOU-
DIRECTOR NEVER THING AND- THE
REST OF THE TEAM- JUST AS
SOMEBODY WHO'S DEALING WITH
MULTIPLE OTHER PENDING LAWSUITS
OR- THE ANXIETY REFERRED TO IN
THE GROWING COMMUNITY. IT DOES
FEEL LIKE A CRISIS MAYBE IT'S
NOT FELT EVERYWHERE BUT I THINK
YOU KNOW GETTING READY FOR THE
DEADLINES IN SIGMA IS DRIVING-
A LOT OF TENSION OUT INTO
VARIOUS COMMUNITIES AND I
REALLY I JUST WANT TO. SPEND
ONE SECOND IF YOU COULD. DRILL
DOWN A LITTLE BIT FURTHER ON
HOW. CRUCIAL THESE GRANTS ARE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
HOW READY THEY ARE TO DO WITH
IT ALL RIGHT MY SENSE IS THAT
THERE'S NOT BEEN A SIGNIFICANT-
DELAY IN GETTING A NEW ISSUANCE
OF GRANTS OUT THE DOOR. AND
JUST LIKE EVEN IF IT'S A MATTER
OF FALLING BEHIND BY SIX MONTHS
WHAT WHAT COULD THAT DO I GUESS
TO SIGNIN BOWMAN TATIAN IN IN
YOUR MIND- DIRECTION EMMA.
THANK YOU SELLER LEADS THAT'S A
GOOD QUESTION SO- I WOULD SAY
THAT- SO HOW'S MY WORKS IS AS
YOU ALL KNOW- THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY. AGENCIES
NEED TO REACH SUSTAINABILITY BY
TWENTY FORTY AND PART OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA IS YOU KNOW REMEDY
IN A RELATIVELY SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME- SOMETHING THAT HAS
ESSENTIALLY TAKEN DECADES- TO
CREATE AND THESE CHALLENGES OF.
DAMAGE FROM WATER BASINS BUT- I
WOULD SAY EVEN MORE THAN THAT
IT'S ALL IT'S ALSO CREATED SOME
CHALLENGES AROUND- WHAT
INFORMATION WE HAVE TO MAKE
GOOD CHOICES SO IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE HE'S GROUNDWATER BASINS
REALLY IN SELECT AREAS- ONLY IN
SELECT AREAS HAVE THEY BEEN
MANAGED AND- YOU KNOW FRANKLY
PLACES LIKE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WERE A LOT MORE AHEAD OF THE
CURVE PARTLY BECAUSE THEY HAVE.
YOU KNOW A BROADER SET OF WATER
CHALLENGES SO WE SAW IT PLAY
OUT WHERE THEY WERE EDUCATED
BASINS- AND VERY FUNCTIONAL
BASINS AND PARTS OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT CERTAINLY THE
LACK OF MANAGEMENT OF
GROUNDWATER BASINS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
THE INFORMATION INFRASTRUCTURE
TO FULLY SUPPORT HOW WE'RE
GONNA GET FROM TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO TWENTY FORTY- TO
SUSTAINABLE- SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER BASINS SO PART OF
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THE
GRANT PROGRAM IS INVESTMENTS
THAT. THESE LOCAL AGENCIES NEED
TO MAKE AND YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE DRILLING MORE
MONITORING WELLS THAT CAN HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND HOW WATER IS
MOVING THROUGH DIFFERENT
LAYERS- WITHIN- THEIR
PARTICULAR- BASINS GEOLOGY.
THAT IS GOING TO BE CRUCIAL
FOR- HOW ABOUT SIGMA IT WORKS
TOGETHER WITH- THE WATER BOARD
AND THE SAFER PROGRAM TO ENSURE
THAT WERE- USING OUR DOLLARS
THAT DEAL WITH DRINKING WATER
QUALITY. I'M IN WAYS THAT- ARE
COMPLEMENTARY TO- PROJECTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED UNDER SICK MIND WE
ARE NOT INADVERTENTLY. THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA.
DEEPENING WATER QUALITY
CHALLENGES AND- AND- THEN
AFFECTING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT KIND OF SAFER PROGRAM SO I
THINK- YOU KNOW THE MORE
INFORMATION. THAT WE CAN GET
THE SOONER THE BETTER- IS GOING
TO GET US ON AN IMPLEMENTATION
TRACK FOR SIGMA- EVEN THOUGH
THESE PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS
TAKE AWHILE- THEY TAKE AWHILE
BUT- THE SOONER WE HAVE BETTER
INFORMATION. THAT HELPS US-
GUIDING FUTURE INVESTMENTS- THE
BETTER OFF WE'LL BE HITTING
THAT TWENTY FORTY GOAL. SCORER
AND REQUIREMENT ACTUALLY. MORE
THAN A GOAL A REQUIREMENT.
THANKS THANKS FOR THE CALL. I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS THAT GOT
THE SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN THEY'LL GET THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER PLANT AND
IN A LOT OF US MIX THEM ALL
TOGETHER SOME PEOPLE MAY MAKE
SOME WITH A- HIGH CARBON
REDUCTION PROGRAM BUT I'LL PUT
THAT ASIDE FOR A SECOND CAN YOU
GIVE US SOME IDEA OF HOW THAT
INTERPLAY IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SOME PEOPLE WOULD OBSERVE WE
SPENT A LOT OF MONEY ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND NOW. THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUNDWATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN HAD IS WORTH
THE LINKAGE. GREAT QUESTION SO
THE DEPARTMENT IS THIS IS
PROBABLY THE AREA IN WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT IS- WORKING MOST
INTENSIVELY WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD- SO. IF YOU CAN IMAGINE-
WE HAVE GROUNDWATER BASINS- WE
HAVE- A- PRETTY SIGNIFICANT-
NEW INFORMATION ABOUT WELLS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT WELLS ARE-
OPERABLE VERSES IN OPERABLE AND
THAT THAT IS RELATIVELY NEW
INFORMATION RIGHT SO. PEOPLE
ARE REQUIRED TO REPORT THAT
COUNTIES WEREN'T REQUIRED TO
REPORT THAT TO THE STATE BUT WE
NOW HAVE. AS OF I THINK ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO WE NOW HAVE THIS.
REALLY SIGNIFICANT PUBLICLY
ACCESSIBLE- INFORMATION
DATABASE ABOUT- HOW MANY WELLS
WE HAVE. WHAT WE DON'T HAVE.
STATEWIDE IN FOR AROUND IS
WHICH OF THOSE WELLS ARE
ACTUALLY OPERABLE AND
FUNCTIONING AND PROVIDING AND
DOMESTIC WELL SOURCE SO- WHEN
WE DRINK. L. DOWN A LITTLE BIT
DEEPER ON INDIVIDUAL PLANS AND
COMMUNICATE WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
AT THE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD AND THEIR REGIONAL BOARDS
BECAUSE OF COURSE THOSE PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN LOCAL BASE
AND WATER QUALITY-
REQUIREMENTS. WE LOOK TOGETHER
AT THE INFORMATION THAT'S
AVAILABLE WHAT DOES THIS
INFORMATION TELL US ABOUT- THE
POTENTIAL EFFECTS OF
IMPLEMENTING THIS SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PLAN AND
WHAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION DO
WE NEED- FROM THE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCY TO ASSURE
HER. THAT WE'RE NOT CREATING
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS IN THE
WATER QUALITY REALM THAT YOU
KNOW THE STATE IS WORKING TO
FUND- IN OTHER WAYS AND THAT
ARE ARE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT-
ONE THING TO REMEMBER IS THAT-
WHAT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT SIGMA IS
ACTUALLY WHEN IT'S IMPLEMENTED
SO WE HAVE OPTIONS UNDER THE
LAW TO ESSENTIALLY MAKE THREE
KINDS OF DECISIONS ONE. YOU CAN
HAVE A PLAN THAT IS WE
DETERMINE IS ADEQUATE WITH
RECOMMENDED CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
AND THEN- THOSE ARE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES NEED TO
SUPPORT ANNUAL UPDATES AS TO
HOW THEY'RE DOING BUT THE
DEPARTMENT IN FIVE YEARS WILL
ESSENTIALLY REEVALUATE WHETHER
OR NOT THAT PLAN IS STILL
ADEQUATE SO THAT'S ONE DECISION
THAT WE CAN MAKE AROUND PLANTS.
THE SECOND DECISION AS WE CAN
SAY THAT PLAN IS INCOMPLETE AND
BY LAW THAT YOU HAVE SIX MONTHS
A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS TO MAKE
IT COMPLETE SO IF WE LOOK AT
THAT WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
PLANS AND WE SAY WELL THEY'RE
MISSING SOME YOU KNOW
FUNDAMENTAL PIECES OF
INFORMATION OR- THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT AVAILABLE
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE. ENOUGH OF
A PLAN AS TO HOW AND WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO GET IT YOU
KNOW PARTICULARLY RELATED TO-
DRINKING WATER WELLS WE CAN
REQUIRE THAT BRUH- A
DETERMINATION THAT A PLAN IS
INCOMPLETE AND THAT WOULD
COMPEL THOSE GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES TO
ADDRESS THAT WITHIN A SIX MONTH
PERIOD. THE OTHER THING THAT WE
CAN DO IS DETERMINE A PLAN TO
BE INADEQUATE AND THAT'S WHEN
THAT PLAN THEN GOES OVER TO THE
WATER BOARD- AND THEY HAVE A
VERY FORMAL PROCEDURE ABOUT
PUTTING- I PLAN ON PROBATION
AND THAT- EMPOWERS THE BOARD
SHOULD ESSENTIALLY INSTITUTE
INTERIM GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT
MEASURES WHILE THAT-
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY IS PUTTING TOGETHER A
PLAN. THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
THE LAW SO WE HAVE ALL THOSE
KIND OF OPPORTUNITIES TO GET TO
YOUR INDIVIDUAL PLANS AND
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY'RE RELATING
TO- GROUNDWATER QUALITY AND HOW
THAT'S RELATING TO- PROGRAM
MANAGEMENT OVER AT THE WATER
BOARD. WITH THOSE SAFER DOLLARS
AND- I WOULD SAY DO YOU HAVE
YOUR IS WORKING VERY WELL THE
STATE LEVEL WITH THE WATER
BOARD AND AT THE LEADERSHIP
LEVEL BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF- OF THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVING INDEPENDENT-
CREDIBILITY- FOR THE FOR THE
PUBLIC AND FOR YOU ALL I KNOW
THAT THAT WAS A TOPIC OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO SENATOR MINING
AND- AND WE ARE WORKING VERY
DILIGENTLY TO ARTICULATE HOW
THESE PIECES MOVE TOGETHER.
YEAH AND JUST FOR THE
REPUBLICAN ALWAYS HAD AND
THAT'S ONLY THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COVERED THESE ARE ONLY THE
AGENCY'S RECOVER BECAUSE IF YOU
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL OR TWO OR
THREE THAT ARE ON ONE WELL
THEY'RE NOT PART OF THE SYSTEM
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE THAT HAVE
IT MAY BE A CAMPGROUND OR MAYBE
SOMETHING THAT HAS AN ACTUAL
WATER DISTRICT THAT'S BEFORE US
SO. THANK YOU FOR THAT. N. AS
THUNDERSTORMS. GIVEN A FOLLOW
UP QUESTION IT JUST FOR ONE
LAST FALL QUESTIONS ACTUALLY.
RELATED BUT. THIS IS MORE
ABOUT- LESS ABOUT SIGMA MORE
BAD IMPLEMENTATION OF A- ON THE
RESIDENTIAL SIDE ON A WATER YOU
STUDY THAT I THINK PENDING WITH
YOU ALL JUST- AND DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE RIGHT NOW RIGHT NOW BUT
A. B. SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
IMPLEMENTATION WONDERING.
STATUS THAT REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WE JUST GET SOME
INFO BACK ON THAT AT SOME POINT
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE THAT
DAY. SO THAT IS- WATER USE
EFFICIENCY AND- D. W. R. AND
THE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD ARE DUE TO PRESENT OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON AN INDOOR WATER
USE EFFICIENCY STANDARDS- AND-
WE ARE- LOOKING TO DO THAT BY
APRIL. I THINK. TO BE CANDID I
THINK THE DEADLINE WAS- END OF
LAST YEAR YOU NOT MEET THAT
DEADLINE BUT IT IS A JOINT
RECOMMENDATION AND- WE PLAN TO.
HAVE IT TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
APRIL- I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS- WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF SENATOR IF YOU WANT TO
DRILL DOWN INTO MORE DETAILS.
OKAY TOLD LOOK LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT THAT'S A THAT'S GOOD. WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA HOLD ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY TWO IN LESS BUT
MOVED TO THE LAST ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY TWO
WHICH IS THE SUBCOMMITTEE TWOS
WILD FIRE PREVENTION RESILIENCY
EARLY ACTION PLAN. I WOULD
PRESENT ON THAT SWELTERING THE
GAVEL OVER THERE- CENTER DOLLY
TO ACT TO SECURE. WITH. GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- CALIFORNIA'S
RECENTLY EXPERIENCED SOME OF
THE LARGEST AND MOST SEVERE
WILDFIRES IN RECORD HISTORY
THEY'VE ONLY BEEN SOME BEER BUT
HAD AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES THE ENVIRONMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE ECONOMY
IN ORDER TO MAKE THE STATE LESS
VULNERABLE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
PROPOSES AN EARLY ACTION PLAN
FOR A TOTAL OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS WHICH
IS OUTLINED IN. ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO. THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
IS MAKING A STRONG EFFORT TO
ADDRESS WILDFIRES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND IN A VARIETY OF
VEGETATION TYPES NOT JUST FOR
US. WE'RE LOOKING AT GRASSLANDS
AND CHAPERONES FOR EXAMPLE
STATE CONSERVANCY'S COVERED
MILLIONS OF ACRES OF OUR STATE
AND SERVICE A GOOD. CONDUIT FOR
TARGETING A FUNDING IN SPECIFIC
REGIONS. THIS PLAN INCLUDES
OVER EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING FOR OUR CONSERVANCY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF- AKTION
RECREATIONS MANAGES ONE POINT
SIX MILLION ACRES OF PUBLIC
LAND IN CALIFORNIA AND OVER
HALF OF THAT ACREAGE. IS
CONSIDERED HIGHLY VULNERABLE TO
WIRE FIRES THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE INCLUDES
TWENTY TWO MILLION TO CONDUCT
ACTIVITIES TO REDUCE RISK IN
OUR PARK LANDS. THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE WHICH WE TOOK
HER FROM DOCTOR BOTTOM- EARLIER
MANAGES OVER A MILLION ACRES.
IT'S 90% OF WHICH IS IN REGIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEFINED AS HIGH
VERY HIGH OR EXTREME THREATS OF
FIRE THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT. OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE LANDS SO WHY WE GIVE
MONEY FOR CAL FIRE AND THEY DO
THE BASELINE WORK THIS IS OTHER
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE STATE
OF. CALIFORNIA DEDICATING.
FUNDING FOR PROPOSED FUNDING TO
DO MANAGEMENT. BUT THAT'S NOT
ALL. THE PEOPLE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE ACKNOWLEDGES THE
NEED TO PROVIDE THE TOOLS
NECESSARY TO ACT QUICKLY SO
WE'RE ADDING FOUR POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR TWELVE A- P. WEISS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO HELP THEM GET THE
JOB DONE. THIS WILL EXPEDITE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
PERMITTING ON FIRE RELATED
PROJECTS WHILE STILL PROTECTING
THE SPECIES AND THEIR HABITATS.
AVOID DELAYS THAT DEPARTMENTS
MAY EXERCISE WITH DGS
PROCUREMENT AND CONTRACTING
PROCESSES WORK AT THIS PROPOSAL
ADDS LANGUAGE THAT'S HACKED
THAT HELPS DEPARTMENT. THIS
QUICKLY IN ORDER TO PERFORM THE
WILDLIFE- PREVENTION WORK
BEFORE THAT THE NEXT FIRE
SEASON AND THIS LANGUAGE IS
BASED OFF OF A TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN EXECUTIVE ORDER WHEN
THE STATE WAS SUFFERING FROM
DROUGHT SO WE'RE JUST RE
PURPOSING IT SAYING. THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR THE DRAW CONCERNS
WE HAVE. IN ADDITION. WE IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SEE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS BOTH WIRE FIRE AND
DROUGHT RESILIENCY AND- THIS
PLAN INCLUDES THIRTY NINE
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION'S. REGIONAL FORCE
AND FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM. AND
OF THAT AMOUNT. WE'VE SET ASIDE
SIXTEEN MILLION TOOK FOR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS IN THESE
UPPER WATERSHEDS THAT ARE
SIGNIFICANT A SOURCE. OF WATER
SUPPLY FOR THE STATE. OF MISTER
CHAIR MISTER DALI WE'VE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS SITE IDEA
THIS HIGH ALPINE WORTH WORTHY
AT THE AT THE TOP OF THE
MOUNTAIN THAT NEEDS THAT HAVE
WORK DONE. ALSO THE PLAN BEFORE
THE SUBCOMMITTEE THAT TAKES
CARE OF OTHER PEOPLE MOST IN
NEED OF WILDFIRE. WERE MOST
AFFECTED BY WHILE FOR FIRE
EVENTS AND PROVIDES THIRTY TWO
MILLION. EMERGENCY CLEAN AIR
AND HYDRATION CENTERS AS WELL
AS COOLING CENTERS WHAT WE
DON'T I CAN'T PREDICT WHEN THE
NEXT FIRES GET HIT OR THE
DEGREE OR ANYBODY THAT MIGHT
TESTIFY DISK WE KNOW IT'S GOING
TO COME WE NEED TO BE PREPARED.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE EARLY ACTION
PLAN PROVIDES A STRONG BALANCE
ADDRESSING A VARIETY OF NEEDS-
WE'VE HAD THE INPUT FROM THE
TERM EARLY ACTION I GUESS IS
THAT WE'RE USING- AND THE FACT
IS REALLY JUST PICKING UP WHERE
WE LEFT OFF. AT THE END THE
SESSION LAST YEAR. MY COLLEAGUE
MAKES MCGUIRE CHEERS WITH MISS.
CENTER RUBIO THE SENATE.
WILDFIRE WORKING GROUP THAT'S
BEEN IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
THE- SUBCOMMITTEE AND THEY'VE
BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY SINCE
THE FALL OF TWENTY NINETEEN
CENTER STERN SERVES ON THAT
COMMITTEE- AND THEY'VE BEEN
WORK FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS
THEY'VE COME UP WITH HOW WE CAN
DEFEND THE STATE AGAINST
WILDFIRE. I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DID I POINT OUT MY
COUNTERPART IN THE OTHER HOUSE
THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THREE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM SEPTEMBER
BLOOM IS THE AUTHOR OF AB.
SIXTEEN FIFTY NINE WHICH WAS A
THREE BILLION DOLLAR SIX TIMES
AS LARGE AS HIS PROPOSAL FOR
NUMEROUS NATURAL RESOURCES AND
WIRE WILDFIRE RELATED PROJECTS.
ALTHOUGH THE BILL WAS NOT
SUCCESSFUL THEY SET A TEMPLATE
THAT WE USE AT THE HALF. I HAVE
A BILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR
THIS THAT HAS BEEN MODIFIED.
THIS PLAN. IS HOW WE SEE THE
EARLY ACTION OF WILDFIRE
PACKAGES SHOULD BE. MORE
WILLING AND EAGER TO ENGAGE OUR
PARTNERS IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE THE CITY
CALIFORNIA SAFER. AND MORE
RESILIENCE. TO WILDFIRES DOWN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION BEFORE YOU IS
THE DIRECT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIR ALONG WITH THE BUDGET
CHAIR AND THE SUPPORT OF THE
PRESIDENT PRO TEMP TO ENGAGE IN
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
COUNTERPARTS IN THE ASSEMBLY ON
THE SUBJECT OF AN EARLY ACTION
WILDFIRE PLAN. THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE PLANS OUTLINES IN
THIS AGENDA. SHOULD SERVE AS
THE BASIS FOR THE FOR MY
NEGOTIATIONS BUT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS LISTED SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED THE CEILING THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF I'D LIKE TO
REPEAT THIS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. IS TO APPROVE A
THREE PARTY AGREEMENT THAT
PROVIDES RESOURCES IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR- TO
MEANINGFULLY IMPROVE THE
STATE'S ABILITY TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACT OF WILDFIRES. THROUGH
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUDGET YEAR AND
BEYOND. BUT NOTHING IN THIS
MOTION IF IT'S IF IT'S APPROVED
BY THE HOUSE SUBCOMMITTEE
SHOULD BE CONSTRUED BY TEN
PARTY EARLY ACTION ON FIRE
WILDFIRE ITEMS WILL NEGATE THE
NEED FOR SIGNIFICANT. AND
MEANINGFUL COMMITMENTS- AND
RESOURCES TO CONTACT THE
WILDFIRES FROM BEING. INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND I WOULD NOTE I'M
SURE EVERYBODY HAS TAKEN NOTICE
IS THAT THERE IS NO MONEY FROM
GREENHOUSE GAS FUNDS IN THIS
EARLY ACTION PLAN IT'S ALL
GENERAL FUNDS. WHICH WILL ALLOW
THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO DEAL WITH
THE EXPENDITURES OF THE CAP AND
TRADE FUNNIES MONIES AT A LATER
TIME AND WITH THAT. RESEARCHER
I WILL ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS AND
DISCUSSION AMONGST THE PANEL.
DO YOU HAVE QUESTIONS OR
REMOVAL AREA. ALL RIGHT. WELL I
WANT TO MAKE SURE I DON'T I
CAN'T SEE IT. SENATOR STERN'S
GUYS HAND UP SO IF HE DOES I
NEED TO KNOW THAT BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE A PHONE LINE HE DOES
OKAY WE'LL GO TO. THE CENTER
STORE AND THEN. I JUST WANTED
TO THANK THE CHAIR. FOR- GOING
BIG AND LAYING OUT A VISION
THAT- THAT IS. AT LEAST TRYING
TO BE A PROPORTIONAL TO THE
LEVEL OF URGENCY I THINK WE ALL
FEEL IN. VARIOUS TYPES OF FIRE
COUNTRY OUT THERE FROM RURAL
COMMUNITIES DOWN TO. VERY URBAN
INTERFACES- AND THIS ISN'T JUST
COMMUNITIES IT'S ALL THE
WORKING PEOPLE. OUT THERE WHO
HAVE BEEN STRETCHED THIN AND
MAYBE NOT EVEN GOT A BREAK.
SINCE JULY YOU'RE AT ONE OF
THESE FIRE CREWS- IT'S
STRAINING ARE PEOPLE GONNA
BREAK OUR FIRE FORCE UNLESS WE
GO BIG- A LITTLE BREAKER TO
MEANS LESS WE GO BIG SO I JUST.
I APPRECIATE THAT OUR CHAIRS-
VISION ON ALL THIS AND FRANKLY
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S WELL FOR
INITIATING THIS CONVERSATION
AND PUTTING IT OUT THERE ALL
IS. IS DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
STARTED STEPPING UP AND TRY TO
PUT THEIR FRAMEWORK FOR IT SO-
JUST NEED ONE MORE ELEMENT TO
THIS DEAL HOPEFULLY IN AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WHAT COMES OUT OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUT I THINK THAT.
THERE OUGHT TO BE A VAST PAST
YEAR FOR SOMETHING REALLY
ROBUST AND- I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING IN THIS THAT IS- YOU
KNOW SLOW MOVING IN. AND NOT
URGENT AT THIS MOMENT I HAVE
LOTS OF DETAILED FEEDBACK WHICH
I DON'T NEED TO NECESSARILY GET
INTO TODAY BUT HOW TO IMPROVE-
SAY ARE SUPPLEMENTED THE
HARDENING PROPOSALS OR TO MAKE
THE OPR PROPOSAL TALK BETTER TO
THAT PROPOSAL OR TO INSURE SOME
LINKAGES BETWEEN SAY ARE FSC.
AND FOREST HEALTH AND SOME OF
THE CONSERVANCY APPROPRIATIONS
AND GET ALL THAT SEE THEM
TALKING TO EACH OTHER BUT- AS
WELL AS THE PARKING CDFW AND
STATE LANDS COMMISSION PIECES
TRYING TO. SORT OF SINK IT SO
EVERYTHING IS SORT OF MOVING
TOWARDS- SOME SIMILAR
PRIORITIES AND WE CAN REALLY
EXECUTE ON THIS STUFF AND MAKE
IT CLEAR TO REAL PEOPLE WHAT
ALL THIS MEANS BUT- SETTING
ASIDE THOSE DETAILS FOR NOW- I
JUST APPRECIATE. THE THE
AMBITION OF THIS WHOLE THING
SO. OURS ARE MY OTHER COMMENTS
FOR USE THANK. YOU ROBERT FOR
THE CENTER OF OUR- THANK YOU SO
MUCH AT MR HERE- JUST TO HAVE A
FEW COMMENTS NO NO QUESTIONS IF
IT'S ALRIGHT WITH YOU IF YOU
CARE. FIRST AND FOREMOST I
WANNA TAKE A MOMENT TO BE ABLE
TO RECOGNIZE AT YOUR Y. CASKEY.
AT TERRA CASKEY OVER THE PAST
MANY WEEKS HAD BEEN PUT IN HIS
HEART AND SOUL INTO THIS
PROPOSAL. ALONG WITH MISS ROY
WHO IS THE VERY CAPABLE
CONSULTANT FIVE THIS COMMITTEE
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
BOTH OF YOU. FOR THE WORK THE
TIME THE EFFORT. IN THIS IS TO
BE HONEST THE BACK AND FORTH HI
THAT IS TAKING US TO GET TO
THIS DAY- OSKI HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT MANY OF THESE ISSUES FOR
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS AS- THIS
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEES
CHAIRPERSON. HE HAS BEEN
RELENTLESS IN HIS PURSUIT. TO
GO BOLD IN BIG. END THIS IS THE
YEAR TO DO SO- AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK NO B.
S. ON THAT. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INCREDIBLE WORK TO BE DONE
TO GET US TO WHERE WE'RE AT
TODAY- UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS IN
FRONT OF US. TO BE ABLE TO GET
A THREE PARTY PROPOSAL- THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO BOLDLY MOVE
FORWARD THIS YEAR. I ALSO WANT
TO TAKE A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE WORK OF- SUSAN RUBIO
SENATOR SUSAN RUBIO WHO'S A- CO
CHAIR OF THE- WILDFIRE WORKING
GROUP. IN TO ALL THE MEMBERS.
IN PARTICULAR SENATOR STERN WHO
IS ALSO ON THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR HIS INCREDIBLE
WORK. WHEN I SAY HANK YOU TO
SENATOR DODD I CENTER ALAN
SKINNER IN THE MOMENT- IS WELL
IN THANK YOU TO AT THE CHAIR
AGAIN. THAT FOR WORKING WITH US
ON- TRACKING HOW THIS IS ALL IT
IS HOW THIS ALL MATCHES WITH
THE BLUEPRINT. SO AS THE- THE
CARE IT SAID. A BLUEPRINT FOR A
FIRE SAFE CALIFORNIA. HAS BEEN
ADOPTED BY OUR CAUCUS IT HAS
FOUR MAIN PILLARS ONE TRAIN
DEPLOY A FIRE RESILIENCY WORK
FORCE. IMPLEMENT A MODERN DAY
VEGETATION. FIRE FORCE
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE HARDENING
POINT EXPAND COMMUTER ACCESS.
CONSUMER ACCESS TO THE
HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE MARKET. IN
DEVELOPED A SHORT AND LONG TERM
FUNDING PLAN THAT WOULD.
CULMINATE IN A BOND BEING
ADVANCE A WILDFIRE AND CLIMATE
RESILIENCY BOND COMING UP IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO. KNOWING
THAT FINES WOULD. B. ADVANCING
TWO FOUR ME THAT WE NEED BE
ADDED TO. A YEAR. TO TACKLE THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGE THAT IS
FACING THE STATE BEHIND THE
PANDEMIC. THAT'S WILD AND
FIRES. THE LIVELIHOODS
LITERALLY OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE AT RISK. IN
WHAT WE KNOW IS THE SIZE AND
SCOPE WHILE THEN FIRES ARE ONLY
GETTING WORSE. THE LARGEST AND
MOST DESTRUCTIVE OF THE FIRES
OF ALL HAPPENED IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS. IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
IT'S EXPEDITED. LAST YEAR WITH
THE FOUR MILLION ACRES AS FAR
AS YOUR DOLLY HAS ELOQUENTLY
STATED SO MANY TIMES. FOUR
MILLION ACRES BURNED. THAT'S
THE EQUIVALENT TO THE EMISSIONS
OF TWENTY EIGHT MILLION
VEHICLES. YES WE CONTINUE. TO
THROW PENNIES AT THIS CHALLENGE
I WILL FIRST SAY. GOVERNOR
NEWSOM HAS EXPEDITED FIRE
RESOURCES MORE THAN WHAT WE'VE
SEEN. IN THE PAST TEN YEARS WE
NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND WE
NEED TO THANK HIM FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP TRULY. BUT HE ALSO
SHOWS UP WHEN ALL HELL BREAKS
LOOSE IN THE COMMUNITIES ARE
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRES. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT AT ANY
HAZARDOUS OFF ONTO THE RIGHT
PATH. AND WE NEED TO GO BIGGER
AND BOLDER. CAL FIRE IS THE
GOLD STANDARD OF A FIRE
FIGHTING FORCE IN THE STATION
CANDIDLY IN THE WORLD. YET
THEY'RE OVERWHELMED. THEY'RE
EXHAUSTED. AND ARE UNDER
RESOURCED. REPEATING HOW FAR
STAFFING IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BEFORE I WAS BORN. YET
WE'RE BRINGING MORE ACRES IN
ONE YEAR THAN WE DID BYE IN
HALF A DECADE IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES. WE HAVE TO START
FOCUSING ON WHAT IS RIGHT AND
CANDIDLY IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO WHAT'S
RIGHT GO BIG AND BOLD.
OTHERWISE IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY- IF IT CONTINUES
TO MOVE FORWARD AS IT IS AND WE
CAN'T KEEP THAT GOING I TRY TO
POINT OUT SOME ISSUES THAT YOU
HAVE. ADVANCED FOR THE FIRST
AND FOREMOST- WITHIN THE
BLUEPRINT IN WHERE MY CASKEY IS
GOING. HE IS PUTTING IN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS EARLY ACTION IN FIRE
PREVENTION GRANTS THESE DOLLARS
WOULD BE ADVANCED. BACK TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES FIRE
DISTRICTS CITIES AND COUNTIES
WHO DESPERATELY NEED THESE
DOLLARS AND THEY WOULD BE IN
CUMBERLAND PRIOR TO THAT SUMMER
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IN THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
HE'S BEEN FOCUSED ON. HE'S
TRIPLING THE NUMBER- FOR THE C.
PARTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
BUT WAS ORIGINALLY REQUESTED
FOR EARLY ACTION GOING TO FORTY
NINE MILLION TO BEER TO GET
THOSE DEPLOYED. IN THOSE LANDS
THAT ARE BORDERING COMMUNITIES-
HE WERE FOCUSING ON GETTING
HAND CREWS OUT EARLIER
ACCORDING TO CAL FIRE LOCAL
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE WHO
REPRESENTS THAT CAL FIRE
FIREFIGHTERS SHOULD TAKE SIXTY
TO NINETY DAYS TO BE ABLE TO
GET A SEASONAL FIREFIGHTER
ONBOARDED IN OUT ON THE LAND.
IF WE WAIT TILL JUNE IT'S NOT
GONNA WORK WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GET A PORTION OF THESE CREWS
OUT EARLY TO BE ABLE TO START
FIGHTING FIRES AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD DO IN
ADDITION BUT WHICH ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR. IS THAT UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF CHAIRMAN CASKEY
HE'S DOUBLING THE DOLLARS FOR
COMMUNITY HARDENING ACROSS THE
STATE W. WE'VE NEVER SEEN FORTY
NINE MILLION ADVANCE OUR
COMMUNITY HARDENING. WE'D LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO GO BIGGER- AND
THAT'S A DISCUSSION BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT- CANDIDLY WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO LOOK AT ADDITIONAL BAND
WITHIN THE AGENCY TO GET THOSE
DOLLARS OUT BUT HE'S DOUBLING
WHAT WAS YOUR REGION INVESTED
LAST. PIECE ON THIS DAY IN
WHICH I REALLY APPRECIATE.
INCREASE THE COW FIRE. SO
THERE'S THIRTY FIVE MILLION IN
THIS PROPOSAL TO BE ABLE TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF CAL FIRE
CREWS- THAT WOULD BE HIRED
EARLY. ON AND JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AS
WE HEARD FROM CAL FIRE
THEMSELVES. MAJORITY THEIR
WORKERS DOING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN ADDITION TO-
FOCUSING ON HAND CREWS. ARE IN
THEIR DUTIES THERE AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR DOING
THIS BECAUSE IT IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE GET THEM
HIRED. I THINK THIS IS. A
PROPOSAL THAT WE SHOULD ADOPT
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU TO SENATOR
STERN CENTER DOLLY. IN CENTER
RUBIO- OUT FOR A MOVIE THIS
WORK. NO I HAVEN'T WEIGHED IN
YET BUT DID YOU HAVE A
SOMETHING OPENED AND I WAS JUST
GONNA SAY- THE- CINEMA. POINTS
OUT THERE'S- A DECADE OF WORK
THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND THIS
IS HERE ONE. THIS IS I MEAN
THIS IS A PROPOSAL FOR THE
FIRST YEAR IT'S A TEMPLATE.
WELL HOPEFULLY THAT. WE'VE GOT
TO DO SOMETHING IF WE DO IF.
YOU HAVE A BOND THERE'S A- A
FILLER OF TWO OR THREE YEARS WE
HAVE TO. WORK WITH SUCH AS
UNDERSCORE THAT. SO I'M GONNA
MAKE MY COMMENTS AND I'M GONNA
OPEN IT UP TO- FINANCE AND NOT
TO RESOURCES IN LA- IF THEY
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SOME
COMMENTS AS WELL. SO FIRST OFF
I WANT TO DO ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
A- CENTER WHITE CASKET WORKE.
HE CALLED ME ON SATURDAY AND
SUNDAY. AND I WAS REACHING OUT
TO ME TO. SEE WHAT MY THOUGHTS
WERE ON. THIS PROCESS AND
BEING- I GUESS A FRESHMAN ON
THIS COMMITTEE- AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW IT WORKS IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT IN. MY TIME IN
THE ASSEMBLY. BUT I DID NOTICE
SOME JUST JACKIE RIGHT NOW I
NOTICED ON WHERE THERE'S THIRTY
NINE MILLION WAS. IN SIXTEEN
MILLION FOR THE DEMONSTRATION
PROJECTS IN THE UPPER
WATERSHEDS WITH EMPHASIS ON
WATER SUPPLY AND QUALITY COMBO
OF TREATMENT STRATEGIES WELL
MONITORING SYSTEMS CAPTURED IT
IT THEN WHEN YOU GET TO THE
BOTTOM THAT PARAGRAPH. ON THESE
PROJECTS ARE IN THE NORTH COAST
SOUTHERN SIERRA SAMBAR NINO
NATIONAL FOREST IN THE CENTRAL
COAST WHICH EXCLUDES THE
NORTHERN. PART OF THE
NORTHEASTERN PART OF THE STATE
WHICH 60% OF OUR WATER COMES
FROM SO I WAS WONDERING- HOW
THAT MONEY WHY WOULD NOT BE
DISTRIBUTED AS WELL TO- THAT
NORTHERN SIERRA'S. IF THAT'S
THE CASE THEN THAT'S AN
OVERSIGHT ON MY PART BY MY PART
BUT THAT WAS NOT TO IT WAS NOT
TO EXCLUDE THEM AT ALL THIS IS
JUST WHERE THE NEED IS WE
UNDERSTAND. THAT THESE UPPER
WATERSHEDS IS WHERE THE WORK
HAS TO BE DONE SO THAT THANK
YOU FOR SPOTTING THAT AND- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT WOULD
BE CORRECT OKAY. AND THEN THE
OTHER THING I DO IS I JUST HAVE
SOME GENERAL COMMENTS I WANT TO
MAKE THAT- SENATOR MCGUIRE.
ALLUDED TO NIGHT AND I WILL
NOT. GIVE UP ON THIS- BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S VERY SIGNIFICANT. IN
OUR QUEST FOR- FIXING THE
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEAR PROBLEM
WE CREATED THE- IN THE END I
WILL SAY NOT ALL IN THE
GRASSLANDS AND SOME OF THE
LOWER ELEVATIONS BUT IN THE
UPPER WATERSHEDS- SUPPRESSING
FIRE. WHICH NATURALLY OCCURRED
WAS WRONG AND THAT WAS DONE BY
US- WE DIDN'T ALLOW FIRE TO DO.
WHAT IT ACTUALLY DIDWHICH WAS
BURNED AND TAKE OUT THE
UNDERBRUSH AND SO. AS A AS MANY
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE AND
MANY IN THE PUBLIC KNOW THAT
I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR- DOING THE
RIGHT THING AND I AND I.
MENTIONED EARLIER IN OUR LAST
SET TO ABOUT. MY FRUSTRATION
WITH NOT COUNTING CARBON- IN
WILDFIRE AND I GOT A RESPONSE
BACK ACTUALLY- MY STAFF ON A
RESPONSE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES BOARD. WHICH WAS FOR
FIVE PAGES OF YOU KNOW THE
CARBON CYCLE AND HOW IT WORKS
IN THE WATERSHED I ALREADY
UNDERSTAND THAT CARBON CYCLE
AND THAT WHAT THEIR QUALIFYING
IS WORKING LANDSCAPES AND- SO
ON AND SO FORTH. BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY THE REASON I PUSHED
REALLY HARD FOR. US TO. FORCE
THE AIR BOARD TO QUANTIFY THE
CARBON OUTPUT FROM FIRE IS
BECAUSE 60% OF THE LAND IN
CALIFORNIA IS MANAGED BY OUR
FEDERAL PARTNER. THEY'RE NOT AT
THE TABLE I'M SORRY THEY THEY
HAVE A BUDGET PROCESS IF MANY
WERE AWARE OF. THAT DOESN'T
INCLUDE. A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
WILDFIRE WE'RE FRONTING THE
BILL QUITE FRANKLY. ON OUR
ECONOMY. TO REDUCE CARBON IN
CALIFORNIA AND IT'S THROUGH
MAINLY TRANSPORTATION AND LOT
OF REGULATION ON OUR BUSINESS
IS. WHICH I HAVE SOME ISSUE
WITH ON LOT OF THOSE ISSUES ON
HOW WE GET WHERE WE'RE GOING WE
DIDN'T GET INTO. THIS PROBLEM
OVERNIGHT AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET OUT OF IT OVERNIGHT
BECAUSE IT WAS A HUNDRED YOUR
PROBLEM. THAT WE STARTED SO. I
WANT TO ADD HOW DID WE SAY THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IF WE
WERE IF WE WERE TO CARRY OUT
THE CARBON. AND WE COULD TARGET
WHERE IT COMES FROM. FROM
FOREST FIRE. WE COULD THEN GO
TO OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS AND SAY
HEY YOU NEED TO PARTNER WITH US.
BECAUSE ALL THE GAMES THAT WERE
MAKING. ON THE TRANSPORTATION
SIDE IS BEING EIGHT UP BY OUR
RELEASES ON THE- ON THE FOREST
FIRE SIDE. AND THE CARCINOGENS
THAT ARE PUT OUT IN THESE FIRES
ARE NOT JUST WOULD SMOKE IT'S
ONE WEEK HOW MANY HOMES WERE
BURNED UP AND HOW MUCH.
CARCINOGENS WERE PUT OUT IN
THOSE TYPES IT IS A SITUATION
SO WE NEED TO QUANTIFY THAT AND
WE NEED THE AIR BOARD TO DO IT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT VERY
CLEAR TO THE SENATORS AND THE
PUBLIC THAT ARE WATCHING THIS
THAT IT AT THE END OF THE DAY
IF WE DON'T DO THAT AND WE
DON'T HOLD THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE. BECAUSE
THEY PARTICIPATED IN. FIRE
SUPPRESSION AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA DID. AND THEY NEED
TO BE AT THE TABLE AND THEY
NEED TO BRING THE RESOURCES. TO
FICTION ON A WATERSHED
APPROACH. SO THE LAST THING I
WANT TO MENTION TO IS THAT. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT WE
NEED N. SEQUESTERING CARBON
THROUGH TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT WE'VE BEEN
USING. WE HAVE. A VERY LIMITED
AMOUNT OF INFRASTRUCTURE IN
CALIFORNIA AND NONE OF THESE
NONE OF THAT NOT VERY MUCH OF
THIS. ALL OF OUR OF OUR
BUDGETING PROCESS GOES TO.
FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE. PRIVATE INVESTORS
TO COME ALONG SIDE US AND HELP
REDUCE THE COST REMEMBER IF
YOU'RE TAKING. A PRODUCT OUT OF
THE FOREST IT'S USABLE IT'S
THERE'S A VALUE TO THAT IN IN
IN NOT VALUE REDUCES THE COST
WE CAN TREAT MORE ACRES RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE IS BIG TIME COSTS
GOING INTO. THE MOUNT OF
TREATMENT SO I JUST WANT TO USE
THIS OPPORTUNITY AGAIN. TO
REITERATE MY FRUSTRATION WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND I'M
TRYING TO HOLD THEIR FEET TO
THE FIRE BY DOING LEGISLATION
THAT REQUIRES THEM TO COME TO
THE TABLE SO I JUST WANTED TO
KIND OF GIVE YOU A LONG TERM
PLAN I MET WITH- CHIEF PORTER-
YESTERDAY TALKED TO HIM QUITE A
BIT ABOUT THIS PLAN AND LOOK SO
IT'S A TWO FOLD. OPERATION
NUMBER ONE. IS DOING WHAT
CENTER REQUIRES BEEN ADVOCATING
FOR TO GIVE US THE MATURE THE
QUICKNESS AND THE MANPOWER. TO
PUT OUT THE FIRE THAT'S BURNING
IMMEDIATELY. THE OTHER HALF OF
THAT IS DOING. THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN THE FOREST AND IN
THE GRASSLANDS. AND WE ARE WE
NEED OUR PARTNERS WHICH IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO BE AT THE
TABLE SO THOSE ARE THE THINGS
MR CHAIRMAN THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SHARE AS PART OF THIS
PROCESS AND I DON'T THINK WE
SPEND ENOUGH RESOURCES ON THE
SECOND HALF OF IT REDUCING THE
VEGETATION. AND FORCING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO COME TO
THE TABLE SO WITH THAT I GUESS
RIGHT NOW WE'LL OPEN IT UP FOR
YEAH FINALLY- FINANCE OR NOT TO
RESOURCES IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT YEAH I WOULD I WOULD I
WOULD AGREE WITH WHAT YOU SAID
I THINK PART OF THE WORK HERE
BEFORE YOU ARRIVE WE'VE- WE'VE
INVESTED IN WORKING LANDS IT
HASN'T ALWAYS BEEN. THE
SOMETHING PART OF THE- BUDGET
FINAL RESOLUTION BUT WE'VE BEEN
PRETTY CONSISTENT ON THE SECOND
HALF OF THE EQUATION THAT YOU
HAVE THE OTHER. FIFTY SIX HE
SAID IS THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE
OVER A TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SCIENCE BASED- WORKING WE'RE
GIVING CAL FIRED A ECOLOGICAL
MONITORING RESEARCH AND
ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT TO DO THAT
THE AIRPORT IS GETTING. A
MILLION BUCKS FOR PERMIT
EFFICIENCIES THAT WE THINK THAT
WE CAN WITH THEY CAN HELP US
WITH THAT AND THEN. THE
RESOURCE AGENCIES GOING TO GET
THIS FOR MOST CENSORING WE'RE
GOING TO GIVE THEM SOME MORE
MONEY SO THAT WE CAN. WE USE
TECHNOLOGY AS PART AND
BASICALLY YOU SEE IS GOING TO
BE PART OF THE- THE- THE CAL
FIRE IF THEY DO SOME. MODELING
AND A DEFINITE HAS BEEN WORK SO%
WE- WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S
SOME WORK THAT HAS TO BE DONE
THAT DOESN'T- PRODUCED
IMMEDIATE RESULTS BUT IS KEEP
MAKING US BETTER PREPARE SO
MAYBE THEY- THE AGENCIES WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE SCIENCE.
PORTION OF THE INVESTMENT ALSO.
SO. JESSICA. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PROPOSAL IN JUST MORE STEPHANIE
SECRETARY FOR A FOREST
RESOURCES AT THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY AND-
WE ARE EAGER AND EXCITED TO
PARTNER WITH YOU ON- ON EARLY
ACTION FUNDING AND ONE
EMPHASIZED HOW IMPORTANT A
SPEED OF EARLY ACTION FUNDING
IS THERE A LIMITED WINDOWS
WHERE WE CAN DO REAL WORK ON
THE GROUND FOR FIRE PREVENTION
GIVEN WEATHER CONSTRAINTS AND
SO AND WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
ONE OF THOSE WINDOWS RIGHT NOW
AND SO TO BE ABLE TO GET THESE-
PROJECTS GOING- TO BE ABLE TO
DELIVER HIGHER RESILIENCE
SOONER. WE NEED TO GET STARTED
AND- QUICKLY- I ALSO EMPHASIZED
THAT- WE ARE EXCITED TO REALLY-
PARTNER WITH YOU ON AND ON THE
DETAILS OF THIS AND- AND GET
INTO SOME OF THE NEW ONES- BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE THAT REGIONAL
APPROACH- YOU ARE A BUYER
STRATEGY THE WAY THIS WAS
DESIGNED- AND I THINK THIS IS
ECHOED IN YOUR PROPOSAL IS
THAT- IS THAT WE WOULD CHANGE
PROGRAMS LIKE THE REGIONAL
FORCES FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM
AND THEY WOULD HELP DESIGN
REGIONAL STRATEGIES WE GIVE
THEM- TOOLS COALITION AND STATE
THAT THEY WOULD INTEGRATE THE
DATA INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE
MAKING. TO BE ABLE TO DESIGN
COHESIVE REGIONAL STRATEGIES
AND THEN OUR PROJECT AHLERS
FROM GRANT PROGRAMS WOULD THEN
BE MORE- INTEGRATED I THREW
INTO THOSE REGIONAL STRATEGIES
AND CONSTANT REGIONAL FIRE
FORCING FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM
SO I HOPE THAT YOU'RE REALLY
SEEING SORT OF THAT PARADIGM
SHIFT ON THE REGIONAL APPROACH
HERE HAPPY TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS BUT JUST EXCITED TO
WORK WITH YOU ON THIS AND-
REALLY WOULD URGE US SPEED. IN
GETTING THESE TOWERS ON THE
GROUND. THANK YOU- FINANCE. HI
STEVEN BENSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
ECHOING- MISS MORRIS COMMENTS
ISSUE PRECIADO REALLY SEEING
THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S PROPOSAL IN
THE DETAILS OF YOUR HELPFUL TO
BE ABLE TO- SEE THE COMMITTEE'S
PRIORITIES AS WE CAN GAUGE THE
CONVERSATION GOING FORWARDS WE
APPRECIATE THIS LEVEL OF DETAIL.
JUST A COUPLE OF THOUGHTS WE
HAD- INITIALLY IS- IT'LL BE
HELPFUL SAID AS WE CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION TO SEE- HOW-
THE COMMITTEE'S EARLY ACTION
REPORT. AND LAY OUT WITH WHAT
THEY WERE THINKING ABOUT DOING
IN THE BUDGET YEAR- YEAH JUST
THINKING THAT LIKE OUR OVERALL
PACKAGE HAS A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
REALLY ACTION AND SOME BUDGET
YEAR. FUNDING AND THEN JUST
TRYING TO SEE SOME OF THESE ARE
ARE CLEARLY. OVERALL INCREASES
IN CERTAIN CATEGORIES OF
SPENDING THAT- BE HELPFUL JUST
TO SEE WHETHER SOME OF THE
OTHERS DARK CELEBRATION SO
SHIFTING FUNDING FROM BUDGIE OR
INTO EARLY ACTION HERE. IS KIND
OF HOW WE LAY ON THE BUDGET
YEARS WELLS WE CAN KIND OF
COMPARE OVERALL PACKAGE THAT.
IS SUPER HELPFUL FOR STARTING
THAT. CONVERSATION AND IT IS
THE OTHER THOUGHT BEING THAT-
SO WE'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
REALLY ACTION OBVIOUSLY ONE OF
THE CONSIDERATIONS. WE TOOK
INTO ACCOUNT WAS- THE CAPACITY
THAT DEPARTMENTS HAD WE'RE
DELIVERING WITHIN THE TIME
FRAME- UP EARLY ACTION IN THE
BEGINNING OF THE END OF FISCAL
YEAR SO. AS WE HAVE THE
CONVERSATIONAL JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE LOOKING AT THE
PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
CAPACITY TO DELIVER. YOU KNOW
KIND OF A HIGHER LEVEL WITHIN
THAT SAME SHORTEN TIME FRAME SO.
I'M HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO IN THIS
KIND. AND INTO- THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC IS YOU KNOW THAT'S WHERE.
DEEP IN VERY IMPORTANT
ADMINISTRATION- THE GOVERNORS
WANTED TO DO BIG THINGS WE'VE
MADE CONTINUED INVESTMENTS IN
THIS SPACE EVERY YEAR- MAKE IT
AGAIN TRY TO YOU KNOW LOOKING
AT DOING SOME MORE. IN EARLY
ACTION AS WELL AS ANYBODY HERE
IN THE SPACE- CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT AND RECOGNIZE ALL THE-
HE SAYS THAT THE ABILITY GOT
FIVE NUMBERS HERE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- THEN ALSO L. A. L.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR GENERATES A
LIST WITH THE LA- WE DON'T
COMMENT ON THE SPECIFIC PACKAGE
BUT JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT
WE ARE HERE AS YOUR STAFF TO
SUPPORT YOU AS YOU WORK THROUGH
THESE DISCUSSIONS AND PLEASE
JUST LET US KNOW HOW WE CAN BE
HELPFUL. AS NEGOTIATIONS
PROCEED. THANK YOU. I JUST HAD
ONE LAST COMMENT TO THAT- I
KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW WE DID SP
NINE A ONE. WHICH WAS
BASICALLY- CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION WHEN WE DID THAT
BILL WE CONTINUE TO PROBATE AND
I KNOW THAT THAT THIS IS VERY
ACTIONS GENERAL FUND. AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE CLEAR THAT THE
THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE.
CONCERNED ABOUT HAS BEEN ON A
ONE THAT WILL COME IN THE
LATER. BUDGET AND THOSE FUNDS
WILL COME OUT OF G. G. R. F.
ACTUALLY- TO. DO THE PROGRAMS
SO WITH THAT- NOT SURE WHAT TO
DO NOW. AND BACK TO THE BIKE.
THIS CALL CENTER START SORRY I
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO SEE
YOUR HAND UP SORRY. DON'T SWEAT
IT- WHEN YOU TAKE MY HAND DOWN
HERE- WELL THAT IS SECOND DID I
JUST QUIT MY SCREEN AFTER MY
GOOD YEAR HERE WE SEE YOU OKAY-
JUST ONE QUICK FOLLOW UP
QUESTION- ON- SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY WE JUST HEARD. I
THINK WE'RE THERE'S A THERE'S A
BURGEONING FOR SPEED WHICH I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE AND- THERE
WAS A LITTLE DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE . F. F. C. PROGRAM- THE
PLANS THAT WE'VE SEEN BOTH FROM
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION AND
FROM SOME OF THE DESIGNATED
AGENCIES UNDER THAT PROGRAM
SHOW THAT- THE- TOTAL.
POTENTIAL SIZE OF YOU KNOW SIR
PROJECT SIZE OF MONEY WE COULD
GET OUT THE DOOR QUICKLY- IS
ACTUALLY MUCH BIGGER MY SENSE
THEN THEN YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN
HERE DO YOU THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT. EVEN WITH THE ROBUST-
PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE GOT HERE
THAT WE STILL HAVEN'T MET THE
THEY NEED AT THIS POINT I DON'T
KNOW IF- EVERY SECRETARY FOR
SURE COMMENTED MR BENSON I'M
NOT SURE- BUT LIKE JUST TO TRY
TO GET A SENSE OF. IT FEELS BIG
FEELS BOLD RIGHT BUT- I MEAN
I'VE SEEN JUST ADAM- THE SOME
OF THE CONSERVANCY'S FOR
INSTANCE IN OUR BACKYARD WHO
AFTERWARD THE DESIGNEES UNDER
THE R. FIFTY PROGRAM. EASILY
COULD SPEND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS ALONE THIS YEAR I
MEAN THAT CENTER DOLLY TALKED
ABOUT. IN THE NORTHERN SIERRAS
I MEAN THEY COULD SPEND THE
SAME I THINK IN A IN A HEART
BEAT I MEAN SO DO YOU. IS THERE
SOME OME WAY TO. TO GIVE US A
SENSE OF HOW TO HOW TO. HOW HOW
CLOSE ARE WE TO KEEP BEGINNING
TO RESULT IN HERE I KNOW I.
PRESSED ON IT THE LAST HEARING
SORT OF TRYING TO. GET A
QUANTIFIED VERSION OF THAT BUT-
DID YOU IMMEDIATELY SAID THAT
FROM A DIRECTIONAL SENSE DO YOU
WOULD YOU SAY IT'S FAIR TO
ASSUME THAT. EVEN WITH THIS
INVESTMENT WE'RE STILL NOT
MEETING THE FULL THROUGHPUT
CAPACITY OF WHAT SOME OF THESE.
AGENCIES COULD DO SECRETARY
MORE STORE CASH EITHER ONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN I'M
HAPPY TO GET INTO THAT- EVEN
THIS IS A MULTI GENERATIONAL
CRISIS I THINK EVERYONE'S
REALLY AWARE OF THAT AND YOU
CAN'T- I'M TANGLE IN IN THREE
MONTHS. AND SO AND IT DOESN'T
FIT NEATLY INTO A BUDGET CYCLE
SO WHEN WE WERE THINKING ABOUT
SORT OF EARLY ACTION PERSON IS
LONGER TERM FUNDING- WE WERE
THINKING ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMS CAN YOU. PUT ON THE
GROUND IMMEDIATELY GET THE BALL
ROLLING AND GAIN A STRATEGIC
ADVANTAGE BY GETTING THOSE
FUNDS- THREE TO FIVE MONTHS
EARLY- WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
GET THOSE FUNDS IN MARCH VERSUS
JUNE. AND SO THAT'S HOW WE HAD
DESIGNED IT- AND SO THE ONLY
THING WE DON'T WANT TO LIVE.
AND SHIFTING IT POTENTIALLY
MORE FUNDING INTO AN EARLIER
APPROPRIATION. IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU HAD MENTIONED EARLIER
IN THIS- IN THIS HEARING WHICH
IS A HYBRID APPROACH TO ONE
TIME FUNDING WE- BUT THERE'S A
THERE'S A NEW ONE IN DEAN. YOUR
DOLLARS- FOR THESE PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY FOR CONSERVANCIES IN
STATE PARKS AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHERE WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
REALLY TAKE PROGRAMS START TO
FINISH. AND SO WE HAVE PROPOSED
A FIVE TO SEVEN YEAR
EXPENDITURE LIGHTS. WERE A LOT
OF THESE DOLLARS WHICH WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO HIRE STAFF
UNLIMITED TERMS AND REALLY A
VOID SORT OF THE START AND
STOP- CHALLENGES WE HAVE WITH
THIS FUNDING I'M THE OTHER
THING THAT ALLOWS US TO DO IS
TO GET MORE TO THIS REGIONAL.
FUNDING I THINK WE'RE GETTING
TO THE SAME VISION THERE'S A
HUGE APPETITE AROUND REGIONS
WITH SHOVEL READY PROJECTS THAT
WE ARE EAGER TO FIND OUR VISION
WAS TO HAVE THE REGIONAL
QUESTION BY OUR CAPACITY
PROGRAMS HELPED- BUILD UP
REGIONS THAT YOU DESIGNED FOR
STRATEGIES. AND AND HAVE R.
FORCE GRANT AND OTHER FLEXIBLE
GRANT DOLLARS BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT THE BUDGET. PROPOSAL
WRIT LARGE YEAH A LOT OF ITS
GRANT FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- CLIMATE CATALYST
MY METER FOR SMALL. LANDING AND
OF COURSE HOW AND FIRE. GRANT
DOLLARS WHICH ARE VERY. THE
GOAL IS TO THEM HOW DOES. INTO
EXECUTING THE- FOR. SO WHETHER
YOU I THINK I HAD. WE CAN HAVE
WITH YOUR STAY IS YOU KNOW
WHAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH ON.
FUNDING CAN USED. OR I'M TWENTY
THREE REGIONAL STRATEGIES OR OR
OR BOTH I THINK THE GOAL IS TO
GET THE FUNDING SHOULD BE
TARGETED. TO THE REGIONS AND
BRING THE FULL FORCE- OF THE
STRATEGY HERE IN PLACE. AND I
THINK THAT IS REALLY EMPHASIZES
THAT NEED STRATEGY WE HAVE
PROPOSED WITH THIS BUDGET- ALL
OF THE PROGRAMS REINFORCE ONE
ANOTHER. AND THEY ARE DESIGNED
TO BE HELD UP AND SO I THINK
ONE OF THE CONVERSATIONS WE CAN
HAVE. ON GOING HERE IS REALLY
I'M SURE THAT ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS GO FORWARD BECAUSE YOU
DON'T WANT TO REMOVE THE BRICKS
FROM THE ARCH- AND WE WANT THIS
TO GO FORWARD IN A WAY THAT IS
NOT ONLY WENT BUST AND FAST.
DATABLE TO REALLY DELIVER THAT
LONG TERM. GOAL OF RESILIENCE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. THANKS
FOR THE AND YOU KNOW I WOULD
ADD I THINK THIS THE SAME
HYBRID. COULD BE MADE ON A
HARDENING SUPPLEMENT AS WELL.
THAT THAT. I HOPE GOING FORWARD
THATWILL WILL ADHERE TO THAT
PRINCIPLE THAT. THEN HAVING
CAPACITY BUILDING INTO EARLY
ACTION MONEY IS A TYPE OF
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS RIGHT BY
INVESTING IN PEOPLE AND THAT
SORT OF CAPACITY AND GIVING IT
THE PROPER INCOME BRING CYCLE
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD THAT INTO
THAT HELP SAVE A COUNTY OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICE ACTUALLY
BUILD THEIR HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN FOR INSTANCE TO TAKE
HARDENING INTO ACCOUNT. AT
PRIVATE HOMES NOT JUST ON
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE AND RIGHT
NOW THEY'RE SORT OF CRISIS TO
CRISIS YOU KNOW- THE SAME GOES
FOR SOME OF THESE LAND
MANAGEMENT AGENCIES YOU TALKED
ABOUT- THIS IS SO AND- THE
CHASING OF THE GRANT CYCLE I DO
WORRY ABOUT A LITTLE BIT. IF
IT'S JUST STRUCTURED IN THOSE
SMALLER DOLLAR AMOUNTS WE DON'T
GET LONG TERM INSTITUTIONAL
CAPACITY MISSION ALIGNMENT AND
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS SO I
REALLYAPPRECIATE YOU BRINGING.
THAT POINT UP- AND I HOPE YOU
WILL CONSIDER THAT GOING
FORWARD AND TO AND TO THAT END
I THINK. THERE'S WE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT IT BUT THERE MAY
BE I MAY. AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME MISTER CHAIR I MAY MAKE A
MOTION FOR SOME CLARIFICATION
AROUND. ADD SOME PARITY ON SOME
OF THESE ELEMENTS BUT- I THINK
THAT'S FOR LATER. IS THAT
THAT'S FOR LATER IN THIS
HEARING PROCESS. YEAH AFTER WE
HAVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
OKAY. GREAT I ALWAYS ARE THERE
FOR LATER THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WELL THANK YOU THAT WILL WILL
COME BACK TO ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY TWO AND NOW LET'S OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT I'M GOING
TO. AREA WE'RE GONNA TODAY'S
AGENDA WE HAVE. THIRTY TWO
ITEMS ON PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE.
WITH. MR KELLY GOOD. GOOD
MORNING YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THIS
IS AN HONEST PAYMENT. HEY LET'S
GET THE AUDIO ON. THANK YOU
OKAY WE'LL BE RIGHT YEAH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CHRISTMAS
CEILIDH ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES- ON
ITEM THIRTY TWO THAT YOU JUST
CONCLUDED- WE DO SUPPORT THE
WORK OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION AND
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
ADDITIONAL COMMENT THAT- THIS
WOULD NOT NEGATE. THE FULL
BUDGET YOUR FUNDING WELL AS YOU
KNOW LAST YEAR WHAT WE BURNED
OVER FOUR MILLION ACRES HAD A
HUNDRED MILLION PLUS TONS OF
GHG EMISSIONS FROM THOSE FIRES.
I THINK THERE IS MORE THAN TEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN INSURED
LOSSES- IT'S SEPARATE SEVERAL
WE ALL KNOW THE STATISTICS AND
HOW BAD IT IS IN ADDITION TO
THE FUNDING AS YOU'RE AWARE WE
BELIEVE THAT SEVERAL POLICY
ISSUES SHOULD BE ADDRESSED AS
WELL. INCLUDING PRESCRIBED FIRE
LIABILITY THE USE OF BIOMASS TO
ADDRESS A LOT OF THE FUEL WASTE
WOOD WASTE IN THE FOREST AND
ALSO DO ESSENTIALLY YOU HAVE
ONE PERSON FIRMLY IN CHARGE OF
GOING AFTER THOSE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STATE ACRES THAT NEED
ANNUAL TREATMENT SO AGAIN WE DO
SUPPORT YOUR ACTIONS MISTER
CHAIR AND WELCOME- WORKING WITH
YOU THIS YEAR ON THIS.
IMPORTANT FORESTRY REFORM ISSUE
THANK YOU. OKAY LET'S SEE
SEEING NOBODY ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM GO TO ROOM ONE ONE
TWO. HAVE THAT REPAIRS TO BE
VACANT SO- THEY'RE BOTH WHO
ONCE SAID LET'S MOVE ON TO
PEOPLE WANTING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- REGARDING. THE
PLAN THE VARIOUS ITEMS BEFORE
BUT BEFORE US HOWEVER AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS 844-291-6364 THE
ACCESS CODE IS FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN SIX OH NINE WHICH IS
ON THE SCREEN. TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY. I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC FIGHTING COMMENT KEEP
YOUR REMARKS TO ONE MINUTE
PLEASE PROVIDE US WITH WRITTEN
COMMENTS AS WE DO READ THOSE.
AT THE AIRPORT BECAUSE OF. WITH
THAT SAID OF MARCH PLEASE. HOW
TWO OF THE FIRST PERSON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBERS IN
PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO MAKE
A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE.
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR OUR FIRST COMMENT.
ON THE LINE OF NUMBER ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ADAM KING
ON US ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. I'M JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR TWO ITEMS
TODAY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
RELATED TO FUNDING FOR THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS. AQUA
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT PROC PROCESS- WE
RECOGNIZE THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS AS THE BEST APPROACH
TO ACHIEVING THE CO EQUAL GOALS
OF PROTECTING. RESTORING AND
ENHANCING THE DELTA ECOSYSTEM
AND INCREASING WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- THE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES PARTICIPATING IN THAT
B. A.'S ARE READY TO BEGIN THE
IMPLEMENTATION PROJECTS NOW-
THEY PLEDGED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND AN
EXTENSIVE SERIES OF.
RESTORATION PROD PROJECTS TO
ENHANCE FISH AND WILDLIFE
HABITAT. THE PROPOSED FINDING
AN ITEM TWENTY FIVE IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL. TO SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION. I'M AND THEN-
VERY QUICKLY ONE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT REGARDING ITEM THIRTY
ONE- RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OB WILL CONTINUE
TO ADVOCATE THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THAT FUNDING IS
DEDICATED TO SUCCESSFUL SEGMENT
IMPLEMENTATION. INCLUDING THE
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS REQUESTED
TODAY. WEEK WE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT E. W. ARE IN THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION WILL STICK BY.
AND THE GSA- WE ALSO AGREE THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET THE
FUNDING OUT SOON BUT WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL THE SPLIT OF
THIRTY MILLION IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND THIRTY NINE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
PROPOSALS THANK YOU NEXT. THE
TERM ALARM NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARE MEMBERS
JENNIFER APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
THE MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION
OCEAN CONSERVANCY AND THE
CALIFORNIA FISHING GAME WARDEN
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ASSOCIATION. IN THE PARK THE
ONE TIME INVESTMENT TO ADDRESS
HUMAN WILDLIFE CONFLICTS THAT
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL ON LIFE AND
THE LORD AND- CLEARLY SUPPORT
YOUR EQUIPMENT TO ENHANCE OUR
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS BUT ALONG
WITH DOZENS OF OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WE'VE WRITTEN TO
YOU ALL AGREE WITH YOU THAT THE
COMPLETION OF THE F. B. BEING
IDEA W. IN ARGUABLY ONCE IN A
LIFETIME OPPORTUNITY. TO ACT ON
THE REALITY THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
SEVERELY UNDER INVESTED IN
MANAGING AND PROTECTING OUR
STATE BIODIVERSITY EFFORTS THAT
MEDICATION AND HIGHLIGHTED THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF DOING
WITH ITS RECENT EXECUTIVE ORDER
RECOGNIZING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LONG TERM ALITY IS THREATENED
BY THE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
BIODIVERSITY. AND THE GOVERNOR
COMMITTED TO TAKING STEPS TO
COMBAT THE BIODIVERSITY AND
CLIMATE CRISIS BUT WE ARE NOT
DOING THAT IF THE STATE ONE
DEPARTMENT WITH MISSION IS TO
MANAGE CALIFORNIA'S RICH ****
WILDLIFE AND PLANT BIODIVERSITY
EXPANDER. OUT LESS THAN A THIRD
OF IT CURRENT RESPONSIBILITIES
THE PROPOSED BUDGET PROPOSES
NOT ONE ADDITIONAL DOLLAR AND
ONGOING FUNDING WE URGE YOU TO
PRESS THESE ISSUES FURTHER WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION WHICH WITH
FRUSTRATINGLY JUST TESTIFIED
THAT THEY WERE NOT MAKING A
COMMITMENT EITHER WAY. PLEASE
MAKE THAT COMMITMENT AND WORK
WITH US I CAN MEET TOMORROW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. MY
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS ALL PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS NOT THE
LANDING TO CLARA VALLEY WATER
DOES I THANK YOU WHAT ARE. I
WANT TO TALK TO ON THE PHONE
TWENTY. MINUTES PRACTICALLY AND
WE START WITH THE COMPANY
EVENTUALLY OF AGE. AFTER THE TO
HABITAT IMPROVEMENT CAN BE PH I
THINK THAT A TROUBLED CRITICAL
AT ON THIS IS- OUR LAND IT THAT
WAS MY A COUPLE YES I AND WE
WERE HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
IS ABLE TO SUPPORT THE- HAPPY
AFTER AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU MAX.
BLIND FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. BUT SURE
NUMBERS ON WALL TIME THE CAL
THAT BUT ASSOCIATION WE HAVE
CONCERNS WITH ISSUES AND TWENTY
THOUSAND ON TODAY'S AGENDA- I'D
LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT OVER THE
PAST NUMBER OF YEARS WE HAVE
SUPPORTED THE TRIPLING OF
HALOGENS BUDGET STAFF SIDE.
WE'VE COOPERATED WITH AND
SUPPORTED BY GROWTH
INTELLIGENCE THAT THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO BE MORE RESPONSIVE AND
BETTER RESPOND TO OUR NEEDS AND
DO THEIR REGULATORY OVERSIGHT.
DESPITE TRIPLING IN SIZE
CALGENE'S WORK PRODUCT HAS
GOTTEN SLOWER AND LESS
EFFICIENT AND LESS RESPONSIVE
RATHER THAN FASTER AND BETTER
BUT WE PIVOTED LAST YEAR AND
BEGAN OPPOSING STAFFING
INCREASES. HELD AT NINETY. AND
THEN PLAN TODAY FOR STABBING
THAT CALCIUM BUT I'D LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE CALCIUM HAS HAD A
CHRONIC VACANCY RATE. RUNNING
OVER 70% FOR THE LAST SIX YEARS
STRAIGHT. SO WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE DEPARTMENT ALL
STAFFING CHALLENGES AT KALYAN
CANNOT BE BLAMED ON COKE AT
NIGHT HE- CURRENTLY COUNT YOU
HAVE FIFTY ONE VACANCIES AND
THIRTEEN FULL TIME P. Y. THREE
DIRECTED TO KOBE CONTACT RATE.
THAT MEANS THERE ARE SEVENTY
FOUR STAFF WE PAY FOR WHO ARE
NOT WORKING AT CAL JAM OUT OF
THE THREE HUNDRED PLUS
POSITIONS THEY ARE A LOT OF.
CALCIUM DOES NOT NEED MORE
STAFF RIGHT NOW THEY NEED TO
HIRE AND RETAIN THE POSITION
THEY ARE CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED.
SPECIFICALLY ON ISSUE TEN
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO ASK THAT F YOU DO RE
AUTHORIZED THESE POSITIONS- OR
CONVERT THEM TO PERMANENT
POSITIONS WE ACTUALLY ASK THAT
YOU MAKE THEM LIMITED TERM
AGAIN. AFTER THREE YEARS WITH A
REPORT BACK WE FULLY COOPERATE
WITH THEIR WITNESS THE PROCESS.
AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THAT ROLE FOR
CALCIUM AND. CLOSING ON ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN. THE TWENTY FIVE
TO THE FROM ONE YEAR ARE ALL.
YET WE WOULD REQUEST THAT GIVE
JAM IT'S YOU CATCH UP AND TIME.
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT LASTLY
THAT THE ONLY ONE OF R. U. I.
T. PROJECT HAS BEEN APPROVED IN
THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF- WE'RE
WE'RE NOT GETTING A LEVEL OF
RESPONSE FROM CAL JAM THAT WE
NEED. FOR THESE REASONS WE
REQUEST THAT YOU MODIFY ISSUE
TEN AND REJECT ISSUE TWENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU SIR. Q. NEXT.
MY NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- CAN DELFINO
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE- ASK ISSUE TWENTY FIVE
DEFENDERS SUPPORTS THE
RECOMMENDATION THE AD BUDGET
THE LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TOTHE RESOURCES
AGENCY ON HOW TO BEST
PRIORITIZED EXPENDITURES OF A
PROPERTY IT HAD BEEN HAPPENING.
FOR YOU TWENTY EIGHT- DEFENDERS
AND THAT TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND
ALIGNED WITH COMMENTS WITH
THOSE MADE BY JENNIFER FEARING
I KNOW THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAD PROPOSED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND LAST
YEAR. ONE THIRTY P. WHY THEN
THEY'RE IN DANGER SPECIES
PROGRAM THAT YOU CAN CREATE
THOSE BENEFITS SPECIES AND
HABITAT CONSERVATION AS WELL
PERMITTING BUT FOR SOME REASON
THEY HAVE FAILED TO PUT THAT
PROGRESS THAT A PROPOSAL FOR
THIS YEAR DESPITE WHAT THE
SERVICE STATE BUDGET SHOWING
THAT WE WOULD AGREE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CAN DO BETTER.
FOR ISSUE TWENTY NINE DEFENDERS
AGREED WITH THE DEPARTMENT B.
C. P. ARE DIRECTED AT FINDING
IMPORTANT ACTIVITIES WE
HIGHLIGHT CRITICALLY DOCUMENT
WILDLIFE CONFLICT AVOIDANT
WETLAND CONSERVATION OF
VEGETATION MAPPING. AND FINALLY
FOR ISSUE THIRTY TWO WE
APPRECIATE THE SENATE PROPOSAL
PARTICULARLY THE FUNDING FOR
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND CDFW
STAFFING PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT
OF WHAT THE SERVICE BASE BUDGET
HAS SHOWN US- GIVEN THAT WE'RE
HEADING IN THE TRIAL AND
ANOTHER POTENTIALLY SEVERE
FIRES. INJECTED HERE TO GET
DOLLARS ON THE GROUND TO THOSE
WHO ARE ALREADY WORKING TO
REDUCE FIRE RESCUE AND RESTORE
LANDSCAPE RESILIENCE AND WE
NEED NEW FUNDING NOW TO KEEP IT
GOING. YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
TIMES THAT WE WANTED THE EARLY
BUDGET ACTION BUT THOSE EFFORTS
DON'T STOP AND WE URGE THE
THREE KEY PARTY. SOMEBODY IN
GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR YOUR WORK
TOGETHER THIS MONTH TO DELIVER
AN EARLY ACTION BUDGET
AGREEMENT SO WE CAN KEEP THIS
MOMENTUM GOING. AND NOT LOSE
CRITICAL TIME THANK YOU. X. MY
NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WITH A CHORISTER AND ALL
ECHO REALLY EVERYTHING CAN TO
YOU KNOW JUST ON BEHALF OF THE
THUNDER WHILE AND FOR PUBLIC
LAND WITH REGRD TO. A WILDLIFE
AS WELL AS THE PROPOSED
WILDFIRE PROPOSAL REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS MADE BY
BOTH STARTED REQUIRE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE ON THE
COMMITTEE- RECOGNIZING THIS
TALE OF THE NEEDS OF WILDFIRE
AND BERKELEY GROUP AND
LANDSCAPERS ONLY IT'S MORE
BROADLY. AND THAT IS GONNA BE
THE CHALLENGE THE NEXT DECADE-
THIS LOCK A LAKE IN THE
PROPOSAL YOU GUYS DISCUSSED
TODAY- INCLUDING THIS FOCUS ON
UPPER WATERSHEDS WHICH SHOP
OWNER DOLLARS ALSO
HIGHLIGHTING- I THINK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WE DO NOT LOSE
TRACK OF IT IS THAT WE NEED TO
ACT RIGHT AWAY IN ORDER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF LOOKING TO FIND.
OUT IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO EVEN THOUGH SOME
OF THIS CONVERSATION NEEDS TO
CONTINUE INTO THE BUDGET
DISCUSSION FOR YOUR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- I REALLY ENCOURAGE
ALL THREE PARTIES TO COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT IN THE NEXT
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO COMING OUT
RIGHT AWAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. MY NUMBER TWO THREE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE CALL.
THE MORNING SHARE- COMMITTEE
THAT HAS JENNIFER P. ON THE
MANAGER FOR THE STATE WATER.
AND WE SERVE ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS SOME
PORTION OF THEIR DRINKING WATER
I'M ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
I JUST WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS FUNDING FOR
THE STATE NOT JUST THEN I'M
PROMOTING THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT BUT JUST BECAUSE
THESE ARE ACTIONS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN TO- REALLY START TO
IMPLEMENT NO RISK- NO REGRET HI
PROJECT OR- PROMOTING BESTEHT
OBJECTED. AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE TRANSPARENCY THAT- NATIONAL
RESOURCES HAS COMMITTED TO WE
HOPE THAT THEY CAN EXPEDITE THE
COLLECTION PROCESS BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO WAIT. SEVERAL
YEARS FOR THAT COMPETITIVE
PROCESS TO GO THROUGH BUT-
OTHERWISE THEY'RE VERY SUPPORT
ABOUT THIS FUNDING AND HOPE TO
SEE A VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT.
THANK YOU MAX. LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS NO WELL
CREAMERS WITH WINE INSTITUTE I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION THIS MORNING ON ITEM
THIRTY TWO FOR THE WILD KERR
PREVENTION AND RESILIENCE EARLY
ACTION PLANS. WHY NOT USE THE
COURT OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCE AND REALLY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE MONEY GET OUT TO
COMMUNITIES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. THE TWENTY TWENTY
WILDFIRES COST AND THE WINE
INDUSTRY THREE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS AND IN THE
RECENT GRAPE CRUSH REPORT WE
SAW A DECLINE IN GREAT CRASH
THAT NEARLY 14% AND THAT TYPE
OF SMOKE EXPOSURE TO GREAT SO.
OUR INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY THE
WILDFIRES IN RECENT YEARS AND
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP REDUCE
FIREBRAND IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
AS ONE EXAMPLE NAPA COUNTY HAS.
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS A FUEL
BREAK. YOU BREAK PROJECTS ARE
READY RIGHT NOW AND IF THEY'RE
COMPLETED THIS YEAR AND IT WILL
SAVE COSTS ON SOME OF THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW. AND
THERE'S ALSO THE NORTH BAY FIRE
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT THAT CAN
USE INTERNATIONAL FUNDING TO
HELP PRIVATE LAND OWNERS BETTER
MANAGE THEIR FORESTS AND REDUCE
FIRE RISK. AND WE URGE EARLY
ACTION ON TAPE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE MOMENTUM IS NOT LOST
AND THESE FUNDS ARE OUT TO HELP
COMMUNITIES RECOVER FROM FIRES
AND PREVENT. THESE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU NECKS. MY NUMBER
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TERM
MEMBERS NIKITA PATEL BY TELL
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL EVEN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE REALLY GETS.
FUNDING WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
FUNDS FOR HABITAT RESTORATION
TO BENEFIT NATIVE FISH AND
WILDLIFE BUT WE ECHO THE ALLEY
AS RECOMMENDATIONS THAT. HE BE
ABOUT TO THE LANGUAGE TO
PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO THE
RESOURCES AGENCY ON HOW TO
PRIORITIZE THE USE OF THE
COTTON. THE TYPICALLY SUPPORT
ALLOCATING THE FUNDS DIRECT
COMPETITIVE PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT GRANT PROCESS
SPECIFYING PRIORITIZATION
CRITERIA FOR SELECTING PROJECTS
TO MAXIMIZE CONSERVATION
BENEFITS FOR EVERY DOLLAR SPENT
AND FINALLY IDENTIFYING AMOUNTS
TO BE USED FOR SPECIFIC STAKE
MY OBLIGATION. THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER FUNDED SUCH AS
RESTORATION OF THE CALL COULD
BE CRITICALLY IMPORTANT HABITAT
RESTORATION PROJECTS SHOULD NOT
BE HELD UP FOR A HYPOTHETICAL
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT MATERIALIZE TO KEEP
TRACK. OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS MAKES CLEAR THERE IS
NO LONG TERM AGREEMENT AND NO
ON GOING NEGOTIATIONS AND
ENERGIES YET MANY OTHER
CONSERVATION OFFICIAL GROUPS
OPPOSE THE PROPOSALS FOR V.
EIGHT THAT HAVE BEEN FLOATED TO
DATE. I DON'T LIKE TO DELETE MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF JENNIFER
FEARING AND KENTUCKY NOW ON
THAT. PART OF MY LIFE. BUT
THAT'D LIKE TO TAKE FOR THE- TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK
YOU A NECK. LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS ALL.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS AND ALSO ON BEHALF YOUR
LOCAL CALIFORNIA- UNTIL FIVE
LET TO PROPERTY YOU HAVE
HAPPENING ALAINA COMMENTS GRIEF
MADE BY THANK YOU AND D. C. A
LIST OF ELLIE WORKING DAYS OF
PEACE SHOULD BE JUST CIRCLE IT
A COUPLE PROCESS. AND THAT YOU
ARE CONSIDERED AMOUNTS FOR-
ADVENTURE OF WETLAND REFUGES
ARE STRUCTURED WITH PALM TREE
AND PRIDE IN TWENTY EIGHT
REGARDING CFW SERVICE BASED
BUDGETING REVIEW A LOT OF
COMMENTS MADE THE JUMP REPAIR
AND CONDUCT YOU KNOW AND WE
ALSO AGREE THAT GFW SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO REPORT SPECIFIC
ACTION THAT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
TAKE TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
ISSUES BEFORE. THE MAY REVISE
THIS RELEASE- THIS IS A POINT
APARTMENT IT MAKES THAT DOES
IMPORTANT WORK AND WE'RE
CURIOUS AS TO HOW THE PARNELL
ABLE TO BE ABLE TO OFFICIALLY
FIND ITS PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MODERATOR- WE HAVE A
FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE THAT'S
GOING ON SIMULTANEOUSLY AND
THEY'RE CALLING THE RULE SO I
WOULD LIKE TO PAUSE FOR A
SECOND WITH THE PUBLIC COMMENT
EVERYBODY ON. PUBLIC COMMENT. A
LINE. STAY ON THE LINE I GUESS
I CAN GIVE. PEOPLE ONLINE BUT
JUST STAY ON THE LINE WE'LL
TAKE A- TWO MINUTE. AND WILL BE
ABLE. TO CONTINUE SO I HAVE.
FOR THAT BUT WE'RE- PART OF THE
COVERT SEEN HERE WERE
OVERLAPPING ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR.
OKAY BACK ON THE
RECORD FUNDRAISER THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE HELLO WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE NECKS OF MEMBER
OR HAVING THE NEXT TELL THANK
YOU MISS. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
LINE NUMBER TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M GAINING MARKETING DIRECTOR
OF WATER RESOURCES WITH
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU- WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM
TWENTY FIVE HELD FOR NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCIES- PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT HABITAT IMPROVEMENT
DC P. FOUR HUNDRED FIVE TWENTY
FIVE MILLION- THAT WILL HELP-
MOVED VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
FORWARD AND MORE RAPIDLY HELP
THE ENVIRONMENT HABITAT FOOD
PRODUCTION ALL BENEFICIAL USES.
WE ALSO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
BRIGHTON THIRTY ONE THE SIGNUP
FUNDING REQUEST THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS
COORDINATION AND OUTREACH TO
ALL STAKEHOLDERS HAS BEEN
SUPERB ON ON THE SEGMENT FRONT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. LIE
NUMBER FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL GOOD
MORNING NOT SURE WHAT ELSE CAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
STEVEN MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS MEETING
MAJOR CONNECTION MENTAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE SPEAKING ON
ISSUE NUMBER FORTY. WEEKS
SPECIAL COURT FOR THE PROPOSED
WILDFIRES MUST BE SPECIALLY THE
EARLY ACTUALLY PROPOSES. IF YOU
HAVE HAD A HISTORY OF UNDER
INVESTMENT EMPIRE PREVENTION
REPORT THE FIRE SUPPRESSION IT
IS INCLUDING EXACERBATED BY THE
LACK OF YOUR INVESTMENTS THIS
LAST BUDGET YEAR WHICH OF
COURSE MANY OF US TO POSTPONE
OUR WORK ON A LONG LIST OF
CRITICAL. PROJECTS THAT WOULD
PROTECT. WHILE WE CANNOT
CONTINUE TO WAIT WE- URGE YOU
TO THESE. INVESTMENT EARLY AS
POSSIBLE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY THREE THE LINE IS ALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING JAMIE MINOR BEHALF OF
EASTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT INTERLOCUTOR DITION
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF ISSUE
TWENTY FIVE THAT PROPOSITION
SIXTY HAPPENED HAPPENING- YOU
KNOW MANY AGENCIES ARE READY TO
GO WITH PROJECT DEPLOYED TO
HELP HABITAT RESTORATION-
YOU'RE DEPENDING ON THAT
AGREEMENT THAT THAT VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS AND THIS FUNDING
WOULD BE YOU KNOW CRITICAL AND
HELPING THEM TO ACHIEVE THESE.
OR TEN- BENEFIT FOR BOTH THE
ECOSYSTEM AND FOR WATER SUPPLY
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU AN X.
Y. NUMBER FOUR. BY NUMBER FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN SENATORS THE CONTRACTS
ON BEHALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT THIS MORNING
FIRST WANT TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
TWENTY EIGHT PERTAINING TO THE
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
WHILE WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR
SUPPOSE ONE TIME EXPENDITURES
WE BELIEVE WE NEED TO DO MUCH
MORE. IN LIGHT OF THE RECENTLY
COMPLETED SERVICE MAKE
BUDGETING PROCESS THE COUNCIL
CLEAR THAT A PLAN FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES CERTAINLY
MORE THAN A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
IS DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE SIGNIFICANT AND
STRUCTURAL UNDERFUNDING GAPS.
IN THE MISSION WORK OF THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE.
R. DIGER THIRTY TWO MAJOR
CONCERT THE STRONGLY. ONLY
ACTION APPROPRIATION A WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE. THERE ARE SHOVEL
READY PROJECTS CRITICAL TO
ADDRESSING THE THREAT OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE. THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR DOING IT IS
THE TIMING THE SOONER WE CAN
ALLOCATE TO CLEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FUNDING THE MORE LIKELY THE
PROJECT WILL BE COMPLETED IN
ADVANCE OF THE UPCOMING FIRE
SEASON. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT HELLO ESPECIALLY THE
FUNDING PROPORTIONS ACTOR
ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND FINDING A
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND FOREST
HEALTH PROJECTS. WHICH CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IMMEDIATELY TO
REDUCE THE IMPACT OF WILDFIRES
INCLUDING. REDUCING IMPACT OF
SMOKE IN OUR COMMUNITIES. ALSO
TMC SUPPORT ISSUE THIRTY ONE
THE SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SIGMA PLANNING INPUT
IMPLEMENTATION GRANT. EITHER
CENTRAL FOR SUCCESSFUL
SEGMENTATION THANK YOU MR
TERENCE LETTERS FOR YOUR
PACKING YOUR SHIP ON THESE
ISSUES WE RESPECTFULLY URGE.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT. LIE NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
TONYA SANCHEZ WITH THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ORGANIZATION AND THE PRIZES
COMMITTEEMAN ISSUE THIRTY ONE
ACCORDING TO FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR SIX MONTHS. WE
SUPPORT THE ABILITY CONDITION
HAVE MINIMUM WE REQUEST THAT AT
LEAST 10% OF THE FUNDING TO BE
USED FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GRANTS TO ENSURE CONTINUED
CAPACITY BUILDING AND
ENGAGEMENT HAS IMPACTED THE
ANISH COMMUNITIES AND KIND OF
PUBLICATION. AND AT LEAST 30%
OF THE FUNDING GO TO PROJECTS
THAT PROTECT YOU CAN WATER
INCLUDING IDENTIFYING THE
IMPACT OF THE PLANS OF THE
IMMUNITY STREAK YOU WANT
IMPLEMENTING WATER MEDICATION
PROGRAM. THANK. YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. WHY NOT THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS ALL PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE BEARING ALSO
REPRESENTING THE GOLDEN STATE
SALMON ASSOCIATION SPEAKING TO
ITEM TWENTY FIVE- AS WITH THE
CASE OF SEVERAL OF THE SPEAKERS
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION- WE'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE STAFF'S
RECOMMENDATION TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE REGARDING THE
EXPENDITURE. PROP SIXTY EIGHT
FUNDS FOR FISH WILDLIFE HABITAT
RESTORATION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
FISH AND WILDLIFE HABITAT
RESTORATION USING THESE FUNDS
SO THERE ARE TWO REASONS WHY WE
SUPPORT THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FIRST IS THAT
THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT PROCESS
IS NOT ON TRACK TO PRODUCE
CREDIBLE AGREEMENTS. YOU CAN
SEE THAT BY THE INABILITY OF
STATE AGENCIES TO SPEND FUNDS
ON VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS THAT
YOU APPROPRIATED FUNDS FOR LAST
YEAR I WOULD DEEPLY CONCERNED
WITH THE FOCUS ON THIS
INEFFECTIVE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT
PROCESS. DELAYING NEEDED STATE
BOARD FATAL FOR STANDARD TO
PROTECT SALMON AND JOBS IN OUR
INDUSTRY SECOND WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
SPENT IN A TIMELY FASHION AND
ON THE MOST EFFECTIVE PROJECTS.
OF TE SURVIVAL OF TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND JOBS IN THE SALMON
FISHING INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
DEPENDS ON BOTH NEW FLOWS
STANDARDS AND AMBITIONS HABITAT
RESTORATION WE BELIEVE THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION ON ITEM
TWENTY FIVE WOULD HELP ADVANCE
BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU HI MAX.
LIE NUMBER THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOE COLE AND
I AM THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
THE TREE PEOPLE IN A CROSS
BORDER VOICE MY STRONG SUPPORT
FOR ITEM NUMBER THIRTY TWO AND-SPECIFICALLY FOR TREEPEOPLE
PROPOSE WILD. WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE HUB AND HEADQUARTERS
CORNER IN CALABASAS I HOPE IN
THIS LOCATION WILL OFFER AN
IMPORTANT MODEL TO EDUCATE
HOMEOWNERS AND THE GENERAL
PUBLIC ON THE CENTRAL WILDFIRE
SAFETY MEASURES THIS LOCATION
IN THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS
AT THE CENTER OF LOS ANGELES'S
URBAN WILDLAND INTERFACE.
BETWEEN THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
IN MALIBU WHERE WILDFIRES
JUSTIN SO DEVASTATING IN THE
PAST AND AS EVERYONE KNOWS WILL
CONTINUE TO POSE. SUCH A HUGE
THREAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NECKS. LIE NUMBER FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
DENNIS I'LL BE ON THE ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA CLARITA VALLEY
WATER AGENCY SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
M. W. D. E. SPACE A WATER-
TOWARD THE UTILITY DISTRICT.
AROUND THEY DID HAVE A CLOSE
CUT OFF ALREADY WE SUPPORT THE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS AND HAVE A
JOB FUNDING FOR TO HELP BRING
THAT COLLABORATION TOGETHER. AS
MENTIONED THERE'S BEEN YEARS OF
INVESTMENT AND THIS COULD HELP
BRING THE HABITAT. BOARD PUBLIC
VOID- THE- INDUSTRY SHOULD ACT
ISSUES. WE ALSO SUPPORT ITEM
THIRTY ONE. SIEGMAN PUBLICATION
WHICH HAS. SIGNIFICANT
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE LOCALS AND
DOING THE STUDIES AND
HYDROLOGICAL EVALUATION
NECESSARY TO BRING THOSE
CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED BASINS
INTO COMPLIANCE. BY LINE. FROM
THE HELP OF OUR AGRICULTURAL
CLIENTS WHICH INCLUDE WIPED OUT
IT'S USUALLY. THE ALMOND
ALLIANCE FOUND THE COLOR GRADED
PMG DISSOCIATION WE ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH THE WINE
INSTITUTE. ON ISSUE THIRTY TWO
WITH WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT BUT WE
WOULD WANT TO PROMOTE
ADDITIONAL BIO ENERGY-
INVESTMENTS AS THAT PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH ENERGY
INVESTMENT AS WELL AS CLEAN UP
THE FOREST AND GET RID OF
SIDEWALKS OF DEBRIS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU ZACKS.
LINER FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME IS RICHARD
GENERAL GOOD MORNING SHARING
YOUR NEEDS AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- I AM ALSO ON BEHALF OF
BLACK FOREST MATTER IN FORCED
LABOR I WOULD LIKE TO DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION WHAT WAS ADDED. TO
THE PUBLIC RECORD- NEARBY AFTER
HEARING FIVE WHY PORTS MATTER
INITIALLY AT I LIKE TO CALL
ATTENTION YOUR COUPLE THINGS
LIVES OUT THREE TO. EARN
SCIENCE BASED MANAGEMENT FOREST
HEALTH AND WATERSHED PROTECTION
AND BRING IN- SHARK DIVE CENTER
DOLLAR HAD TO SAY ABOUT TAKE A
HUNDRED YEARS YOUR SISTER'S
SITUATION DEMANDS TO GIVE SOME
PERSPECTIVE ON THAT YOU GO TO
THE APRIL TWENTY EIGHTEEN. R.
L. A. O. A REPORT PROVING
CALIFORNIA'S TROJAN WAR SHOULD
MANAGEMENT AND PAGE NINETEEN
GIVES A GRAPHIC EXAMPLE OF WHAT
A HEALTHY FOREST USE WHICH IS
OUR GOT A PREDOMINANCE OF THE
LARGER IN OLDER TREES POLISH-
REALLY ACTION PLAN ITEMS IT'S
IMPORTANT RELIVING THE
MERCHANDISE DID YOU MOVE
FORWARD. BUT THE STANDARDS
JACKSON JUST TO HELP THE POOR
TO MARGINAL RETREAT IS NOT
HAPPENING AND IT USED TO BE A
PART OF THE ACTION FROM THE
BEGINNING. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT. BLIND FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ZERO PLEASE AHEAD. I JANKI
NATH WITH WHAT CENTER. COMING
ON ISSUES ONE REGARDING FIFTY
MILLION FIRSTPLAN AND
EMPLOYMENT. INTERLINKING THE
COURT WITH THE CONDITIONS ARE A
MINIMUM RATE WE WERE THAT IT
10% OF THE FUNDING BE USED FOR
TECH ASSISTANCE GRANTS. TO
ENSURE CONTINUED CAPACITY
BUILDING AND ENGAGEMENT OF
IMPACTED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND CLINICAL
INFORMATION. AND ONLY 30% OF
THE FUNDING GO TO PROJECT THE
PROTECTING HIM WATER INCLUDING
IDENTIFYING THE IMPACT OF THE
PLANS. ON COMMUNITY DRINKING
WATER AND IMPLEMENTING.
MITIGATION PROGRAM ZERO THREE
POINT TURN OF. IDENTIFYING THE
IMPACT OF THE PLANS ON
COMMUNITY DRINKING WATER THIS
HAS TO BE DONE BY OBTAINING
COMPLETE INFORMATION ABOUT ALL
DRINKING WATER USERS LOCATION
AND WHILE THAT. AND ENSURING
THAT GST MODELLING WILL SHOW
THE IMPACT OF POLICY DECISIONS
AND ACTIVITIES ON DRINKING
WATER USERS. THERE WAS
DISCUSSION EARLIER TODAY AROUND
URGENCY AND WHETHER THE FUNDING
SHOULD QUALIFY AS EARLY ACTION.
AND THERE ARE URGENT AND
IMPLICATIONS FOR THAT- THANK
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET HEARING AND
ANALYSIS OF THE PLANS EVERY
MONTH OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
DEMONSTRATED THAT. FAR FROM
PROTECTING THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
WATER THE CURRENT GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS. WOULD
RESULT IN AS MANY AS- ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND PEOPLE LOSING THEIR
DRINKING WATER SUPPLY AND
PERSONABLE CONDITIONS. EVEN IN
THE BEST CASE SCENARIO TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF TWELVE EXPECTED TO
GO DRY. AND SOME ALREADY HAVE
BEEN REPORTED. IT'S UNKNOWN-
THE CURRENT PLANS WILL COST
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS MEDICAID.
MEDICATE DUE TO THINKING NO
LONGER IN ON VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES PRETTY. LOW INCOME
OF COLOR WE THEREFORE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THE
FUNDING AND EARMARKED
SUBSTANTIAL PORTIONS OF IT WERE
CRITICAL DRINKING WATER
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BYE BYE OUR NECKS. MY
NUMBER FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'D LIKE
TO THANK MEMBERS OF THE CENTER
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND BUILDING
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE JUST
WITH THE WILDFIRES THAT
AFFECTED COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. HI MY NAME'S KEVIN JUST
FALLING ON THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF TREAT PEOPLE LAND TRUST IN
REGARD TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
TWO WE PLOT THE AUGMENTATION TO
HOME PARTNERS. AT OPR FUNDS
THAT ARE INTENDED BEFORE SCHOOL
FOR PROJECTS SUCH AS OUR WILD
FIRES GOING CELIBATE
HEADQUARTERS CORNER. WE WALKED
OUR OFFICE MEDICATION WITH THE
WITH THE OLD PART TWENTY
SIXTEEN I TRULY BELIEVE THAT
REBUILDING THE FIGHT OVER WHO'S
GOING SEVEN ABOUT FOLKS LONG
COMMUNITY COULD BECOME A MALL
ACROSS BUT SIR. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR ACTIONS.
THANK YOU THE EX. LINE NUMBER
FIVE YOUR LINE IS PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT'S IS STACEY
OF THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AT FIRST LIKE TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY Q. OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR MEMBERSHIP
BEING AURORA CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES WITH A LOT OF FORESTED
LAND LOCATED WITHIN OUR
BOUNDARIES. AND WE OBVIOUSLY
SUPPORT MORE MONEY GOING OUT
AND EARLIER THE BETTER FOR
WILDFIRE SEASON BEGINS AND
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT THE FUNDING GET ON THE
GROUND AS SOON AS HUMANLY
POSSIBLE- I DON'T LIKE TO SPEAK
TO ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY ONE AND
SAY THAT WE WOULD SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED. FOR SIXTY
NINE DOLLARS TO ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND SUSTAINABLE
GROUNDWATER AGENCIES WITH THE
CRITICAL PLANNING WORK THEY ARE
CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING THE
STIGMA. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NECKS. LIE NUMBER TWELVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR JERRY CANS
MARKET YOUR MAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AND WATERSHED RESEARCH AND
TRAINING CENTER. I THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
THIS COMMENT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUBCOMMITTEE'S
WORK AND THIS PROPOSAL ON ITEM
THIRTY TWO. ALLOCATE MORE
FUNDING IN EARLY ACTION MAY
KNOWLEDGE MEANT THAT WE NEED TO
ACT QUICKLY AND WE SUPPORT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATION. WE DO
WANT TO ECHO W. SECRETARY
MORSE'S COMMENT ABOUT THE
BENEFIT OF SPEED IN GETTING
THIS MONEY OUT THE DOOR QUICKLY.
BUT WE CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE TIME WE HAVE NOW. I WISH I
WANT TO COME OUT THE FUNDING
FOR HOME HARDING I WOULD HAVE
TO BUILD FIRE ADAPTED
COMMUNITIES. BEING AFTER SHE
WIRED WILDFIRE RESILIENCE FROM
HOMES TO COMMUNITIES TO OUR
NATURAL LANDSCAPES. AND LASTLY.
I WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION REGARDING THE
ARCHITECT SHE- DIRECTIONS PROBE
PROPOSALS WILL BE IMMINENT
MINISTRATION COMMENTS. ABOUT
THE INTERPLAY BETWEEN LOCAL AND
REGIONAL ACTORS STATE PROGRAMS.
I WERE READY AND EAGER TO
CONTINUE THEIR WORK. THE WORK
BUILDING REGIONAL STRATEGIES
INFLUENCING. THAT CERTAINLY
NEEDED WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
PROJECTS. THANK YOU. SO MUCH I
THANK YOU NEXT. LINEUP SIX YOUR
LINE IS ALL. SIX ZERO. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AMANDA
MONACO I WORK WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE WORKED
ALONGSIDE- ABOUT THIRTY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ON
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY ON
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ISSUES. I
WANTED TO QUICKLY MAKE COMMENTS
ON THREE ISSUES VERY FUN ISSUE
THIRTEEN ON THE CLIMATE
VULNERABILITY AND ADAPTATION
STRATEGY FOR SAN JOAQUIN BASIN
WATERSHED. WE WANTED TO NOTE
THAT WE SUPPORT THE STRATEGY
AND HOPE THAT IT WILL PRIMARILY
BENEFIT COMMUNITIES WITH LITTLE
TO NO INFRASTRUCTURE. OR FLOOD
CONTROL IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
WE WORK WITH MANY RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY IN. HE EVENTUALLY
COUNTY THE PRODUCT THAT'S NEAT
REPEATEDLY- REGARDING ISSUE
TWENTY SEVEN HELD HIM OVER
STATE. WE NOTE THAT COMMUNITY
HEALTH AND SAFETY HAVE PAID THE
PRICE OF OIL AND GAS FURNACE
BEING APPROVED WITHOUT A PROPER
REVIEW BY THE DEPARTMENT. HELLO
JIM OVERSIGHT IS LONG OVERDUE
AND YOU COULD COUNTERACT THE
EFFECTIVELY UNCHECKED EXPANSION
OF OIL AND GAS EIGHT. LASTLY
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW REMARKS
ON THE ISSUE THIRTEEN REGARDING
STIGMA IMPLEMENTATION OF A
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR BUDGET FOR
THAT- I'D LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH. A STATEMENT FROM
THE COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
SELF HELP ENTERPRISES. WE
REQUEST THAT AT LEAST 10% OF
THE FUNDING TO BE USED FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE GRANTS FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. AND AT
LEAST 30% HONEYCUTT PROJECT.
THINKING WATER. THEY'RE SEVERE
ISSUES WITH YES HE'S A
CURRENTLY WRITTEN. AND THEY
WOULD ALLOW CONTINUED PUMPING
AT THE EXPENSE OF DRINKING
WATER CRISES IN THOUSANDS THE
FAMILY HOME. NOTHING
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY. IF YOU
ARE DEALING WITH A LOT OF
COMPETING INTERESTS HERE BUT AS
WE ALL KNOW- OUR PRIMARY GOAL
IS TO PROTECT THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO WATER IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE
NEED TO GUARANTEE THAT SO- SOME
CHANGES TO THE FUNDING
STRUCTURE OF THAT SIXTY MILLION
WOULD REALLY SUPPORT THE THAT
WE AREN'T PROTECTING DRINKING
WATER. BY ENSURING THAT FUNDING
IS DEDICATED TO CONTINUE
CAPACITY. BUILDING FOR
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT. AND PLANS
IDENTIFY AND- DRINK WATER IN
INFORM DRUG WATER MANY. THANK
YOU NECKS. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU HELLO TERRY
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PRETTY BAD AT THE ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA BUSINESS COUNCIL AND THE
PIER CONSORTIUM ON IT THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE POWERFUL WORK BEING PUT
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE THROUGH ITEM THIRTY
TWO. PARTICULARLY THROUGH THE
SIERRA NEVADA IN CALIFORNIA
TAHOE CONSERVANCY I'D LIKE TO
REITERATE THE NEED FOR URGENCY
TO GET DOLLARS ON THE GROUND AS
ANOTHER DRY WINTER LEAVES THE
COMING WILDFIRE SEASON- WHILE
ALSO REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
CONSIDERATION OF THE CLINIC
CATALYST FUND. THAT EARLY
ACTION FUNDING TO SUPPORT
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN
INNOVATIVE WILDFIRE PREVENTION
STRATEGIES WILL HELP HELP WHEN
YOU REAP THE BENEFITS AND
PROTECTIONS OF THE PROJECT ALL
THE DINNER. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. LINER FORTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS USUALLY GARINGER WILL
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IMPORT SQ ITEM.
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE I CAN
PULL VERY STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
PROPERTY HOW TO BIND OR USED
FOR THE VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT.
AND ALSO ONLINE ISSUE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE RELATING TO THE KING
OF ALL GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM FUNDING WE SUPPORT
THIRTY MILLION IN EARLY ACTION
DOLLARS AND THIRTY MILLION FOR
THAT. TWENTY ONE TO REACH YOU I
CAN'T HEAR THANK YOU. MY THERE
ANY OTHER PEOPLE ON THE PHONE.
AT THIS TIME OF YEAR WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. GET MY MASCOT
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE PUBLIC HEARING AND BRING
THE MATTER BACK TO THE- THE
COMMITTEE FIVE. WE HAVE. ON OUR
FOOD ONLY CALENDAR- THE CHAIR
WILL- ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
ISSUES NUMBER. THREE FOUR SIX
SEVEN EIGHT NINE. TWELVE
THROUGH NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND TWENTY FOUR
SENATOR DOLLY DO YOU HAVE SUCH
A MOTION. SOME OF. BUSH'S BEEN
MADE ON THOSE ISSUES. THAT'S
RIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MY
CASKEY HI KELLY- MISFIRE. STERN
RIGHT I I'M SORRY I HAVE TO
RIDICULOUSLY I SEE SENATOR
STERN. NINE OKAY STERN I COULD
WE PLEASE REPEAT QUITE CASKEY
AND DOLLY I HAVE TO SAY THE
WHITE HOUSE SKI HI I. CASKEY I.
DOLLY I STERN I WAS BEFORE
THANK YOU OKAY WE GET THAT
TECHNOLOGY- ARE NOW ON ISSUES
NUMBER TEN ELEVEN AND TWENTY
ONE CENTER STORE AND WE HAVE A
MOTION. SO MOVED. MY CASKEY
QUITE CASKEY HI MY CASKET HI
DOLLY DOLLY NO DOLLY NOW
REQUIRE. STERN GARDAI STERN
STERN I WILL KEEP THE KEEP THAT
MATTER OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. NOW WE HAVE A MOTION
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE IN
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN-
STERN YOU HAVE TO LOOK. MOTION
BY SENATOR STERN. MY CASKEY BY
CAL SKI BY. DAWALY SEES ME WHY
CASKEY I DOLLY. THE ONLY NOT
VOTING REQUIRE. STERN STERN I
STERN I WILL KEEP THAT MATTER
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS NOW
MOVING TOWARD DISCUSSION
CALENDAR WE HAD- WE HAD ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX WHICH IS THE
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCIES STATE
LANDS COMMISSION DELTA
PROTECTION COMMISSION SAN DIEGO
RIVER CONSERVANCY. THE W. R.
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE
FUND THE- A RELATED PROPOSAL
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION IS TO
APPROVE- ITEMS B. E. N. F. BUT
KEEP OPEN ITEMS A C. AND D. IT
MIGHT GO THERE'S A MOTION BY
SENATOR DOLLY ON THAT- SPLIT
STAFF RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
CALL ROLE IN THIS ROLE. MY
CASKEY WHITE CASKET BY MY
CASKEY HI DOLLY. SORRY HI
REQUIRE STERN AND I. STERN I
OKAY WE'LL KEEP THAT MATTER
OPEN FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS IN
FILING HAVE ISSUE NUMBER THIRTY
TWO THE SUBCOMMITTEE TO
PROPOSAL- WIRE FOR EARLY ACTION
ON WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND
RESILIENCY PLAN SENATOR STERN
YOU HAVE A MOTION. I DO I HAVE
A MOTION AND- ISSUE THIRTY TWO
TWO- AUGMENTS- STRAIN OF MONICA
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY FUNDING
TO BRING IT TO PARITY WITH THE
SAN GABRIEL AND LOWER LA RIVERS
AND MOUNTAIN FUNDING. ENTER
PROVE THE REST OF THE- ENJOY
THE CREW OF THE REST OF THE-
ISSUE. OKAY WE HAVE A PROMOTION
AS MODIFIED TO APPROVE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROPOSAL. RIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MY CASKEY
HI WHY CASKEY FIVE. THIS REPORT
IN ORDER. SO I WANNA MAKE SURE
I UNDERSTAND SO- CENTERS TURN.
AS AMENDED THIS MOTION BUT WE
DIDN'T TAKE THAT AS A SEPARATE
ACTION WEEK WE'RE TAKING IT ALL
IN ONE ACTION. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE WE CAN TAKE IT AS YOU SAID
NO I'M I'M SUPPORTIVE OF IT I
DON'T CARE BUT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE IT WOULD NOT DOING
THINGS OUT OF. NORMALLY WOULD
DO. THE MINUTES. SEPARATE AND
THEN GO BACK AND- DO THE
REGULAR MOTION BUT I FOUGHT IF
IT'S OKAY IF IT'S- IF IT'S-
OKAY SO MR STERN WE WILL VERY.
VICE CHAIR GOOD POINT WE WILL
FIRST TAKE A MOTION ON THE
AMENDMENT THAT MR STERN IS
PROPOSING TO. BRING THE
CONSERVANCY IN SANTA MONICA UP
UP TO THE FUNDING LEVEL SAID
SANTA GABRIEL'S DO YOU HAVE
SUCH A MOTION. SO MOVED HI THIS
ARE THE AMENDMENT TO THIS CITY
THE PROPOSAL BY THE- US UP TO
OKAY PLEASE CALL RULE ON THE
AMENDMENT. CASKEY ALL RIGHT THE
CASKET HI DOLLY HI NATALIE I
REQUIRE. STERN RIGHT YOU'RE
NOT. THE MATTER ON THE
AMENDMENT OPEN NOW THE ISSUE
NUMBER THIRTY TWO IN CHIEF
CENTER STERN DO YOU HAVE A
MOTION SO MOVED. OKAY THERE'S A
MOTION TO APPROVE THE. THE
ENTIRE- PROPOSAL OR ISSUE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CASKEY BY
CASKEY HI CASKEY I DALI HI
HOLLY I REQUIRE. THIRD I. OKAY
STERN I THINK VERY MUCH START
SORRY BOUT THE CARQUINEZ THAT
PROCEDURAL FIVE CALL WE WILL
KEEP MATTERS OPEN SENTIMENT
CHOIR IS AT A LEADERSHIP.
MEETING AND HAS TO COME BACK
BUT THE REST OF THE MEMBERS I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS THIS IS.
THE LAST SCHEDULED HEARING THAT
WE HAVE SO WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING ELSE ON THE SCHEDULE I
PRESUME THAT WE MAY BE MEETING.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IN
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
HI INPUT TODAY- AND THE
THOUGHTFULNESS OF PEOPLE
PRODUCTS. HI AND WE WILL PAUSE
FOR REQUIRE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
THANK YOU TO YOUR STAFF.
SORRY
OKAY BACK ON THE M. FIVE THE
RECORD THIS IS A- THE MOTION ON
THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR OF
ISSUES. THREE FOUR SIX SEVEN
EIGHT NINE. TWELVE THROUGH
NINETEEN N. ISSUES TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSA MEMBERS PLAN
RIGHT. FOUR ZERO THE VOTE IS
FOUR ZERO THOSE MATTERS ARE
APPROVED ON. ISSUES THE MOTION
ISSUES TEN ELEVEN AND TWENTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE OPTION
MEMBERS CHOIR HI. LARRY I AM.
THREE ONE CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU
VOTED THREE TO ONE THOSE
MOTIONS ARE PROVED AND FINALLY
ON THE PHONE ONLY CALENDAR
ISSUES ONE TO. FIVE AND TWENTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
REQUIRE. REQUIRE HIGH WHOSE
ROLE TALLY THE VOTES THREE ZERO
THREE ZERO THE THOSE MATTERS
ARE PROOF THEY'LL ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX WE HAD THE MOTION
BEFORE US WAS TO APPROVE THE
BUDGETED ITEMS UNDER B. E. L.
F. BUT HOLD OPEN. AT THE BUDGET
ITEMS ON A- C. D. THAT'S RIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSA MEMBERS.
THE CHOIR RIGHT THE CHOIR I
CLOSE REAL TELL YOU BOTH THREE
ZERO. DOES THAT MATTER IS
APPROVED FOUR ZERO ON SEPT AND
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THREE WE
HAD A AN AMENDMENT BY SENATOR
STERN TO AMEND. THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROPOSAL TO BRING
PARITY BETWEEN SAN GABRIEL AND
SANTA MONICA CONSERVANCY PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE OF MEMBERS. I
DON'T THINK MEANT IT. YEAH WE
DO THE AMENDMENT. YEAH THIS IS
THE THIS IS ON THE AMENDMENT
ONLY. THE CLAN HI. CLOSE TO
RELY ONLY. REQUIRE HI FOUR ZERO
OKAY REQUIRE FIVE FOUR ZERO ALL
OF THE AMENDMENT NOW THE ISSUE
BEEN CHIEF ON THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE'S PROPOSAL PLEASE
CALL THE ABSA MEMBERS REQUIRE I
REQUIRE HI WHOSE ROLE TELL YOU
TO VOTE FOUR ZERO FOUR ZERO IT
MATTERS APPROVED. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ALL RIGHT THAT
CONCLUDES OUR- BASE WORK
TODAY'S HEARING WE HAVE NO
OTHER SCHEDULE HEARINGS AT THIS
TIME- ALTHOUGH A LOT OF
INTEREST IN HAVING EARLY ACTION
SO WE'RE JR.